[Musique]
Florian Philippo, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Oui. Donc
je suis donc Florient Philippo. Je suis
né en 1981 dans une famille euh
d'enseignants de l'école publique dans
le nord de la France, dans le
département du nord d'ailleurs euh où
j'ai grandi et je suis arrivé pour mes
études à Paris, j'avais 17 ans. Euh j'ai
fait mes études,
j'ai fait HC, enfin une prépa puis HC
puis l'ENA. Euh, j'étais ensuite au
ministère de l'intérieur et j'ai rejoint
assez vite en fait ce qui était vraiment
le bah le la base de de ce qui me
motivait, c'est-à-dire le service de la
France. J'ai toujours été intéressé par
la politique et par le l'idée de de
vouloir servir mon pays. Donc assez
rapidement, je me suis réorienté après
être sorti de l'ENAT, travaillé au
ministère de l'intérieur, je me suis
réorienté vers la politique d'abord au
Front National comme il s'appelait à
l'époque. Enfin, j'avais d'ailleurs fait
campagne pour Jean-Pierre Chevinement
puisque je suis souverainiste. Et puis à
l'époque au Front National quand le
parti était beaucoup plus souverainiste
que maintenant, peut-être qu'on en
reparlera comme vous voulez. Et ensuite,
j'ai quitté ce mouvement quand il a
abandonné certaines idées et j'ai fondé
en septembre 2017 Les Patriotes qui est
un parti politique que je préside
aujourd'hui. Euh voilà donc on arrive en
2024 dans cette situation là.
Vous faisiezco ministère de l'intérieur.
J'étais à l'inspection générale de
l'administration. Alors l'IGA c'est une
des trois inspections générales
interministiales de l'État. Il y a l'IGF
qui est très connu. Un certain Emmanuel
Macron y est passé. Euh il y a l'IGAS,
affaire sociale et il y a l'IGA donc euh
qui est la plus ancienne de toutes qui a
été fondée je crois euh avant la
Révolution française hein euh au 18e
siècle et qui s'occupe d'inspecter les
préfets, les sous-préfets et puis toutes
les politiques relatives à la sécurité,
la sécurité civile,
voilà ministère de l'intérieur et puis
assez souvent on est sur des missions
interministériales donc qui m'est arrivé
de travailler aussi avec d'autres
d'autres inspections sur des
problématiques plus sociales relatives à
la santé. J'ai fait un gros rapport sur
la gestion des crises par exemple qui
m'avait amené à à travailler bien avant
le Covid sur comment préparer une grosse
épidémie. C'est intéressant et puis
faire une rétrospective de la première
là qui avait été amorcée en 2009 sous
Roseline Bachelow le H1N1 à l'époque
quand on avait acheté pour rien un
milliard d'euros de de vaccin et puis
bah pour rien parce qu'il y avait eu 400
cas en France.
On avait acheté 1 milliard d'euros de
vaccin pour rien et ça avait été un gros
scandale.
À l'époque, vous aviez des rapport qui
était sortis, des commissions d'enquête
parlementaire et ce rapport que j'ai
cosigné de l'IGA qui avait fait un
diagnostic, je crois, assez juste qui
malheureusement n'a pas du tout été
repris lorsqu'il s'est agit d'affronter
le Covid en 2020.
C'était quoi le diagnostic ? Bah, le
diagnostic que euh
il faut éviter de paniquer dans les
crises en fait et en particulier quand
il y a euh une épidémie ou un virus, la
peur est probablement ce qui a le plus
mauvais.
C'est ce c'est vous savez, on dit
souvent la peur est mauvaise conseillère
ou mauvais conseiller. C'est c'est le
cas. et et on avait quand même écrit ça
en le justifiant, en disant ça vous
amène à prendre des décisions qui ne
sont pas rationnelles, qui panique les
population, qui dégradent les finances
publiques parce que ça coûte cher euh et
qui ne sont à postériori pas justifié.
Et pourtant, boum, on est retombé
là-dedans en bien pire en 2020 quand un
certain Covid-19 est arrivé.
Vous parlez vous parlez Covid-19, je
comptais pas commencer là-dessus mais on
va commencer làdessus. On parlera
d'Emmanuel Macron juste après.
Euh la peur est mauvaise conseillère
certes. Euh on fait une expérience de
pensée entre nous. D'accord.
Vous avez des un ambassadeur monsieur
Judi Jordi. Comment il s'appelle
l'ambassadeur de France de l'époque en
Chine ?
Aucune idée. Ouais.
Qui donne l'alerte un 31 janvier ou
2019 ? ou un un 29 janvier ou quelque
chose comme ça.
Euh non, on a eu l'alerte fin 2019 déjà.
Oui, c'est ça. Décembre 2019, il donne
l'alerte. Bon, ça devait être la trève
des confiseurs, ils étaient peut-être
pas prêts. Euh ils connectent les
choses, ils se disent "Bon, on a
construit des labos français là-bas.
Hm.
On connaît les Chinois par rapport à
leur capacité à euh leur vie, pardon. On
on connaît le on connaît le les
capacités des Chinois à faire ce qu'ils
veulent quand ils veulent où ils veulent
ou des choses comme ça.
On savait que il travaillait sur les
coronavirus.
On voyait que les capacités de la France
à pouvoir encaisser ce type de maladie
aéroportée, manuporté avec des degrés de
rémanence sur les surfaces relativement
importantes.
On a vu notre stock de masque. On a dit
bon les masques, ça sert pas à
grand-chose. On a dit aux pharmaciens si
vous vendez des masques, attention c'est
10000 € d'amende. Est-ce que la panique
venait du fait que un on était en short
en terme de de de préanticipation,
en terme de structure ?
en terme de matériel, en terme de chaîne
logistique et comme c'était un
laboratoire relativement compliqué, que
ce soit un P3 ou un P4,
qu'on a peut-être pas gobé tout de suite
l'histoire du pangolin, euh ça ça leur a
fait peut-être un peu peur.
Donc la question c'est on a surréagi
parce que on est avec une
préconnaissance de potentielle
fuite accident industriel
où on avait peur parce que on savait
qu'on était en short pour une manué
reporté.
Comment ça se passe ? Ben moi, je peux
vous dire comment ça s'est passé parce
que j'étais à l'époque comme président
de parti politique invité à toutes les
réunions de crise. À l'époque, c'était
monsieur euh Verrand euh qui remplaçait
Agnè Busin, ministre de la santé et il
se trouve qu'ils invitent euh on a
régressé démocratiquement depuis hein
parce que maintenant on n'est plus
invité mais à l'époque ils invitaient
des présidents de parti politique aux
Réunion au ministère de la santé
avant le conseil de défense.
Ah oui oui oui. Euh tout début on a
commencé en février 2020. Moi j'ai été
invité au ministère de la santé puis
même à Matignon.
Euh ensuite quand j'ai commencé à poser
des questions un peu gênantes, j'ai été
évacué.
Quel type de questions gênante ?
Euh c'est un petit peu plus tard quand
je leur ai dit. Par exemple, je me
souviens très bien d'un jour, il y avait
Castex premier ministre et Verand
ministre de la santé. On était dans une
très grande salle
en au ministère de la santé, donc avenue
de Séure et et je leur dis "Est-ce que
vous êtes allé voir ce qui se passe en
Suède ?" Mais ça c'était avant juste
avant c un petit peu plus tard. C'est
juste avant le deuxème confinement, donc
c'était l'automne 2020. Je leur dis,
"Est-ce que vous êtes allé voir en Suède
?" Parce que là-bas, ils n'ont jamais
fait de confinement. Ils n'ont jamais
imposé le masque obligatoire, ils n'ont
pas fait de de enfin de tout ce qu'on a
fait ici. Et pourtant, il se trouve que
ça se passe plutôt bien et qu' leurs
courbes sont en train de passer sous les
nôtres en terme de mortalité. Et je me
souviens très bien qu'à ce moment-là,
Olivier Verrand me répond "Non, c'est
faux. Il c'est le pays où il y a le plus
de mortalité au monde. Et là, j'ai
Castex à côté qui fait comme ça. Il
parle pas mais vous savez comme le petit
le petit chiot à l'arrière des voitures
avec la tête qui fait comme ça.
Comparaison pareil.
Non mais elle est gentille la
comparaison. Elle est pas elle est pas
dénigrante de la tête.
Mais ce qui m'a vraiment fait penser en
temps réel à ça. C'est pour ça que je
vous dis ça. C'est pas c'est pas
dénigrant dans ma bouche mais il dodit
de la tête effectivement. Exactement. Et
donc je lui dis, j'avais les chiffres
officiels sous le sous les yeux que le
monde sortait le classement tous les
jours de de la mor le classement entre
guillemets la mortalité en Europe et
dans le monde. Et je dis non c'est pas
vrai c'est alors alors Verrand dit non
vous avez raison c'est pas dans le monde
mais en Europe. Je dis même pas on est
passé devant la Belgique aussi l'Italie
aussi l'Espagne aussi. Non non non c'est
impossible et cetera. Je suis dit
"Écoutez, vous devriez envoyer une
mission française pour voir ce qui se
passe là-bas parce que je trouve ça
intéressant." Mais au tout début, si je
reviens quelques mois en avant, donc en
février 2020, moi je savais pas
honnêtement, vous voyez euh j'ai été
assez vite dans le combat pour les
libertés.
On a organisé toutes les manifestations
qu'on a organisé. On a été très choqué
et moi je suis personnellement très
choqué de ce qui s'est passé à ce
moment-là. On s'en est toujours pas
remis d'ailleurs hein, que notre pays
accepte un instrument comme le pass
sanitaire et le pass vaccinal,
c'est-à-dire la rupture du secret
médical et l'obligation de de de prouver
que vous avez fait un test médical ou un
vaccin pour pouvoir prendre un café sur
une terrasse ou aller à votre salle de
sport ou garder votre boulot, ça c'est
encore pire parce que moi j'ai eu tous
les samedis dans les bras des
infirmières, des pompiers en pleur,
enfin c'était quelque chose
d'humainement absolument terrible et du
point de vue des principes qui m'a
beaucoup choqué. Euh mais
alors qu'il y en a alors qu'il y en a
qui faisait bamboche à côté de la la rue
la rue des Numismates là, comment ça
s'appelle ?
Vivienne.
Vous vous rappelez monsieur qui qui aime
bien cultiver ?
Oui, mais c'est pas le pire Pierre Jean
Chalançon. Mais c'est pas c'est pas le
c'est pas le pire parce que parce que
lui à la limite il faisait resto
clandestin. Enfin donc à la limite resto
clandestin, j'ai rien contre eux parce
que moi ce qui m'embêtait plus c'était
les fêtes dans les ministères
où c'était monsieur Baou qui avait été
pris en photo à Orle à l'aéroport sans
masque au moment où le masque était
obligatoire et où on venait embêter les
autres passagers en leur demandant de
mettre le masque au-dessus du nez par en
dessous. Bon et et en réalité à cette
époque-là, au tout début, moi je vais
dire au tout début on a de la part du
ministère de la santé des discours
alarmistes.
On ne sait pas ce que c'est.
On voit la Chine puis l'Italie.
Souvenez-vous le premier pays en dehors
de la Chine qui a fait des confinements,
c'est l'Italie qui ont commencé à
confin.
On nous dit que c'est un taux de
mentalité entre 3 et 4 % ce qui est
énorme ce qui à la fin Dieu merci ne
sera pas le casin. On n pas du tout à 3
4 % sur le Covid mais au départ on nous
dit ça. On voit même des vidéos
souvenez-vous qui circulent sur les
réseaux sociaux avec des gens qui
tombent par terre en Chine. On comprend
pas ce qui se passe. Enfin c'est c'est
c'est c'est Walking Dead si vous voulez.
C'est c'est vraiment la la série
catastrophe sur Netflix hein. Euh et
donc au début bah on fait plutôt
confiance. Moi, j'ai pas de raison de
penser que on va nous emmener vers
quelque chose de délirant qui va durer 3
ans.
Donc au début, je fais plutôt confiance.
J'écoute, je prends l'information.
Monsieur Delfi vient dans ses réunions
qui était le responsable du conseil
scientifique qui a été créé au mois de
mars parce qu'il y a eu plusieurs
réunions. Euh voilà. Donc au début, je
suis assez
suiviste entre guillemets. On me dit le
confinement va durer 2 semaines et ce
sera efficace. Pourquoi pas ? C'est pas
non plus dramatique de se confin
semaines si vraiment c'est efficace.
Je peux je peux vous interrompre ?
Oui.
Donc à l'époque, vous étiez sous le
robinet de l'information
gouvernementale.
Oui.
Et vous avez pas cherché à vous informer
par votre propre réseau ?
Si. Mais j'avais pas d'information
particulière.
D'accord. Le le Vous aviez des contacts
sur place ?
Non, pas du tout.
Vous aviez des copains, des amis qui
étaient épidémologistes, virologues,
spécialisé dans les maladies défectuses
tropicales ?
Pas Non, pas à ce momentlà.
D'accord. Vous avez étudié les mesures ?
deux terrains des Chinois avec les
points de contrôle, les analyses de de
d'eau usée, la construction d'hôpitaux.
Ouais, bien sûr.
Vous aviez vous aviez ça à porter de
main ou pas du tout ?
Non. Alors, au tout départ,
c'est pour ça que vous vous êtes mis
sous le robinet du gouvernement.
Bah au tout départ, c'est une maladie
qu'on ne connaît pas euh voilà qui
arrive et on nous dit ça mais
extrêmement vite. Je vais vous dire
qu'on ne connaît pas chez l'homme
ou
ou qu'on ne connaît pas chez la
chauve-souris.
Non non qu'on ne connaît pas chez
l'homme. Non non les coronavirus de
toute façon les coronavirus il y en a
plein. C'est une famille de virus.
Bon ce SARSCOV 1 ou je sais pas combien
de c'est ça ? Ou on SARSCOV 2 c'est ça ?
On le connaît pas chez l'homme. On nous
dit il est très mortel, il est très
dangereux, il faut faire comme ça. Au
tout début, je vais vous dire moi, vous
voyez, c'est la preuve que je suis pas
un complotiste, contrairement à ce que
certains vous vouzent faire croire,
mais un complotiste, ça serait de de
tout remettre en cause par principe.
C'est pas mon cas. Moi au départ, j'ai
des autorités savantes que je n'ai pas
de raison de de remettre en cause au
tout début qui me disent ça. Bon,
pourquoi pas ? Donc ça c'est les les
premiers jours, les premières semaines
et puis on nous dit il y a tout ce
cafouillage que vous avez rappelé, les
masques ne servent à rien puis a du jour
au lendemain, ils servent à rien. Avec
quand même une porte-parole à l'époque
Sibat and Dire qui nous dit "On sait pas
euh moi je sais pas comment mettre un
masque. Souvenez-vous de cette séquence
et de mentir pour protéger le chef
d'état." C'est ce qu'elle a dit ensuite.
Et ensuite, on nous dit par contre
quasiment du jour au lendemain, on passe
de ça ne sert à rien à il faut le mettre
partout, y compris quand vous êtes seul
en forêt sur la plage et on va commencer
à voir ces photos et ces vidéos où la
police vient vous contrôler sur la plage
euh pour vérifier que vous avez bien le
masque. Alors vous êtes seul sur une
plage très aérée dans une forêt et là je
me dis il y a un truc qui cloche quoi.
Et puis aussi, il y a un truc qui m'a
très qui m'a très vite choqué, c'est
c'est le sort qui a été réservé au
traitement. Très vite. On nous a dit
avant avant d'aborder les traitements,
on continue l'expérience de pensée, vous
et moi. Oui, bien sûr.
Imaginez-vous, vous avez un état en
panique parce que il lui arrive d'un
autre canal de renseignement que
peut-être que c'est un un accident
industriel et que le fait de laisser
balader des gens en forêt, ça peut aussi
créer des foyers sur la faune locale de
forêt.
Non. Ouais,
imaginez-vous ça, c'est que on a vu on a
vu des servidés choper le coronavirus,
on a vu le chat
choper le coronavirus. Ils sont
peut-être dit dans leur flip, merde, si
dans la forêt de Fontainebleu, de Mot de
Vincen ou quoi que ce soit, il y a un
foyer qui mute,
merde, protégeons les petits oiseaux et
les petits servidés pour éviter de se
retrouver avec un foyer mutant. Oui,
c'est ça reste une expérience de pensée,
mais est-ce que c'est logique pour vous
? Est-ce que ça peut expliquer leur
panique ?
Non, mais d'abord, ils ne l'ont pas
argumenté comme ça en temps réel. Donc,
on a la preuve que c'est pas ce qu'il
pensait, sinon il se serait pas privé de
le dire. Non, non, je pense que très
vite, on a basculé dans un une gestion
qui s'est approchée d'un contrôle social
où on voit bien qu'on était plus du tout
dans la science. On a moi ce qui vous
savez ce qui m'a vite ce qui m'a mis la
puce à l'oreille extrêmement vite dès la
fin du mois de mars on va dire 2020.
Donc on était dans le confinement hein
surtout qu'on avait le temps pendant le
confinement de regarder de se
renseigner. Bon et ce qui m'a mis la
puce à l'oreille extrêmement vite c'est
l'irrationalité. C'est-à-dire que moi,
je suis un garçon logique et je veux
bien accepter à peu près tout. Mais il
faut que ça reste logique. Il faut que
ça reste si vous voulez euh A implique
B, non B implique non A. Vous voyez ce
que je veux dire ? Moi j'ai j'ai je suis
un garçon et j'ai besoin de de que ce
soit reste ça ça reste extrêmement
logique sinon ça me fait peur.
Logique selon votre clé de lecture ?
Non la vraie logique, la pure logique.
Il faut que ça reste logique. Quand un à
un moment il décide un couvre-feu parce
qu'avant les confinements enfin il y a
eu les confinements puis ensuite il y a
eu avant même le pass, il y a eu d'abord
des couvre-feux. Souvenez-vous c'était
très compliqué. Il y avait des
couvre-feu dans certaines villes, puis
dans toutes les villes, c'était d'abord
18 21h puis 20h, puis 18h. Enfin, tout
le monde a oublié, c'est normal. Mais il
y a eu plein plein d'étapes différente.
À un moment, on avait une étude qui
avait montré qu'il y avait autant de
contamination dans les villes sous
couvre-feu que les villes hors
couvre-feu.
Donc moi, j'interroge ça.
Quelle était votre explication ? Alors,
c'est que le couvre-feu ne servait
strictement à rien.
Et pourquoi donc ?
Parce que vous n'arrêtez pas un virus
comme ça.
Parce que les gens se contaminent
autrement. Mais oui et et vous avez
assez vite le professeur Raoul qui a
sorti cette étude que j'ai vérifié qui
une étude qui a eu lieu en Espagne et
une autre en Italie qui a montré que en
fait le confinement n'avait rien changé
au taux de contamination parce qu'en
fait les quand vous vous confinez une
personne contaminée avec trois personnes
non contaminées euh dans un appartement
à la fin tout le monde est contaminé.
Donc en fait autant laisser les gens
dehors si vous voulez
c'est aéroporté ça passe par la la
l'aération de la salle de bain. C'est ça
par exemple. Mais vous avez sur les
couvre-feux, je me souviens très bien,
l'étude pour démontrer que parce que il
fallait quand même démontrer que c'était
efficace. Donc on allait tordre la
science et tordre la logique. Donc il y
avait les mêmes chiffres dans les villes
non confinées, les villes non couvre-feu
et les villes souscouvre-feu. Mais pour
démontrer que c'était quand même
efficace, il nous avait pondu cet
argument et je vous assure que c'est
vrai. C'est un document officiel du
ministère de la santé. Il y a eu une
résonance de l'information sur le
couvre-feu dans les villes qui ne sont
pas soumises au couvre-feu.
Sous-entendu, les gens ayant entendu que
dans la grande ville à côté, il y avait
un couvre-feu se sont eux-mêmes mis dans
une disposition euh peut-être même
directement sous couvre-feu eux-mêmes
euh volontaire pour éviter la
contamination. Vous voyez ? Donc ils en
sont arrivés là et on est arrivé vite
vers des choses qui n'avaient plus rien
à voir avec la rationalité. Je vous ai
parlé de ce masque sur les dans les
forêts, sur les plages euh et ensuite on
a dérivé très vite vers le deuxè
confinement. Puis ce qui pour moi est
gravissime, le pass sanitaire. le pass
sanitaire qui est un instrument
qui est une rupture avec notre
civilisation, qui est une rupture
anthropologique, est une rupture avec le
secret médical, qui est une rupture avec
toutes nos libertés fondamentales euh où
elle a considéré à partir d'un moment
que une chose n'était pas obligatoire
puisqu'il n'était pas sauf pour
certaines professions, il n'était pas
obligatoire de se faire vacciner. Mais
si vous ne le faisiez pas, vous étiez
déclassés socialement en n'ayant plus le
droit de participer à certaines
activités, les restaurants, le sport, le
théâtre, le cinéma, les voyages, train,
avion et cetera. voir et c'était
dramatique pour certains leur profession
puisque je le rappelle nous avons
accepté d'être dans un pays où pendant 2
ans des des infirmières formées, des
médecins formés, des pompiers formés, je
crois pas qu'on en est trop, je crois
pas qu'on en est trop, des militaires,
des gendarmes n'ont plus été payés,
n'ont plus eu le droit de travailler,
n'ont même pas eu le droit au RSA, se
sont retrouvés sans rien. Certains me
montraient leurs fiches de pay, elles
étaient même négatives parce qu'il leur
restait des anciennes cotisations à
payer. Donc ils étaient à mo- 12 € par
mois et ça n'a posé de problème à aucun
responsable politique ou presque. Donc
moi à ce moment-là très vite, la
première manifestation qu'on avait
faite, c'était le 24 octobre 2020. J'ai
dit toutes les semaines, on sera là sous
les fenêtres de monsieur Verrand au
ministère de la santé et on dira qu'on
n'est pas d'accord. on commencera à 50
et on a commencé à 50 et on est monté
peut-être à 100000 à certaines
manifestations. Euh mais on n' pas
accepté cet état de fait.
Beaucoup de Français l'ont pas accepté.
Aujourd'hui, il y a beaucoup de gens qui
qui disent que tout ça a était
catastrophique et cetera.
Mais globalement, ce qui m'a un petit
peu inquiété et vous savez, on avait
créé un batge qui s'appelle "Je ne suis
pas un rhinocéros", référence à Yonesco,
le rhinocéros. quand il voit les gens
victimes de cette épidémie de
totalitarisme. Alors, on peut y voir le
nazisme ou d'autres choses, le fascisme
à l'époque, c'était ça. Mais mais on
peut y voir en fait, c'est universel
cette histoire. C'est-à-dire que euh il
nous s'explique comment un totalitarisme
s'introduit, se diffuse dans une société
euh où il voit des gens qui euh par
conformisme, par refus de penser, par
refus de remettre en cause quelque chose
qui les rassure, et bien entrent dans un
moule qui les amène à faire de la
délation par rapport à leurs voisins et
on en a eu beaucoup pendant le Covid. Je
vous appelle monsieur le policier parce
que mes voisins font une fête et ils
sont plus de cinq. Je vous appelle parce
que j'ai vu que tel telle ou telle
personne laissait son restaurant
manifestement derrière le la le rideau
fermé le soir ouvert pour accueillir
quelques amis alors que nous sommes sous
couvre-feu. Je vous appelle pour vous
prévenir que j'ai vu une personne dans
la rue qui n'avait pas son masque et
cetera et cetera et on est entré dans ce
genre de société et donc nous on a fait
exprès un batch qui a cartonné
d'ailleurs alors que vous voyez à la
base qui connaît Yonesco et Rhinoceros ?
pas grand monde mais on a fait un masque
un batch qui s'appelle je ne suis pas un
rhinocéros pour dire on n'accepte pas
cette société cette dérive vers une
forme de totalitarisme.
Comment vous expliquez que Macron nous
dise nous sommes en guerre ? Comment
vous expliquez qu'il classe sous le
secret défense le conseil de défense ?
Je l'explique par le fait que ces
éléments de langage ont été diffusés
dans beaucoup de pays au même moment. Il
n'est pas le seul à avoir dit qu'on
avait été en guerre parmi les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement. Il faut
jamais se comparer au derniers de la
classe.
Non, mais c'est un vous remarquerez vous
remarquerez que c'est un élément de
langage qui a été diffusé à ce moment-là
dans beaucoup de pays. Vous avez au même
moment, je crois que c'était encore R
Angela Merkel qui était chancelière
allemande, Angela Merkel qui disait à
peu près la même chose. Vous aviez
différents chefs de gouvernement et
d'État qui disaient à peu près la même
chose. Donc ces gens-là puisent leurs
sources aux mêmes éléments de gestion de
crise. et il y a des boîtes qui sont
chargées de vous aider à gérer une crise
et donc il puisent leurs sources au même
conseillers, au même cabinet de conseil.
On sait que monsieur Macron est très
friant des cabinets de conseil et donc
vous aviez cette rhtorique qui était
censée vous faire peur, donc vous rendre
obéissant. La peur, c'est quand même ce
qui amène à obéir, hein,
qui lui donnait lui un prestige
de chef de chef de guerre qu'il n'a pas
eu par ailleurs. Ça lui donnait un
prestige et ça permettait d'obtenir
l'obéissance en tout cas un temps.
C'était ça l'objectif.
La soumission.
La soumission bien sûr. L'obéissance, la
soumission. Comment vous expliquez que
la Chine est levée beaucoup plus
tardivement
ces mesures de confinement strict ou ces
ces mesures de d'encadrement de la
population ?
Je ne sais pas mais en Chine, ils sont
allés très loin dans la folie.
Souvenez-vous à un moment quand vous
deviez aller en Chine, vous aviez un
test anal.
Vous vous souvenez de ça ?
Avec un petit bâton.
Un petit bâton. Ce qui fait que c'était
pas le petit coton dans le nez, c'était
ailleurs. Ce qui fait que beaucoup de
gens d'ailleurs n'allaient plus en
Chine. C'était quand même assez logique.
Et vous vous arriviez vous conduisiez
gentiment pendant 2 semaines dans un
hôtel qui ressemblait furieusement à un
camp. À vos frais.
À vos frais. Tout à fait. Et vous
n'aviez pas le droit de quitter votre
chambre.
Alors que craignait la Chine ?
Je ne sais pas.
peut-être
une agitation sociale.
Est-ce que vous avez suivi l'histoire
des des bases ADN de virus qui qui ont
été viré d'Internet, des bases internet
chinoises ?
Non, c'est-à-dire
bah
les les la bibliothèque ADN des virus
étudié en Chine, surtout les
coronavirus,
une grosse partie a à a dégagé. Est-ce
que vous avez suivi euh euh les souches
de coronavirus en Chine qu'on peut plus
aller prélever dans certaines grottes ?
Une énorme porte blindée. Est-ce que
vous êtes renseigné sur les séquelles du
coronavirus à court, moyen et long terme
?
Quels sont les séquelles neurologiques,
hépatique et j'en passé des meilleurs ?
Est-ce que vous êtes au courant de ça ?
Je je suis un petit peu au courant mais
juste sur l'origine du virus parce qu'il
y a encore une vraie controverse
là-dessus.
Euh, il y a pas d'ailleurs de de
C'est le pangolin ou c'est l'accident
industri ?
Non, le pangolin, il a été évacué, ça
c'est certain, qui est un intermédiaire
chauve-souris d'une manière ou d'une
autre. D'une manière ou d'une autre,
oui. Soit par gain de fonction
directement sur la chauve-souris,
c'estàd que ça c'est une intervention
humaine. Mais est-ce que c'est vraiment
en Chine, à Voine ou est-ce que c'est
aux États-Unis en Caroline du Nord ? Ce
qui est, vous savez que Peter Dass qui
est le président de l'ONG EOSHalth
Alliance, là vous avez là-dessus et je
compte beaucoup sur la présidence Trump
pour nous en dire beaucoup là-dessus
parce que
par intuition et ensuite en écoutant des
gens qui savent et vous avez par exemple
récemment monsieur Sabatier qui a sorti
un livre qui est chercheur au directeur
de recherche au CNRS he qui est
spécialiste de microbologie cellulaire
qui vient de sortir un livre là-dessus
qui explique aujourd'hui que ça vient
beaucoup plus probablement de Caroline
du Nord que de voine mais en tous les
cas que c'est plutôt d'origine
laboratoire.
Donc accident industriel,
accident ou volontaire ?
Pourquoi volontaire
ou volontaire ? Je ne sais pas.
D'accord. Je ne sais pas. OK.
Ah ben je ne peux pas savoir puisque et
peut-être même zonose. Je je n'ai pas
encore de certitude là-dessus et vous
savez moi j'aime bien donner des choses
sûr et vous aussi sur cette chaîne. Donc
je ne m'aventure pas. Mais ce qui m'a
frappé, c'est que dès le début, quand
vous disiez ça peut s'être évacué d'un
s'être échappé, pardon, d'un laboratoire
Voan, on pensait tous au P4 de Voan en
Chine
ou P3 d'ailleurs.
Ben il est P4, non ?
Il y a un P3 aussi.
Il y a aussi un P3, vous avez raison.
Mais le P4 avec euh
la le le partenariat avec la France,
avec euh Chirak euh et l'inauguration
par euh celui qui a failli de Cazuve là
qui a failli devenir un premier ministre
il y a peu de temps, qui le sera
peut-être dans peu de temps. Euh il se
trouve que on pensait peut-être à ça,
c'était pas absurde puisqu'on nous
disait c'est le marché alimentaire de
Vouan. Or, il se trouve qu'à Voan il y a
un P3 et un P4. Donc c'est pas
totalement absurde de se dire il est
possible que ça vienne aussi d'une fuite
de laboratoire de la même ville. Et ben
non, vous avez à l'époque des articles
de fa shaker de vérificateurs de fait en
bon français du point du monde en vous
disant c'est du complotisme. Il y a même
des sondages qui ont été faits auprès de
la population française en disant ceux
qui croient ça sont plutôt des gens qui
sont proches des extrêmes et cetera et
cetera avec un un bas niveau
intellectuel
bien sûr pas éduqué comme on dit.
Exactement
parce qu'on reprend le terme américain
educated. Alors qu'on devrait dire
plutôt niveau d'instruction en France,
mais on dit éduquer pour que ce soit
vraiment rabaissant hein. Euh mais ça
ils aiment bien parfois prendre les
termes américains. C'est comme quand
Trump parle d'immigration. Euh en
anglais on dit deportation pour dire euh
expulsion mais on dit il veut des
déportations. Ça fait très peur. Non
c'est juste qu'on traduit mal.
Qui a dit qui a dit que les journalistes
parlaient anglais ?
Non mais là ils savent ils savent très
bien ce qu'ils font là dans ce cas-là.
Mais euh voilà donc c'était pas absent.
Mais non, on a tout de suite été taxé.
Alors, vous savez, moi j'ai souvenir,
j'étais en décembre 2020, j'ai un
souvenir parfait de ça. J'étais sur une
chaîne qui s'appelle C News dans une
émission et j'avais à côté de moi Martin
Blâchier.
Je vais pas le dénigrer, je je vais pas
du tout le dénigrer mais je vais
simplement dire les faits. Euh il se
trouve que à un moment, je dis attention
parce que j'avais tout simplement lu des
articles, nous allons aller à ce rythme
de folie. Nous allons aller vers ce qui
s'appelle un passeport sanitaire.
On était 5 mois avant le premier pass
sanitaire. Mais 2021, à l'époque c'était
sur les grands rassemblements, il sera
transformé en passe sanitaire du
quotidien en juillet 2021. Et quand j'ai
prononcé ce mot, instantanément tout le
plateau a crié non ça c'est complotiste,
il y aura jamais de passeport sanitaire
en France et cetera. Bon, il se trouve
qu'on en avait un 5 mois plus tard. Donc
si vous voulez, même chose sur l'origine
du virus.
Il sont excusé ces gens-là.
Pas du tout. Mais j'ai pas demandé
d'excuses et j'en veux pas. Et à la
limite,
vous savez, moi je suis pas du d'un
naturel rancunier ou
haineux ou quoi que ce soit. Je je
j'aime pas me laisser faire, je me
laisse pas faire.
quand monsieur Darmanin, ministre de
l'intérieur se permet de s'est permis à
un moment de dénigrer nos manifestations
en faisant quand même on est quand même
au niveau du ministère de l'intérieur,
du ministre de l'intérieur, en faisant
un arrêt sur image de certaines vidéos,
en faisant croire que des gens faisaient
des salut bizarres, vous me comprenez ?
Alors qu'ils étaient en train de taper
dans les mains, faire du clapping en
disant liberté, liberté, liberté et que
lui il fait un arrêt sur image et qu'
publie ça sur son compte X comme
ministre intérieur. Là, j'ai porté
plainte parce que ça c'est pas possible
pour mon honneur et l'honneur des
manifestants.
Ça on est où ?
Ça ça n'a rien donné.
Vous savez quand moi je porte plainte la
plupart du temps,
ça finit dans une dans une corbeille. On
continue. Et d'ailleurs, je vais vous
lancer euh sur l'Europe.
Oui, parce que là, les gens vont se dire
il est dans son truc Covid, il arrive
pas en sortir. Mais l'affaire n'est pas
terminée parce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui à l'affaire des effets
secondaires
de du Covid ou du vaccin ?
Du vaccin.
D'accord. Renseignez-vous aussi sur les
effets secondaires.
Non, mais je connais cette histoire, le
Covid
sur une maladie qui n'est pas
immunisante, qui a des répercussions sur
le cerveau,
qui donc peut avoir des répercussions à
long terme sur le système de santé, les
capacités cognitives d'une population,
sur une maladie qui se propage à grande
échelle, qui est manuportée, aéroportée
avec un degré de rémanence sur certaines
surfaces pouvant aller jusqu'à 6 ou 8
jours. Donc on verra peut-être dans les
5 10 prochaines années les conséquences
sur le le cui des Français, les
conséquences sur le prix que ça va
coûter à notre système de santé et
peut-être notre déclassement en terme de
caution intellectuelle par rapport aux
autres puissances. On verra peut-être
les répercussions à long terme avec ça,
les répercussions à long terme sur les
Suédois et les pays nordique pour voir
les conséquences de pas avoir confiné et
on verra sur leur système de santé ce
que ça peut donner. Et peut-être ça
expliquera leur angoisse d'avoir bouclé
tout le monde sans connaître que c'était
reporté ou quoi que ce soit. Ça
expliquera peut-être aussi pourquoi il
voulait peut-être pas que les sers nous
développent des foyers tels que les
c'est les visons en Italie du Nord ou X
élevage de chat. Je sais pas pour les
élevagges de chat mais en fait
les visons au Danemark aussi.
Les visons au Danemark. Donc on verra ça
plus tard dans 5 ou 10 ans. Peut-être
que vous êtes un prophète que les gens
n'ont pas compris ou peut-être que c'est
un mix des deux. C'est-à-dire, ils
étaient au courant que c'était une
saloperie, que il y avait des
conséquences à long terme sur la
population. Faut savoir ce que fait un
coronavirus sur les colonie de
chauve-souris, hein. Et donc ensuite, on
verra si on peut transposer les
séquelles neurologiques ou hépatiques ou
sur d'autres choses ce qu'on appelle le
Covid long.
Ouais.
Sur la population, si ça crée des
acoupenes et et voir si c'est séquel du
vaccin ou si c'est quel du Covid ou si
c'est les mêmes séquels dans un cas
comme dans l'autre. L'avenir nous dira
mais le le Covid lui-même, le vaccin
provoque des des myocardites, mais le
Covid aussi provoque des myocardites
chez les jeunes notamment.
Rappelez-vous comment les jeunes appelés
suisses avec leur radio pulmonaire
commençai à montrer que des gamins de 19
ans et des avaient des insuffisances
pulmonaires.
Tout à fait.
Ce sera peut-être dans les livres
d'histoire plus tard,
mais il y a cette histoire là et vous
avez parfaitement raison. Et il y a
aussi l'histoire que c'est une
expérience totalitaire.
Ah bah quand les gens paniquent,
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Ils serent la
vis. Oui, mais on est arrivé à une
rupture de principes et
qui vous a dit qu'il y avait encore des
principes en France ?
Alors, ce qui m'a beaucoup choqué, c'est
un sujet très important, vous avez
raison, c'est les contrepouvoirs. C'estd
que nous, on a souvent saisi le Conseil
d'État pour faire annuler des des
mesures qui nous paraissaient
extrêmement contraires aux libertés
fondamentales qui est censé défendre le
Conseil d'État. et on nous a toujours
rétorqué que c'était proportionné si
vous voulez y compris je c'est un truc
qui est marrant mais en juillet 2021
passe sanitaire passe sanitaire c'estàd
que c'est vaccin ou test
et à l'époque le conseil le conseil
d'état sort une décision en disant ça va
parce qu'il y a aussi le test si ça
n'était que le vaccin ce serait ce
serait disproportionné
puis quand 6 mois plus tard on passe au
passe vaccinal où il y a plus le test il
y a que le vaccin le conseil d'état est
ressaisi Mais il dit c'est bon. Donc il
se contredit lui-même à 6 mois
d'intervalle, ce qui prouve que on n'est
plus dans le droit ni l'état de droit.
Mais monsieur Rota qui est notre
ministre intérieur nous a dit que de
toute façon c'était pas très grave parce
qu'il on était en rupture avec l'état de
droit sous le Covid. Il l'a dit et que
il fallait l'assumer et qu'on le sera à
nouveau demain. Euh mais moi je
l'accepte pas ça. Et donc on a vu une
expérience totalitaire. Il faut pas
minimiser cela. C'està-dire qu'on a
testé qui est-ce qui voulait emmerder
les Français d'ailleurs ? Macron qui a
dit euh en décembre 2020 21 en disant
"J'ai envie d'emmerder les non
vaccinés". ce qui est une un propos de
chef d'état hein. Vous me direz
aujourd'hui, il vient même de dire que
les Haïtiens étaient des cons.
Faut faut vraiment être
c'est au même niveau. C'est du même
niveau. Mais euh
les gens qui ne sont rien, ce genre de
petites phrases bien condescendantes,
très condescendante et absolument pas au
niveau et et c'est une expérience
totalitaire parce qu'on a on a on a
brisé des des des règles absolues, le le
secret médical, les libertés
fondamentales.
Euh on a quand même on s'est quand même
privé d'infirmière, de médecins, de
pompiers. C'est vrai qu'on en a trop en
France.
Rappelez-vous les infirmières qui est
obligé de se des casacs en sac
poubelle.
Oui, tout à fait. On a poussé les gens à
se à faire de la délation. J'en parlais.
Souvenez-vous de ces campagnes
publicitaires où on expliquait au gamins
de 6 ans que s'il ne mettait pas le
masque, ils allaient tuer grand-mère. Je
sais pas si vous aurez imaginé les
impacts psychologiques de cette
dinguerie. On a expliqué aussi qu'il
fallait que papi et mamie aillent manger
dans la cuisine leur bûche de Noël seul
à Noël. Ça c'est Rémy Salomon de la PHP.
On a eu tout ça. Je veux dire, il faut
quand même se rendre compte qu'on nous a
aussi pris pour une bande de cobail où
on s'est dit voilà il y a une crise
alors ça peut être une épidémie et
pensez contre vous-même. Imaginez-vous
ça peut être une guerre, ça peut être un
accident nucléaire ça peut être plein de
choses. On voit comment les gens
réagissent. Est-ce que ça désobéit à
plein tube ou est-ce que ça obéit ? Ça a
globalement obéi, ce qui moi ne me
rassure pas beaucoup.
Vous ê politique. Vous êtes politique.
Imaginez l'impact politique de trier des
patients sur le trottoir de l'hôpital.
Ouais.
On avait pas de respirateur. Respirateur
ventilateur.
On éta obligé de faire appel à quelques
constructeurs d'automobile pour nous
faire des ventil des respirateurs.
Politiquement parlant, c'était un
assassinat pur et dur pour eux.
C'est-à-dire trier des patients en
disant "Toi, tu es jeune, bon euh toi tu
es vieux, toi tu es gros." Euh
politiquement parlant, on s'en relevait
pas. C'est peut-être pour ça qu'ils ont
surréagi à dire à papi mami dans la
cuisine parce qu'on sait jamais, ça nous
en fera peut-être deux de moins à
traiter.
Bah oui, vous en mettez pas, vous avez
raison, dans un monde normal, mais si
vous surestimez le danger, si vous dites
"C'est tellement énorme ce qui nous
arrive, regardez ce qu'ils font
maintenant sur la dette."
On a certes augmenté la dette de 1000
milliards d'euros pendant le quinquena,
mais rendez-vous compte, on a eu le
Covid
200 milliards.
Le Covid, c'est 200 milliard rien que
pour le Covid. Ouais. Mais alors oui,
mais les gens se disent "Ah oui, c'est
vrai, ils ont eu le Covid comme si en
plus euh les les décisions qui avaient
été prises euh étaient forcément
induites obligatoirement par le Covid
alors que des pays ont pris d'autres
décisions qui ont été beaucoup moins
coûteuses euh et qui ont pourtant été
plus efficaces en terme de de non
mortalité.
Donc euh moi je pense que ils ont pas
perdu temps tant de plume à ce
moment-là. Je pense qu'ils en perdront
dans les années dans les mois, les
années qui viennent.
Les médias aussi euh la défiance a
augmenté la défiance. Le fait qu'ils
aient mis une chap de plomb sur toi tu
es complotiste parce que tu dis qu'il y
a un laboratoire P2 P3 P4 P3 P4 pardon à
ça les a flingué.
Vous savez moi j'ai eu un un jour un
débat pendant cette période sur une
radio grosse radio nationale et avec un
médecin de plateau comme je les appelle
et et qui était pas le P parce que au
moins lui n'était pas agressif ni
condescendant.
mais il était pas d'accord avec moi. Et
je me permets de dire à l'antenne, vous
savez, il y a des médecins qui
recommandent la vitamine D, ça fera pas
ça fera de mal à personne et ça peut
être et ce qui aujourd'hui est plutôt
recommandé hein. Si vous prenez trop de
vitamine D, ça peut vous faire aussi
Non, attention, bien sûr, pas de pas. Et
j'ai toujours précisé, j'ai toujours
précisé que ce soit dans les médias ou
sur ma chaîne, je ne suis pas médecin.
Vous faites avec votre médecin.
Voilà, avec votre médecin sur tous les
sujets. Compr vous comprenez pourquoi je
vous reprends.
Vous avez raison à 150 %. Euh et ce
médecin sur à l'antenne dit "Non, non,
non, non, non." OK.
Je vous promets que ce que je vous dis
est vrai. En sortant du plateau, enfin
de du studio parce que c'est une radio,
un l'instant où je suis sorti, il me dit
"Faut que je vous dise un truc, ce que
vous avez dit sur la vitamine D
exactement vrai. C'est totalement vrai.
Mais si je le dis, moi j'aurais un
problème avec l'ordre, avec le conseil
de l'ordre."
J'ai dit monsieur, j'ai dit non, j'ai
dit là moi je lui ai dit écoutez moi
j'accepte pas ce genre de je vous
balancerai pas parce que je suis pas
comme ça mais j'ai vous pouvez pas faire
ça vous pouvez pas dire ça c'est juste
pas possible on parle de vie humaine
on parle de bons conseils.
On pourrait on pourrait
c'est ça cette période là faut pas que
les gens oublient quand même.
Oui c'est on pourrait faire 3h là-dessus
même 5h 8h en une semaine.
L'appel
on va dire
les marchés sur les vaccins, ils ont été
l'appel d'offre il a été fait comment ?
au niveau de l'Union européenne
forcément du coup parce que ça a été
piloté par l'Union européenne. Bah
écoutez, j'aimerais bien savoir, je suis
en procès contre Solarle Layon à ce
sujet et je me retrouverai à Liège
d'ailleurs face à elle. Enfin, j'espère
qu'elle viendra, elle est convoquée euh
le 6 décembre prochain puisque nous
avons porté plainte. J'aimerais bien
savoir, ils ont manifestement été
négociés d'une drôle manière. Ça c'est
ce que dit la médiatrice euh de l'Union
européenne, c'est ce que dit la Cour des
comptes européennes. Euh c'est ce que
dit dans son enquête un journal
américain, je crois que c'est le c'est
le New York Times. C'est ça ? Oui, c'est
New York Times qui a fait qui qui a le
premier soulevé ce lièvre des SMS.
C'est-à-dire que c'est un il faut quand
même se rendre compte que ce c'était
cette affaire de vaccin a été négociée
et pilotée par l'Union européenne parce
que les États ont considéré que c'était
mieux, ce qui est déjà absolument
discutable. Mais bon, de toute façon,
tout ce qui est européen est beautiful.
C'est forcément bien. On nous explique
que tout ce qui est européen est bien.
Donc, ils ont dit, on va le faire au
niveau européen. OK. L'Union européenne
a négocié un contrat au total de 71
milliards d'euros pour les vaccins dont
35 milliards pour cette tranche qui nous
intéresse avec Pizer, ce qui est le plus
gros contrat avec une boîte privée de
l'histoire de l'Union européenne.
Un journal américain se penche sur cette
affaire en 2021 et découvre grâce en
fait au porte-parole la porte-parole une
porte-parole de la Commission européenne
que ça a été négocié en partie par SMS.
Ces SMS n'ont pas été stockés. Or, il y
a un règlement européen qui dit que il
faut stocker tous les documents
liés aux institutions européennes.
Donc plainte,
nous on est très dubitatif sur cette
histoire. On se dit des sommes aussi
gigantesques qui sont négociées par SMS
en dehors de toute règle. Ça pose
question, ça pose question pour la santé
publique. Ça pose question pour les
finances publiques parce que c'est notre
argent. Faut jamais se oublier que
l'argent de l'Union en Pine, ça n'existe
pas. L'argent de l'Union européenne,
c'est l'argent des États. Donc c'est
l'argent de nous contribuable. Et nous,
en particulier français, puisque nous
sommes un pays qui contribue beaucoup
plus au budget européen qu'il en reçoit.
On a un différentiel chaque année qui
est monstrueux. Bah le différentiel
actuel officiel qui apparaît dans les
budgets, c'est 12 milliards et quelques.
Si vous y ajoutez, les autres
contributions monent à 15 milliards par
an. On est deuxè derrière l'Allemagne
qui a un différentiel de 25 milliards
par an. Donc on est un contributeur net.
Donc ça nous intéresse. Donc on a porté
plainte. Voilà. Donc on n sait pas plus
pour l'instant. Dans l'affaire si ça
vous intéresse, on apporté plainte par
rapport à un juge d'instruction belge,
monsieur Freé, qui est un homme
remarquable qui s'est fait remarquer, on
l'a pas choisi au hasard, on est allé en
Belgique parce que c'est en Belgique que
ça s'est passé, mais on est allé à
Liège. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'elle juge
Freiné. Juge Freiné, c'est un peu si
vous voulez le vend Runbec belge. C'est
son âme.
Exactement. C'est un juge d'instruction
remarquable.
Vous tapez son nom sur Google, vous
trouverez plein d'affaires où ce juge
belge a fait tomber des élus belges
corrompus. Donc, il a pas froid aux
yeux. C'est un type indépendant,
professionnel. Moi, j'ai été plusieurs
fois dans son bureau, j'ai beaucoup
discuté avec lui. Je peux pas tout vous
raconter parce que c'est couvert par un
secret de l'instruction, mais il m'a dit
des choses très fortes et très justes.
Et il a envie d'enquêter. Mais on lui a
mis dans les pattes un truc qui a été
créé en 2021. 2021 en plein Covid. qui
s'appelle le parquet européen qui est
une justice fédérale
et qui estime que dès qu'il y a euh
dès que les finances de l'Union
européenne sont en cause, c'est à lui de
reprendre la compétence. Et donc là,
notre enjeu pour l'instant, c'est même
pas le fond de l'enquête, c'est la
compétence. Le juge belge défense sa
compétence par rapport à ce parquet
européen qui veut récupérer l'affaire.
Et je très j'ai de très grandes craintes
si le parc européen récupère l'affaire
parce que je pense qu'il il la prendra,
il la mettra dans la main, il la mettra
à la poubelle. Qu'est-
Qu'est-ce que vous essayez de me
suggérer là ?
Je vous je vous le dis même. Je vous dis
que si le Parc européen récupère
l'affaire, il la mettra à la poubelle.
Parce que dans l'Union en peigne, il n'y
a pas de partage des pouvoirs, il n'y a
pas de séparation des pouvoirs. Ça
n'existe pas. l'Union européenne et
c'est en cela que c'est une c'est un
système qu'on devrait classer dans les
tyranies selon la classification de
Montesqueux. C'est un c'est une c'est un
c'est un système où il n'y a pas de
séparation des pouvoirs. Donc ça n'est
pas une démocratie. D'abord, ça ne peut
pas être une démocratie parce qu'il y a
pas de démos européen, il y a pas de
peuple européen. Donc premier problème
et en plus
députés européens.
Oui mais ça n'est pas vous savez moi
quand j'étais député européen, je l'ai
été entre 2000. Oui, j'ai oublié de le
dire dans ma présentation. J'aurais pu
le dire. Ça touche combien députés
européens ?
Ça touche à l'époque ça augmenté mais à
l'époque c'était en net euh 6007 je
crois.
Et euh vous avez la sécotiser.
Vous êtes payé combien d'impôts ? C'est
de l'impôt comment ?
Euh vous payez de l'impôt directement
là-bas à la source. Euh il y avait pas
d'autres enveloppes parce que les autres
enveloppes vous les gérez pas mais vous
avez des enveloppes pour les assistants
parlementaires tout ça mais ça elle
tombe pas sur votre compte. Et vous êes
vous avez traîné avec le scandale des
assistants parlementaires du du
Rassemblement national ou pas ?
J'ai été entendu par la police. J'ai été
entendu
j'étais
par quelle police ?
Le le la police anticorruption enfin
comment s'appelle de de Nanterre le
l'liff
c'est normal hein. J'ai été convoqué
parce que j'apparaissais sur
l'organigramme du Front National. Donc
j'ai été convoqué trois fois. J'y suis
moi je n'ai jamais refusé la moindre
convocation. Donc je suis allé trois
fois m'expliquer devant la police et une
fois devant une juge et je suis sorti du
bureau de la juge qui m'a dit "Vous
n'êtes pas mis en examen
parce que parce que moi j'avais pas de
problème. J'avais des vrais assistants
qui faisaient du vrai boulot et en plus
j'étais moi un électron libre au front
national. J'étais
C'est pour ça que vous êtes fait virer ?
Je me suis pas fait virer.
Vous êtes parti ?
Non mais je sais que beaucoup croient ça
et je je vous assure que je me suis pas
fait virer.
Vous êtes parti de vous-même ? Je suis
parti moi-même.
Parce que vous avez senti que ça
commençait à craindre.
Non, c'est une c'est c'est tout c'est
tout bête. C'est c'est une histoire de
conviction. Alors ça peut paraître
lunaire pour beaucoup parce que les
convictions, la politique, les sauts
aujourd'hui il serait députés européens,
il serait peut-être député national.
Probablement
principe, c'est sacré.
Non mais beaucoup se disent je vois des
gens qui me disent "Vous savez, vous
auriez dû rester là-bas parce que
aujourd'hui vous seriez député
probablement. vous seriez ou députés
européen, euh vous seriez tous les
matins sur BFM ou RTL ou TF1 ou je sais
pas quoi.
C'est vrai, peut-être, je l'ai été un
moment. Euh
mais moi, je suis arrivé un jour, j'ai
rencontré Marine Le Pen d'abord en
clandestin parce que j'étais encore
ministère de l'intérieur. Je l'ai
conseillé en le soir et le weekend.
Devoir de réserve quand même.
Non, j'ai pas j'ai pas rompu mon devoir
de réserve. Je l'ai je l'ai vraiment
conseillé sur mon temps libre. Mais je
pouvais pas apparaître justement parce
que je respectais ce devoir de réserve.
Et puis quand je elle m'a proposé d'être
directeur de sa campagne en 2012 à la
présidentielle, je me suis mis en dispo
de du ministère de l'intérieur dans les
règles de l'art et j'ai pu là récupérer
totalement ma liberté d'expression et ma
liberté de parole. Et
vous empêcher de parler de quoi ?
Non, c'est normal. Non mais moi je je je
je suis en d'accord avec ça. Je suis
d'accord avec cela. Un haut
fonctionnaire quand il est en fonction,
c'est normal qu'il a un devoir de
réserve.
Touchz combien au ministère de
l'intérieur ?
Oh, j'étais inspecteur euh seconde
classe euh
à l'IGA, donc j'ai dû commencer à je
devais être à 3008 net.
Des avantages en nature ?
Non, je crois pas. Est-ce que j'en avais
?
On avait un pool de chauffeur ministère
l'intérieur qu'on pouvait utiliser quand
la voiture était libre.
Ce qui est appréciable mais il fallait
que ce soit libre, c'est tout je crois.
Mais après quand vous devenez inspecteur
général, c'est plus
Revenons, revenons à l'Europe.
Plus plus rémunérateur.
Non, revenons. D'ailleurs, juste une
parenthèse.
Non, au front voulez me dire donc j'ai
pas été viré. Non, faut quand même je
réponde à ça. Donc j'ai j'ai dit à
Marine Le Pen le jour où je suis arrivé,
vous savez ce qui m'a rassuré, c'est que
je lui ai dit, elle m'a dit "Est-ce que
vous le premier jour, on s vous voyez
après on s'est toujours tutoyé, mais le
premier jour, elle me dit est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu une expérience
politique ?" Je lui dis "J'ai soutenu la
campagne de Jean-Pierre Chevenement en
2002 à la présidentielle. Je suis
souverainiste et je pense que la France
doit quitter l'Union européenne de
manière vitale. Et elle m'a répondu
alors on n'est pas loin.
Et je me suis dit non mais vous souriez
mais je vous assure
que je vous qui vous dit que je vous
souris vous vois. Je suis le seul à vous
voir dans Et donc
et donc non ce qui m'a rassuré parce que
parce que est-ce que Jean-Pierre
Chavinement il est plutôt moi vous savez
gauche droite pour moi ça veut rien dire
depuis longtemps mais il est plutôt
cassé à gauche et je me suis dit si
vraiment c'est une femme d'extrême
droite elle va m'entendre parler d'un
homme de gauche donc elle va hurler
c'est pas du tout sans réflexe donc je
me suis dit elle est dans une démarche
qui m'intéresse et je lui ai dit vite si
un jour tu abandonnes le frxite et la
sortie de l'eur je me barre
Elle m'a toujours riz à ce moment-là.
Elle me croyait pas. Je l'ai dit y
compris à des journalistes qui
d'ailleurs le jour où je suis parti
m'envoyer un texto en me disant respect,
vous avez vos convictions.
À un moment après le débat
catastrophique de 2017, tout le monde
s'en souvient et donc derrière le score
très décevant au second tour la
présidentielle, je suis pas parti tout
de suite. J'ai attendu 4 mois.
Je peux vous couper ? C'est vous qui
l'aviez préparé au débat ou
je l'avais préparé mais pas du tout en
ce sens. Je l'ai préparé à toutes ces
émissions entre 2009 et 2017. Donc donc
je je ne l'ai pas préparé en ce sens. Je
je l'ai laisser en fin de matinée dans
un état qui m'a paru inquiétant parce
qu'elle était beaucoup plus stressée que
je ne l'avais jamais vu. Et ça ça
m'avait inquiété.
Et je sais qu'elle a eu des visiteurs de
l'après-midi que je ne connais pas bien
et qui lui ont mis de très mauvais
conseils dans la tête.
Bon mais vous savez, je vais vous dire
une chose, le lendemain du débat second
tour,
je vais vous dire une chose, ça c'est
bien un politique.
Non, ça vraiment,
je crois pas. Bon, si vous le dites,
mais le lendemain de du débat,
catastrophe.
Elle a un meeting dans Picardie.
Il se trouve que euh
je suis à ce moment-là
Marine Le Pen est au fond du trou. Elle
s'est rendu compte pas tout de suite
mais elle a fini par se rendre compte le
lendemain que c'était une catastrophe
son débat qu'elle avait perdu beaucoup
et qu'elle allait perdre beaucoup.
Normalement tous les cadres
l'accompagnaient dans son dans ses
meetings. J'étais le seul à
l'accompagner. Vous voyez le seul. Les
autres ils se cachaient. Ce que je dis
est vrai.
On est arrivé, il y a eu 1000 personnes.
Pourquoi il y a d'autres trucs que vous
m'avez dit qui était faux ?
Non non.
Pourquoi vous êtes obligé de préciser ?
Je sais pas. Parce qu'on pourrait me
dire il il
se donne il se donne parce que je veux
insister sur le fait que que parce que
parce que ça pourrait paraître comme il
se valorise, vous voyez. Je veux pas du
tout me valoriser. Je dis vraiment la
vérité. Le lendemain, on est, je suis le
seul à l'accompagner dans ce meeting. Il
y a 1000 militants qui nous tombent
dessus en disant "Qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé hier soir ?" En mode "Rendez-nous,
rendez-nous des comptes parce que eux
voulaient vraiment qu'on gagne face à
Macron, ce qui est normal."
Et ça, il fallait l'affronter ce regard
et ces questionnements légitimes des
militants. Personne d'autre ne
l'accompagn. Donc moi, je l'ai pas
laissé tomber. J'ai encore dans mon
téléphone les textos que je lui ai
échangé avec elle à ce moment-là où je
lui dis où je la je lui remonte le moral
parce qu'elle est dans un état de
dépression totale.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Quand vous avez
été auditionné par la police, est-ce que
la police vous a saisi saisi vos
téléphones et choses comme ça ?
Non non non, j'ai pas été mis en garde à
vue ou quoi que ce soit.
Merci. Continuez.
Ouais. Euh c'est des auditions libres.
J'aurais pu ne pas y aller euh d'autant
que j'étais député européen à l'époque
donc ils avaient pas le droit de faire
certaines choses. Mais euh
donc là on est en 2017 donc je suis pas
parti tout de suite. Elle dit "On va
ouvrir un débat en interne. On ouvre un
débat en interne sur la sortie de
l'Union en peine, la sortie de l'euro et
cetera. Je participe loyalement le
débat. Quand je vois que je suis
minoritaire et qu'il a été décidé
d'abandonner le Frexit et la sortie de
l'euro, septembre 2017, je pars.
Je pars et donc je suis pas viré et ça
l'aurait bien arrangé que je reste. Je
suis parti et j'ai créé les patriotes.
Compliqué au début hein. Vous quittez un
parti qui a déjà à l'époque 45 ans
d'existence, 1972
qui est
combien de déficit
à l'époque ? Il était en déficit.
Maintenant ils sont richissimes. Mais à
l'époque ils étaient en déficit. Vous
entendez pas richissime ? Bah
aujourd'hui, ils ont 20 millions d'euros
par an d'aide publique. Vous savez que
le la le l'aide publique des partis
politiques est définie par le nombre de
voix et le nombre de de députés que vous
faites aux élections législatives. Donc
nous, on est à zéro parce qu'on était un
petit peu en 2022 parce qu'on avait
présenté des candidats et qu'on avait
respecté les critères. Puis en 2024, il
nous a fait cette dissolution
inattendue le 9 juin. On n pas présenté
de candidat parce que c'était trop
rapide et puis on aurait eu de semaines
de campagne, c'était pas raisonnable. à
chaque fois que vous êtes présenté,
donc on a pas d' public,
à chaque fois que vous êtes présenté à
euh à une élection euh vous aviez,
permettez-moi l'expression, fait des
scores lamentable
euh en tant qu'e patriote, comme alors
comme FN, je faisais le score du parti,
je faisais des scores magnifiques
parce que vous savez les gens font le
score de l'étiquette hein. Il a je vois
des gens aujourd'hui qui me font la
leçon au FN. Oh, tu sais, face à ton
candidat, j'ai fait 40, vous vous avez
fait deux. J'ai dit
mon grand demain vas-y sous tes propres
couleurs. Tu feras pas deux, tu feras
01. Tu vois de ça existe déjà, c'est
déjà un parti qui existe de parce que
quand tu te présentes sans rien, tu fais
00 05 ou 01. J'ai paradez pas trop parce
que moi j'ai appris beaucoup l'humilité
là-dessus. J'ai appris beaucoup
l'humilité. C'est vous savez euh je
faisais des scores. Moi j'ai fait 30 %
dans ma grande région aux européennes
largement en tête. J'étais au régional
2015 largement en tête. 12 points
d'avance sur le président de région
sortant. Donc mais c'était l'étiquette.
Alors peut-être en plus vous avez votre
personnalité dans la campagne mais
l'étiquette joue énormément surtout et
on pourrait y revenir surtout dans une
société dépolitisée. Comment vous
expliquez la montée ?
Alors attendez sur les scores que font
les patriotes, c'est pas totalement vrai
parce que moi je me suis présenté sous
tout seul au régional 2021 dans le grand
test, j'ai fait 7 %. J'avais le RN en
face de moi qui a fait 21, c'est trois
fois plus certes, mais 7 c'est pas rien.
Sur une région qui regroupe Champagne
Garden, Laoren, Alsace, c'est beaucoup
de monde 7 %. Donc c'est quand même
beaucoup de voix. Vous voyez euh on
s'installe, moi j'ai pas l'accès au
médias, je l'ai pas, je l'ai très peu
parce que c'est très compliqué parce que
les journalistes me disent "Vous avez le
droit cette semaine à 13 secondes." Et
c'est vraiment comme ça hein.
Aujourd'hui, c'est le gosse plan.
Qu'est-ce qu'on dit en 13 secondes ?
On dit rien. Donc on n'y va pas en fait.
On peut pas y aller
simple et court. Et le
Mais regardez quand je fais de temps en
temps une émission au début maintenant
le journaliste me dit "J'ai le droit de
vous interviewer 8 minutes 30
aujourd'hui." Les règles se sont
considérablement durcies ces dernières
années par l'ARCOM. Euh d'ailleurs, je
vais faire une grosse manif je pense le
14 décembre devant l'ARCOM là-dessus. Je
l'annonce déjà euh parce que c'est pas
possible. Euh euh c'est le gos plan qui
distribue les secondes et les minutes.
Et donc vous aujourd'hui si vous essayez
d'émerger comme parti politique, il faut
être très bon. Vous faites du terrain,
ça vous avez le droit. Vous faites des
réseaux sociaux, pour l'instant vous
avez le droit. Tant qu'il y a pas trop
de censure et on est très très bon, on
est très fort. Les médias, c'est
complètement cannassé. C'est l'oligopole
qui se préserve, son monopole. Enfin, ça
veut rien dire ce que je viens de dire,
mais son l'oligopole qui se préserve,
c'est médias. Euh et donc les parties
sortant ont droit à tout le temps de
parole et les nouveaux entrants n'ont
droit à rien, ce qui était pas le cas
avant. C'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on
prend pas de carte de presse, qu'on paye
la TVA en dedans à de 20 %, qu'on a pas
de TVA arrangé à 2.5, qu'on a pas les
les avantages de cartes de presse parce
que dans la prévision où il commencerait
à mettre les mains sur les réseaux
sociaux, les plateformes YouTube, je
pense que ils vont demander des quotas
un peu comme dans les médias
et nous on veut pouvoir interviewer
autant de temps qu'on veut, qui on veut,
comme on veut et soutenez-nous sur Tipi
parce que c'est grâce à vous qu'on est
indépendant.
Je vous pose une question. Vous vous
grenouillez, vous crapautez, vous
bourlinguez dans le milieu de la
politique depuis un certain nombre
d'années. Comment vous expliquez la
montée des extrêmes en France et en
Europe ?
Bon, après, il faut voir ce qu'on
appelle l'extrême, mais euh c'est-à-dire
que euh
alors j'explique une chose par une chose
assez simple ce qui se passe.
Nos pays, là on va revenir au cœur du
quand même du sujet. La France et les
pays européens n'ont plus de
souveraineté.
Donc, vous avez ce succédant au pouvoir
des gouvernements qui sont des
gouvernements de protectorat.
qui par définition qu'il soit classé à
droite ou à gauche, monsieur Sarkozy ou
monsieur Hollande ou monsieur Macron au
centre, on va dire, vont mener la même
politique puisque la politique, elle est
décidée au-dessus.
Donc ils vont faire beaucoup de
promesses pendant les campagnes sur
l'immigration, sur l'économie, sur
l'industrie, sur plein de sujets et en
réalité en arrivant au pouvoir, ils vont
mener toujours la même politique. Donc
logiquement le corps électoral mais il
se passe deux choses. Un une partie va
arrêter de voter, d'où l'explication de
la forte hausse de l'abstention
notamment en France qui était pas un
pays abstentionniste. Nous sommes une
nation très politique. Vous savez que
Marx disait qu'on était la nation la
plus politique du monde. Nous sommes un
pays politique. Dans quel pays
discute-on encore de politique au bar au
comptoir des bars ? En France, vous en
avez plus beaucoup des pays comme ça.
Mais l'abstention malgré tout, parce que
les gens se disent "Attendez, on a voté
en 2005 pour le nom à l'Union
européenne, on nous a mis le traité de
Lisbonne 3 ans plus tard dans la
figure." Donc les gens se disent "On va
arrêter de voter." On nous a dit que
SarkoZi alla être la rupture, c'était
son slogan. On a rien vu du tout.
Hollande devait mettre la finance à
genoux, souvenez-vous, il a rien mis du
tout à genoux. Euh donc euh Macron euh
et cetera. Donc et puis le deuxième
phénomène, c'est que les gens vont aller
chercher ailleurs. Donc ils vont aller
chercher vers une offre qui va leur
redonner un petit frisson
anticapitaliste ou euh euh de de justice
sociale plus prononcée. Voilà. Et puis
une offre qui plus nationale, dite, plus
souverainiste dont moi je dis qu'en tout
cas en France, malheureusement, elle a
elle est aujourd'hui euh euh de plus en
plus agglomérée au système elle-même
parce que le système, vous savez, c'est
une quand vous rentrez dans ce système-
làà c'est une c'est une lessiveuse ça
finit par vous absorber. Il faut faire
très attention à ça. Si vous avez pas
vos convictions chevillé au corps, vous
finissez comme le RN aujourd'hui à tout
abandonné. Donc vous restez dans l'OTAN,
dans l'Union européenne, dans l'euro,
dans Schengen, dans tous les dans tout
le système et vous en arrivez à faire un
bisou à Zelenski et et une accolade à
Ursula von Derleon. Donc il faut faire
très attention à ça. Mais le corps
électoral, il est normal qu'il se déface
de tous ces gouvernements qui sont en
fait des gouvernements du système qui
lui ont promis beaucoup de choses qu'il
ne pouvaient pas tenir puisque nous
sommes un pays sous tutelle. Et ça c'est
la le grand secret de la vie politique
française, c'est que la politique la la
décision, la prise de décision n'est
plus ici. Donc c'est pour vous c'est une
des explications de la montée des
extrêmes. Alors moi je vous voyez
aujourd'hui je je considère pas que le
RN soit un extrême ni même je vais vous
dire LFI en fait.
Vous savez prenez le programme
économique et social de LFI ou du NFP
puisqu'ils étaient en alliance là au
législative nouveau Front populaire.
Leur programme économique et social,
c'est Pinot par rapport au programme
commun de 1981 où vous aviez
nationalisation de 90 % de des banques
françaises et de 50 % de l'industrie
française,
ce qui a fait partir beaucoup de gens.
Je sais pas.
Non, à mon avis ce qui a plombé la
France c'est 83, c'est pas 81. C'est le
tournant de la rigueur. C'est quand sous
pression à l'époque de Moroi et de l'or
contre Fabus et Cheevainement,
Mitéran choisit de rester fidèle au SME
à l'époque système monétaire européen
qui était le déjà le l'héritier du
serpent monétaire européen et donc
l'enseêtre de l'euro et de dire on fera
le choix de l'Europe par rapport au
choix du programme. Et moi je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus ça qui a fait du mal
à la France que 80 où il y a sûrement eu
des erreurs. Je dis pas
mais moi je suis pas
je comprends que beaucoup de gens été
enthousiasmés en 81 par ce qui s'est
passé.
Quelles sont les racines
de l'augmentation du vote je dirais
contestataire ? Mais ça
ça
mais c'est-à-dire vous avez un un un
système démocratique qui euh quoi que
vous fassiez euh vous choisissez la
droite, la gauche, le centre, vous avez
à la fin la même politique. Bah au bout
d'un moment, les gens se disent "On va
aller voir ailleurs."
Est-ce que c'est pas le vide dans les
frigos ?
Oui, mais c'est une conséquence puisque
cette politique du système a pauvri.
Cette politique du système a
désindustrialisé la France. Le choix de
l'euro,
faut mettre les pieds dans le plat. Le
choix de l'euro, le choix du libre
échange qui sont deux politiques
structurelles de l'Union européenne.
Attention, libre échange, c'est externe
à l'Union européenne et c'est interne.
N'oubliez jamais que l'essentiel de nos
délocalisations sont à l'intérieur de
l'Union européenne. Ce soir, le Grand
vient d'annoncer qu'il quittait la
France pour la Hongrie.
Vous voyez ? Donc c'est pour ça quand on
vous dit l'Europe, la souveraineté
européenne, ça veut rien dire. S'il
s'agit de faire bosser des ouvriers
polonais et des ingénieurs bulgares, la
belle affaire pour l'ingénieur français
et l'ouvrier français. Bon, mais
évidemment aussi par rapport à
l'extérieur des localisations en Chine,
aux États-Unis maintenant puisque
l'énergie est moins chère et cetera. Euh
et l'euro
l'euro qui est un problème politique.
J'ai ouvert un blog en 2005, j'étais
étudiant qui s'appelle sortir de l'euro.
Donc je suis un convaincu de ce sujet
depuis très longtemps qui est un
problème politique et un problème
économique.
Vous videz les frigos puisque vous
désindustrialisez la France, puisque
vous tuez son agriculture, son industrie
et et donc ses services puisqu'on a mis
à la tête du pays des gens qui nous ont
expliqué pendant des années qu'on était
dans
l'économie sans usine, je sais plus
c'est Jean-Marie Messier qui disait ça,
c'est ça J2M qui disait avec sa
chaussette trouée qui nous expliquait
que
ça allait être l'avenir, que la
mondialisation heureuse que nous on
était plus intelligent que tout le
monde. Donc on allait faire construire
par les Chinois, les Indiens qui et puis
que nous on allait se réserver les
choses très intellectuelles, sauf qu'ils
sont absolument pas plus bête que nous
et qu'ils ont fini par exactement la
même chose, voir mieux. Donc en réalité
voir aujourd'hui, vous savez ce qu'on
fait avec le bois par exemple, nous on
prend le bois brut, pays du Cœmonde
hein, on leurevend le bois brut sans
valeur ajoutée, il le transforment en
meuble ou en parquet et il nous le
revendent. Et donc on achète des meubles
et du parquet chinois, on leur a vendu
notre bois.
Pas les mêmes normes. Et en plus en plus
on fait bosser des gamins, on fait
bosser des prisonniers dans des
conditions épouvantables et on pollue et
on pollue comme pas possible.
Chez eux.
Ouais, chez eux. Mais c'est la même
planète, hein.
Est-ce que vous avez des alliances dans
d'autres partis politiques ? Est-ce que
vous êtes amis avec la légende vivante
du Frexite qui est François Azelino ?
Bah moi, j'aurais bien aimé mais il a
pas il a jamais voulu.
Pourquoi ?
Ah, il faudrait lui demander. Enfin si,
il vous dira euh plein de trucs. Enfin,
ça change tous les mois. Mais non, non,
on lui a proposé bien sûr. Non, je l'ai
rencontré euh je l'ai rencontré fin 2019
pour la première fois à ma demande au
siège de son parti l'UPR.
Euh, j'ai toujours regretté qu'au moment
où le FN était sur une ligne friteuse,
il ne viennent pas la renforcer, qu'il
soit un peu en cavalier seul. Je pense
que c'était une déperdition d'énergie.
Euh mais bon voilà, il m'avait déjà
attaqué depuis très longtemps. Il
m'attaquait dans les médias sans me
connaître depuis très longtemps.
Mais pourquoi il vous attaquer ? C'est
quelqu'un qui est absolument gentil et
charmant. François, il est pas
Je sais pas mais en tout cas
publiquement euh d vous retrouverez il
est passé chez Rier en 2014, il m'avait
attaqué alors qu'on se connaissait
absolument pas. Ni on sé on avait
échangé, il avait inventé des trucs
contre moi épouvantables.
Ah ou il avait inventé que eu la
diffamation pas d'énigrant. Non, mais
c'est lui pour le coup qui avait fait de
la diffamation. Mais il avait euh il
avait dit que ben vous regarderez, c'est
en ligne hein. Ruier 2014, on n'est pas
couché à Slino. Il avait dit que un de
ses conseillers était allé un de mes
meetings où je n'avais eu de cesse de
taper sur les Arabes, ce qui quand on me
connaî euh c'est juste pas possible. Et
en plus, je sais très bien ce que je dis
dans les réunions et je suis pas comme
ça et enfin bref, mais bon et donc
j'avais j'avais hésité à porter plainte
mais bon, j'avais mis un tweet contre
lui à ce moment-là en direct tellement
j'avais été choqué. Mais bon, peu
importe. Mais en tout cas en 2019, les
choses étaient passées et j'avais voulu
le rencontrer parce que je pense que
c'était plus intelligent. Et puis il
m'avait invité un événement pour le
Brexit fin janvier 2020. J'étais allé
évidemment avec d'autres, c'était très
bien. Et puis je lui avais proposé
pendant le premier confinement, je
faisais des Facebook direct avec Nicolas
Dupontignan et d'autres personnalités.
Je lui en ai proposé, il a toujours
refusé. Je l'ai invité à tous nos
événements, à toutes nos manifestations.
Ensuite, il a toujours refusé. Et puis
finalement, je lui ai proposé des
alliances électorales, je lui ai proposé
plein de choses, je vais proposer de
nous encore. Je j'ai fait un une assise
de la souveraineté là, on a été 2500 à
Aras le 14 septembre. Je l'ai réinvité
comme d'autres, il a de nouveau refusé.
Donc je peux plus rien faire, je veux
dire au bout d'un moment. Et là, je vais
vous dire
s'il dit oui
et en plus il me répond toujours j'étais
le premier. D'abord un, pour moi c'est
pas un argument.
C'est pas un argument parce qu'à ce
momentlà vous parlez que aux Français
convaincus depuis longtemps et vous
laissez de côté les Français qui ont été
convaincus il y a une seconde mais moi
je parle aussi aux Français qui ont été
convaincus il y a une seconde parce que
je pense que pour faire une majorité il
faut parler à tout le monde.
Alors pourquoi le Frexite ?
Et en plus c'est même pas vrai parce que
moi en 2005 quand il était conseiller de
Paris UMP moi j'ai jamais été dans un
parti du Oui. Jamais. Moi j'étais déjà
blogueur étudiant pour le nom et ma
première télé c'était en 2005 parce que
j'avais été repéré par France 2 parce
que j'avais un gros blog pour le nom. la
Constitution en peine totalement
indépendant et France 2 un jour m'avait
envoyé un blog en disant un mail en
disant "On a vu votre blog, il est
super, il s'appelait sep fois ses noms."
Euh cette fois référence à Mastrich euh
non pas le chiffre mais CE de TE et euh
et il m'avait invité à un débat en à 13h
au direct en direct au 13h de France 2
le 1er mai 2005 et j'étais jeune
étudiant HC c'était à Saint-Malot,
superbe ville que j'ai découvert à ce
moment-là. Ah les Maloins sont
absolument adorables.
Et donc j'étais allé euh voilà donc en
plus l'intériorité ne tient même pas.
Mais en fait moi je m'en fiche de
l'intériorité c'est pas un argument pour
moi. Euh non c'est très dommage mais si
demain il change d'avis je suis sûr
qu'on pourra faire plein de choses
ensemble et de toute façon on fait déjà
plein de choses avec plein de frxiteurs,
de souverainistes.
Nicolas duant aussi. Oui, on a fait
l'alliance en 2022 avec Nicolas
Dupontignan, avec Charles Henri Gallois,
on a fait avec Jean-Féri Poisson mais
vous savez, moi j'ai invité dans mes
manifestation mais et dans nos
événements, on a invité Tom Benoît, on a
invité Olivier de la Marche, on a invité
Charles Gave, on a invité moi j'aurais
on a j'ai invité Alexis Poulin, j'ai
mais mais franchement j'aimerais bien
avoir un Omumbourg, j'aimerais bien
avoir Philippe Deviller, mais tout le
monde Pierre de Gaulle, il faut arrêter
cette histoire, il faut que tout le
monde se parle même si on a des petites
nuances et tout. La situation de la
France est tellement gravissime qu'on ne
peut pas se permettre ce genre d'excuse.
Donc vous me faites une perche, c'est
très bien. Merci. Donc vous anticipez
des choses difficiles pour la France et
vous pensez que l'Union européenne nous
emmène par le fond.
Verbalisez-moi ça un peu plus en détail.
Risque 1, risque 2, risque 3. Court
terme, moyen terme, long terme,
efficacité. Non mais je vais vous dire
fly le le risque ne
c'est pas fly.
Non sky fly. Pourquoi j'ai dit ça ?
Je vais vous appeler Robert dans 2
secondes.
Mais vous aurez le droit.
Pourquoi j'ai dit ça ? J'ai pensé à un
vieux magasin de de meubles. Mais vous
n'êtes pas un magasin de meubles.
Bon bref. Skyter les dents dans
Oui, il va être méchant. Non, j'avais de
la chance jusqu'ici. Non non, je reste
Sky. Excusez-moi. Je euh
vous savez ce que ça veut dire
ciel.
Là, je sais aussi qu'en ce moment, il y
a plein de gens très à la mode qui
quittent X en disant "Je vais aller sur
un ciel bleu, Blue Sky". Parce que
là-bas et tous les 3 mois ils changent
de C'était Mastodon, c'était euh enfin à
chaque fois ils ont une nouvelle
marotte. Bref, peu importe, c'est pas le
sujet. Alors, je vais vous dire
euh Sky,
je vais vous dire
le risque qui englobe, qui surclasse
tous les autres risques qui la
disparition de la France.
Litération totale.
Disparition totale, c'est le but.
Pourquoi ? Alors,
je vais vous dire, c'est le but depuis
l'origine.
C'est le but de qui ? C'est le but de
quoi ? C'est le but de la construction
européenne depuis l'origine. Et nous à
un moment on l'a pas bien compris parce
qu'on a eu la magnifique parenthèse
gauliste
qui a lutté contre cela. Dès l'origine
dès la CECA en 1954 Communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier dès
le projet de CED en 54 Communité
européenne de la défense qui était une
armée européenne pilotée par l'OTAN
qui à l'époque grâce aux golistes et au
communistes a été viré par le Parlement
français. ça a bien changé euh dès le
traité de Rome en 57 dont je vous
rappelle que Pierre Mind France avait
voté contre comme député Pierre Mes
France a voté contre le traité de Rome
en 57 en faisant un discours remarquable
en disant il y a deux manières
d'instituer une dictature. Soit le
pouvoir conférer dans les mains d'un
seul homme, ce qui est la dictature
classique qu'on connaît, soit déléguer
nos compétences à une autorité
administrative au-dessus des nations qui
va finir par exercer toute la politique
nationale et internationale.
Il y a une troisème méthode d'ailleurs
il y a une troisème méthode d'ailleurs.
Laquelle ?
La dette.
La dette c'est une vieille méthode.
L'esclavage pour dette l'antiquité. Mais
ça, on y revient totalement. Vous avez
vu aujourd'hui ils ont voté les 7h sans
travailler et un sénateur a proposé 18h
sans travailler. On est dans l'esclavage
pour dette. Euh vous avez raison. Mais
le
donc on en arrive. Donc l'Union
européenne si vous voulez depuis
l'origine, c'est un projet qui vise à
dissoudre les nations, les États-nations
et à créer sans le dire. C'est la
méthode des cliqué de Robert Schuman et
de Jean Monet.
étape par étape, quelque chose on peut
pas revenir en arrière, quelque chose
qui va s'apparenter de plus en plus à un
état. Et le mot a été lâché par Mario
Dragui, c'était en novembre 2023. Il
faisait une dédicace de livre en Italie.
Un moment, il a lâché, il y avait des
journalistes. Moi, je pense demain que
l'Union européenne doit maintenant
passer une étape supérieure et devenir
un état. Si si l'Union européenne
devient un état, la France n'est plus un
état. Donc la France n'a plus de siège à
l'ONU, à Forceurie, au Conseil de
sécurité. La France n'a plus de
diplomatie, elle en a d'ailleurs de
moins en moins. La France n'a plus la
politique d'un état. Plus la dissuasion
nucléaire.
Ben plus rien. Je vous je Olaf Scholz
qui est l'actuel chancelier allemand.
Merci de me signaler.
Ouais, je mais non mais parce que je
vous l'annonce, je vous annonce que je
vais dire Olaf Chos quand il était
vice-chancelier
avait euh c'est pas c'est pas si vieux
hein, c'était il y a 2 3 ans, avait
déclaré ou 3 4 ans avait déclaré que il
serait bien que la France partage son
siège permanent au Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU et l'Européanise.
Et vous avez des ministres allemands qui
ont déclaré également que la France
devrait partager sa force nucléaire et
l'européaniser. D'ailleurs, Emmanuel
Macron est allé un peu dans ce sens en
en déclarant que l'intérêt européen,
c'était pareil que l'intérêt national.
Voilà. Donc
Jacques Catali, il a quand même un peu
refrainé dans ses ambitions de partager.
Jacques Atal lui a dit quand il était
jeune étudiant, il a raconté une
anecdote. Il a dit quand il était dans
la commission Athalie, Macron, pas
étudiant mais à l'IGF,
jeune jeune fonctionnaire, il il
cherchait des économies et Macron lui
avait dit "Bah, on a 4 milliards à
récupérer tous les ans facilement à
l'époque. C'est la dissuasion
nucléaire." Et là, Atali.
Voilà. Donc euh bon, voyez, comme quoi
parfois les gens sont plus sauvables
qu'on le croit puisque on aurait pensé
autre chose peut-être de Jacques Atali
mais enfin en tout cas moi j'aurais con
Jackali
pardon
vous le connaissez ?
Non je le connais pas du tout je le
connais qu'à travers ses œuvres et sa
production je suis pas un fan de Jaatali
mais parfois il peut me surprendre en
bien sur ça par exemple mais plus
souvent en mal et là il ne me surprend
pas. On peut ouvrir une parenthèse ? On
continue sur l'Europe. Je voudrais
Non mais l'Europe c'est la destruction
des pays et c'est une catastrophe
économique. Enfin excusez-moi quand on a
les risques pour la France c'est
l'oblitération économique de
souveraineté et
bah c'est c'est c'est à peu près tout.
Vous savez quand déjà votre pays
disparaît
il reste plus grandchose à sauver.
Vous connaissez beaucoup de politiques,
de politiciens français.
Oui.
Ils sont conscients de ça ou pas du tout
?
Alors,
est-ce qu'ils vont à la cantine occuper
des postes d'élus parce que c'est bien
payé ? Il y a la fame, il y a les
chauffeurs, il y a les bons restos de
l'Assemblée nationale, il y a les bons
restos du Sénat. Le Sénat est meilleur.
Le le Sénat est meilleur. On a été
invité une fois à manger là-bas par une
sénatrice
et et on on a mis un peu les pieds dans
le plat. Je vous raconterai ça en off ou
dans le livre qu'on va bientôt publier.
Et euh le Sénat est meilleur. Pourquoi ?
Le service
c'est comme ça. Ah bah au Sénat on prend
son temps.
Voilà. L'assemblée nation nation. Vous
parlez de celui qui est au dernier
étage, c'est ça ?
Ah je sais pas. Moi, j'en ai eu j'ai eu
le droit qu'à un seul. C'était déjà
bien. J'avais été invité par un
sénateur. Mais
d'accord.
Non, mais au-delà de ça, euh
est-ce que vous pensez que les élus
français sont conscients de ça ou est-ce
que euh pour pas faire de généralité,
ils sont tous pourris qu'ils vont à la
canto et que voilà ?
Non, vous savez,
la plupart de ce qu'on appelle les
hommes et femmes politiques français
aujourd'hui ne font plus de politique.
C'est pas de la politique
parce qu'ils connaissent pas les
dossiers, ils connaissent pas les
fondamentaux. C'est même pas ça. C'est
que
ils ont pas de vision de la France.
C'est ça.
Ils n'ont pas de vision de la France.
Parfois non, je vous dire parfois au
Parlement européen, ils connaissent au
contraire les dossiers. Ils sont dans
une commission où ils doivent changer la
virgule d'une directive et se
passionnent pour ça pendant des heures
et cetera. Euh mais c'est pas pour moi
de la politique, c'est être technicien
d'un et c'est faire ce qu'on vous
demande de faire quand vous n'avez plus
la souveraineté. En fait, c'est
amusez-vous dans le bac à sable de la
technique là. Faites des petites des
petits débats de virgule, de
pourcentage, de chiffres. Nous, on
s'occupe des sujets stratégiques. Parce
que la politique, ce sont les sujets
stratégiques. Est-ce qu'on fait la
guerre ou la paix ? Est-ce que on décide
le protectionnisme ou le libre échange ?
Comment on sauve notre agriculture ?
Comment on réindustrialise la France ?
Quelles sont quelle est notre vision
stratégique de l'industrie française
dans 5, 10, 20 ans ? Quand général de
Gaul débarque en 64 en Guyane qui a que
la forêt vierge et qu'il y a rien Guyane
française et qu'il dit il fait même du
teasing avant l'heure, il dit sans dire
ce qu'il veut dire, il dit ici dans 4
ans il y aura une grande œuvre
française.
Et vous savez qui est-ce qu'il a appelé
?
Qu'est-ce que
vous savez qui est-ce qu'il a appelé ?
Le général de Gaul à ce moment-là ?
Non.
Il a appelé Jacques Blamon, fondateur du
programme spatial français. Oui, mais
c'était ça. C'est-à-dire que 4 ans plus
tard, décollait Véronique, la première
fusée française Vyron électronique,
puisque les moteurs comme Arian sont
toujours à Veyron aujourd'hui, hein.
Euh, Véronique. Voilà. Bon, mais il
avait annoncé, c'était une vision si
vous voulez mettre. Alors, c'est vrai
que c'était bien placé sur le globe pour
faire ça, mais quand même, c'était
audacieux. Et puis le faire comme quand
il est s'est battu Mordicus pour qu'on
ait notre dissuasion nucléaire française
dans les années 60. Alors que les
Américains ont tout fait euh pour que
euh on l'est pas ou qu'on ait la double
clé comme les Britanniques, ils
choisissent à notre place. Quand est-ce
qu'on déclenche ?
Est-ce que vous pensez que 68 ça a été
un peu aidé par les Américains ?
Alors là-dessus, oui, il y a eu des
financements américains. Euh il y a eu
des financements chinois sur M68 parce
que ça contrait des groupes qui étaient
euh favorables à l'URSS. Donc là, il y
avait la rivalité. Il y a eu beaucoup
plus en fait de financement chinois
qu'Américains, mais il y a eu des
financements américains. Euh mais si
vous voulez qu'on parle les influences
américaines entre 1940 et les années 70,
je j'en connais un rayon. C'est pas en
68 que ça s'est le plus déchaîné en
fait.
On viendra sur les ingérences étrangères
un peu plus tard. Ouais, ça s'est
beaucoup déchaîné pendant la guerre et à
la libération où là ils ont voulu nous
imposer l'ameg
et les banilons et les chewinggums.
C'est ça.
Oui. Oui. Mais ça ça faisait partie du
plan Marchal et de l'amgotaging.
Mais ils ont voulu pire que ça nous
imposer le franc Amgot, le faux dollar
et et puis un système et ça avait
beaucoup à voir. Dans le package, il y
avait la la CECA,
la CED, l'armée européenne et le traité
de Rome. Et vous aviez Jean-Menet qui
était dans le package. Jean-Menis qui
était partout y compris quand la France
en 63 fait le traité de l'Élysée Lino
d'ailleurs en parle beaucoup.
Peut-être mais quand mais c'est
l'histoire quand quand Jean-Menis quand
pardon la France de Gaul à Denuer euh
vous savez qui était très séduit par de
Gaulle cit euh 20 janvier 2000 1963
traité de l'Élysée entre la France et
l'Allemagne
qui était quelque chose qui avait rien à
voir avec la construction communautaire
avec les États-Unis et cetera
et que on signe ça qui était un acte
d'indépendance
Au moment où ça passe en ratification
Bundestag, vous avez un certain
Jean-Maiis qui va en Allemagne et qui
fait pression envoyé par Washington pour
faire ajouter un préambule par le
Bundestag allemand à ce traité d'Élysée
en disant tout ce traité s'inscrit bien
sûr dans le cadre de l'OTAN et de
l'indéfectible amitié entre l'Europe et
les États-Unis. Et donc ça annule le
traité de l'Élysée. Et c'est ça en fait
la principale ingérence américaine
pendant ces 30 ans. Ça a continué
ensuite puisque vous souvenez qu'en 94
Mitteran a fait comme une confession à
Jean-Pierre Cabache à la fin de son
mandat, son deuxème mandat en disant
"Nous sommes en guerre, les Français ne
le savent pas, nous sommes en guerre et
cette guerre nous est menée
impitoyablement par les États-Unis
d'Amérique."
Question : C'est quoi la vision de la
France pour C'est quoi la France pour
Floriant Philippo ?
C'est c'est tout. C'est la France, c'est
Ah, vous savez, moi je vibre à la
France. Enfin, je c'est pas une
expression. C'est c'est vraiment Alors,
je élevé dans une famille qui n'est pas
une famille militante. Je n'ai jamais
été emmené à un meeting, on n' jamais
été encarté à la maison. Une famille de
Hussar noir de la République. Mes
parents étaient tous les deux des
instituteurs de l'école publique. Et on
m'a appris très vite, très tôt,
peut-être tout de suite, l'amour de la
France et le respect de la de tout ce
qu'on devait à la France et à tous ceux
qui se sont battu pour la France. Et en
plus, je suis né à côté de l'île. Ville
natale. Il n'y est pas resté longtemps,
mais c'est quand même la ville natale et
on peut visiter sa maison aujourd'hui.
Je vous invite à le faire pour ceux qui
l'ont pas fait, la ville natale du
général de Gaulle. Euh et donc on m'a
aussi, j'ai baigné là-dedans très vite
et très tôt, j'ai eu une admiration à me
mettre les larmes aux yeux pour la pour
la France. Enfin, pour moi, c'est un
pays
qui a une histoire tellement belle,
tellement grande,
avec des gens tellement remarquables,
avec une langue tellement belle, avec
des paysages et tellement
extraordinaires
et que je vois quand je suis un petit
peu à l'étranger, à quel point à tel
point les gens attendent encore
attendent encore de ce pays qui est
devenu aujourd'hui tellement triste et
déprimé et faible que on ne peut que
avoir les larmes yeux et les frissons
quand on pense à la France. Enfin, en
tout cas, moi c'est tout ce qui me
motive et donc c'est pour ça que je suis
pas resté une seconde de plus au Front
National quand on m'a dit "Non, on va
rester dans l'Union européenne, on va
rester dans l'Euro." Mais c'est pas
possible.
Ce sont les attributs même d'un état que
d'avoir une monnaie. Qu'est-ce que ce
sont les attributs d'un état ? La
frontière, la monnaie, l'armée et la
loi. Qu'est-ce qu'on contrôle encore
aujourd'hui ? La loi, non, puisque le
droit est suprational.
La monnaie, non. La frontière, non, on
nen a plus.
L'armée à moitié.
C'est quand même qui peut accepter ça ?
Qui peut accepter ça ? Vous me parlez
des politiques, je sais pas fini de vous
répondre mais moi je regarde avec
beaucoup de sévérité la classe politique
française aujourd'hui. Beaucoup de
sévérité. Alors vous savez, on a des
amis souverainistes très sincères. Ce
sont mes camarades et mes amis de lutte
et de combat et nous sommes vraiment des
frères d'armes. Vraiment des frères
d'armes. Et on coma on tombera au combat
ensemble, on gagnera ensemble. qui
Pierre Géron. C'est un homme d'une
sincère euh remarquablement sincère
euh
des gens que qu'on a eu dans les
manifestations qui sont et qui viennent
régulièrement qui sont des gens je peux
en citer d'autres hein mais des gens que
je crois très sincère je pense Olivier
de la Marche voyez on n'est pas du tout
dans le même domaine. Peut-être qu'
peut-être qu'il m'en voudra dire ça
même. de la marche, il a la France
chevillé au
mais je pense que c'est un homme
remarquable et extrêmement sincère et je
perçois cette sincérité. Parfois, je me
suis trompé un petit peu sur des gens
mais là je pense que je me trompe pas.
Euh
j'ai de l'admiration ensuite pour les
gens que je connais pas encore
j'aimerais bien rencontrer. Je je pense
pas totalement comme lui parce qu'il va
pas jusqu'au Frexite, mais je je suis
assez admiratif de Arnold Mondbourg.
Je trouve que c'est un homme qui est
courageux, qui dit les choses vraies. Je
suis assez admiratif de Dominique de
Villepince sur la politique étrangère,
pas sur le reste, mais je suis moins
d'accord avec lui, mais je le trouve
courageux en tout cas. Euh, il y en a
d'autres et puis chez nous, on a des
gens qui sont d'une d'une intensité,
d'une sincérité remarquable. Et puis il
y a cette frange de souverainistes qui
me disent en privé, et ça je suis
désolé, moi je ne supporte pas, qui me
disent "Je suis d'accord avec toi, il
faut lexit, il y a pas d'autre solution
mais tu comprends, si je veux mes
signatures de maire pour être candidat à
la présidentielle,
je peux pas le dire. Ou si je veux
continuer à passer à la télé, je peux
pas le dire."
Et moi, je me je me permets de leur
dire,
c'est quoi ? C'est de la censure
l'accès aux médias par rapport à ce
sujet là. Nous, on a décidé de nous
faire venir parce que pour avoir un vrai
un vrai point de vue de frxiteur, on a
soit la légende vivante Françoise Linour
qui est déjà passé chez nous, soit vous,
soit Nicolas Dupont. On les voit pas
beaucoup dans les médias.
Alors heureusement du poignon est pas
sur le frexite pour le coup mais
pardon ce serait bien qu'il y soit d'
chacun a créé sa chaîne YouTube pour
pouvoir bypasser ça. La question que je
vous pose c'est pour vous c'est une
censure coordonnée des médias c'est ou
c'est parce que c'est un sujet qui
n'intéresse pas ou parce que vous
représentez personne ou quoi ? Alors,
c'est c'est c'est pas aussi direct que
ça. Genre, il y aurait une autorité
supérieure qui dirait il parle du
frexite, donc censure.
Il y a peut-être un petit peu de ça,
mais c'est pas aussi simple.
C'est d'abord que dès que vousz moi
quand j'interviens sur différents sujets
qu'on parle de la crise agricole
actuelle de l'industrie, de
l'immigration,
de l'Ukraine, de plein de sujets, assez
vite je suis obligé de parler de l'Union
européenne parce que j'estime non pas
par fantaisie ou par goût, c'est que je
suis obligé par logique d'analyse de le
faire.
Or, les formats médiatiques ne sont pas
ou plus adaptés à ça.
Les la plupart aujourd'hui des émissions
politiques vous obligent à rester sur le
terre à terre. Et moi, j'ai remarqué dès
que j'essaie d'élargir en disant
"Attendez, vous me parlez de la crise
agricole mais je suis obligé de vous
parler du sujet européen et les
journalistes ont peur que le
téléspectateur décroche parce que ça
devient trop conceptuel, trop compliqué
et cetera. Il faut rester sur le terre à
terre." Donc il y a beaucoup ça. Donc on
va dire bon bah eux lui on peut pas
l'inviter parce que on sait qu'il va
nous mettre au bout d'un moment dans les
dents son frxite son union en peine et
ça nous c'est juste que ça nous saoule
en fait. C'est même pas plus que ça.
Non ça les saoule eux.
Oui, c'est ce qu' se disent eux. Ça nous
saoule. Alors moi je pense qu'il
sous-estime beaucoup les gens. Je pense
que les gens au contraire sont très en
attente et on voit avec le succès de
chaînes comme la vôtre ou d'autres sur
internet sont très en attente
d'explication de fond
et d'ailleurs les formats médiatiques se
sont beaucoup appauvri puisque moi je me
souviens très bien j'ai rencontré par
hasard mais Emmanuel Todd il y a
quelques mois et on a un petit peu
discuté ensemble et on s'est rappelé une
émission qu'on avait faite ensemble par
hasard pas ensemble ensemble mais on est
arrivé ensemble programmé au même moment
sur la même mission c'est un mot croisé
sur France
et ça durait quand même 1h30 et c'était
alors certes c'était pas en première
partie de soirée mais c'était quand même
à 22h20 donc il y a quand même du monde.
On était plus d'un million un million et
demi à regarder. Enfin il y avait un
million 1 million et demi de
téléspectateurs qui regardaient cette
émission et on avait toute une émission
à l'époque faut-il sortir de l'euro.
Et je me suis dit j'ai dit à Emmanuel T,
j'ai dit mais est-ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui cette émission serait
programmée 1h3 sur le service public
faut-il sortir de l'euro ? Bien sûr que
non ça n'existe plus. Vous voyez il y a
une régression. Alors ça c'est les
explications un petit peu politiques de
fond. Après vous avez des explications
toutes bêtes, c'est qu'il y a un
problème avec l'arcom. C'est qu'on a pas
de temps de parole possible. Moi il y a
des chaînes qui voudraient m'inviter qui
me le disent ou qui voudraient m'inviter
plus souvent qui me disent "Je n'ai pas
le droit avec le service juridique de ma
chaîne qui est sous surveillance de
l'ARCOM. Si je vous invite, je vais
avoir des amendes, des remontrances de
l'ARCOM. Je n'ai pas le droit.
Et donc le débat se fait entre 5 si
partis politiques qui sont représentés
au Parlement. Et vous avez vu les
européennes cette année, vous avez eu 12
débats peut-être ou 15 euh à la
télévision et c'était toujours dans 100
% des cas les sep mêmes têtes de liste.
Je savais même pas ce qu'elles avaient
encore à se dire au bout du 15e débat
parce qu'elles ont dit toujours la même
chose. C'était inintéressant. et vous
auriez mis dedans, vous m'auriez mis,
moi j'aurais dit à certains ou certaines
d'entre elles, "Attends, tu veux arrêter
totalement l'immigration, mais comment
tu vas le faire en restant dans
Schengen, l'Union européenne et la SEDH
? Ça n'est pas possible. Tu veux
augmenter les salaires, mais comment tu
vas le faire en restant dans l'euro ?
Tu veux faire une politique écologique,
on est d'accord ? Mais comment tu vas
faire avec l'Union européenne qui gère
notre commerce et donc qui peut nous
imposer de libre échange ultra pollueur
? Ça m'aurait intéressé. Un mot sur le
mercourd.
Oui,
juste un mot, dites-moi.
Totalement contre.
Totalement contre. Mais il faut dire la
vérité. Les traités européens prévoient
que le commerce est une compétence
exclusive, c'est écrit comme cela dans
les traités européens de la Commission
européenne.
Donc le prochain vote au au Parlement
français, à l'Assemblée nationale sera
une mascarade.
Donc les syndicats agricoles qui ne vont
pas sur le sujet du Frexite emmènent
leur troupe à l'abattoir sans mauvais
jeu de mot, ça ne sert à rien. vraie
solution et la seule solution si on veut
mettre fin au traités de libre échange,
c'est de reprendre en main notre
compétence commerciale, agricole,
alimentaire, c'est-à-dire de sortir
l'Union européenne.
Et comment on fait ça ?
Et ben, on sort de l'Union européenne.
Bonjour, au revoir.
Oui, article 50 des traités. On peut
partir, on s'en va.
On fait quoi avec notre monnaie ?
Et encore, je suis gentil d'utiliser le
article 50 parce que la convention de
Vienne me permet de dénoncer des traités
et c'est un traité, je peux le dénoncer
quand je veux souverainement. Mais
jouons le jeu, faisons comme les
Britanniques l'article 50 qui est prévu
depuis le traité de Lisbonne pour
quitter l'Union européenne. Quittons
l'Union européenne. Nous sommes un pays,
vous savez, si la France quitte l'Union
européenne, il y a plus d'Union
européenne. C'est même pas comme le
Royaume-Uni qui est une île arrivée plus
tard dans les années 70 qui contribuait
peut-être moins que nous et cetera. La
France, c'est un pays géographiquement,
historiquement membre, fondateur,
central, très contributeur
financièrement.
Si la France quitte l'Union européenne
et l'euro, il n'y a plus du jour au
lendemain d'Union européenne et d'euros.
Si l'Allemagne aussi sort,
bien sûr. Tout à fait.
Et donc on appelle
c'est à peu près les deux seuls pays
pour lesquels on peut dire ça. Même pas
l'Italie.
L'Italie s'en sort pas mal d'ailleurs là
en ce moment économiquement parlant par
rapport aux autres. L'Espagne aussi.
Enfin, ils ont beaucoup souffert avant.
Ah oui, clairement ça les a fracassé.
Totalement.
Ouais.
Question. On appelle la Banque de
France. On dit bon coucou dans une
semaine tu vas m'imprimer des billets
avec la tête d'Emmanuel Macron. Euh non
non ni Brigitte
non ce sera pas Macron qui fera le
frexit et puis on mettra pas la tête du
président sur le Ça serait bizarre.
J'ouvre une parenthè
mettons des grands hommes ou des grandes
femmes de France. Le général de Goule
notamment
le français.
Pourquoi pas faire un concours
d'ailleurs les Français pourraient
choisir ?
On fait on fait oui un sondage sur
vous savez j'ai fait une fiction comme
ça. J'ai écrit un livre qui s'appelle
les 100 jours de la révolution qui vient
et dedans je parle de il y a un chapitre
sur la sortie de l'euro et je prévois un
un concours comme ça.
Vous avez lâché une dinguerie sur votre
compte Twitter récemment sur Emmanuel
Macron qui allait démissionner ?
Non, j'ai dit que c'est possible. C'est
un scénario tout à fait possible. Oui.
Donc vos sources en interne, ça veut
dire
Ah bah tous les États-murs politiques ne
travaillent que sur cela. Et c'est
marrant, tous les candidats
tous les candidats sont en train de
passer leur weekend à réunir leur mère.
Il y a beaucoup de déjeunés en ce moment
dans les campagnes.
Leur maman
M res leur pluriel mère qui signe les
parrainages. Et donc en ce moment vous
avez beaucoup de banquers dans les
campagnes de France parce que vous avez
beaucoup de candidats qui sont en train
d'inviter à déjeuner les maires pour
qu'ils ressignent si jamais il y avait
une présidentielle anticipée.
Il pas le droit de se représenter
Emmanuel.
Non, il aurait pas le droit. Il aurait
pas le droit. Alors différence avec la
constitution américaine. Constitution
américaine, vous faites deux mandats au
total.
Donc Trump, c'est fini. Ensuite, euh
Constitution française demanda d'affilé,
même si le deuxième n'est pas terminé,
donc c'est bien son cas. Donc là, il y a
une il y a une un avis du Conseil
constitutionnel cet été qui a dit non,
il pourrait pas se représenter. Donc il
pourra pas se représenter. Par contre,
s'il y a un autre est élu entre-temps,
il peut se représenter ensuite.
Il démissionnerait pourquoi Emmanuel ?
Juge je peux parler des parages un
instant, mais bon je
je vous autorise.
C'est un un énorme sujet ça.
Sauf si vous proposez à François Esdino
de se retrouver ici.
Donc si vous lui proposez, je vous
laisse parler des parrainages.
Ça veut dire quoi ? Ben
proposez-lui de vous rejoindre sur
Serview pour discuter un peu de ce qui
se passe.
Non mais les débats entre nous, c'est
pas hyper intéressant. On pense la même
chose à peu près.
Mais on peut le faire. Ce sera un
dialogue surtout pour se dire pourquoi
pourquoi on travaille pas ensemble. Mais
c'est pas c'est à lui de répondre, c'est
pas à moi parce que moi je veux
les parrainages.
Alors les parrainages, c'est un énorme
sujet. Parrainage au départ, vous savez
c'était 100 sous le général de Gaulle,
c'était des maires maires et conseillers
régionaux. Non, à l'époque ça existait
pas conseillers régionaux, conseillers
département généraux comme on disait et
les parlementaires. Et c'était anonyme
et puis c'est passé à 500 et puis sous
Hollande c'est passé à 500 publics et
puis entre-temps on a fait
l'intercommunalité.
Donc entre-temps, ce n'est plus du tout
un filtre, ce qui était bien au départ,
un filtre de représentativité, ce qui
était normal. Vous allez pas avoir 3000
candidats à la présidentielle surtout
que c'est la seule élection où vous avez
à la fin l'égalité médiatique. Vous
pouvez pas organiser l'égalité
médiatique si vous avez 3000 candidats.
Chacun aura 2 secondes, ça marchera pas.
Euh mais aujourd'hui, ça n'est plus un
filtre de représentativité, c'est un
filtre oligarchique.
J'en veux pour preuve 2022 où à la fin
ni Mélenchon, ni Marine Le Pen, ni
Zemour, qui sont pourtant
représentatifs, quoi qu'on pense d'eux,
euh n'avait leur signature. Reprenez les
articles de presse de l'époque, ils
n'avaient pas leur signature. C'est
François Baou qui est intervenu et qui a
dit "Je vais distribuer les signatures."
Mais François Baou, c'est qui ? le
pouvoir, c'est un allié de Macron. Donc
c'est le pouvoir sortant qui a choisi
ses candidats officiels.
Sûr de ça ?
Ah bien sûr, vous retrouverez les
dépêches de l'époque. Moi, j'ai pas eu
le droit à distribution de François
Baou. J'ai pas eu le droit et comme
d'autres hein, je suis pas le seul, mais
eux, ils ont eu le droit.
On peut pas continuer comme ça. Élection
après élection, vous avez de moins en
moins de maires qui signent parce que
pour eux, c'est insupportable. Ils ont
des pressions ensuite de
l'intercommunalité, du département. du
préfet de la région, des menaces sur les
subventions, des problèmes parfois avec
leur conseil municipal et cetera. C'est
horrible pour eux.
Pour nous candidats, moi j'ai tenté sans
grands sans grand espoir mais mais et
sans succès, j'ai tenté d'en avoir et
très vite, je me suis retiré et j'ai
laissé la liberté au maire qui voulait
me parraîner de remettre dans la nature
les signatures parce que sinon j'allais
congeler pour rien des signatures. Et
en fait, c'est épouvantable parce qu'il
vous explique tout ça. Bon, puis vous
avez même des gens maintenant qui sont
payés pour aller chercher des
signatures. Enfin, vous rentrez dans un
un système horrible hein. Ils vous font
ils font payer au candidat 500 € par
signature pour vous en ramener et
cetera. Donc vous rentrez dans un
système commercial.
Ça c'est juste pas possible. Un
peu comme la startup nation pour aller
chercher des subventions. C'est ça
exactement. Donc moi, je propose qu'on
arrête tout ça, qu'on rende service au
maire qui n'en peuvent plus de cette
responsabilité, qu'ils ne veulent plus
parinage citoyen. Vous aviez la
commission Josepin au début des années
2000 qui avait fait un rapport là-dessus
qui a proposé 150000 signatures de
français inscrits sur les listes
électorales issues de x départements
différents pour pouvoir être candidat à
la présidentielle. Moi, je propose
100000 100000. Je vais lancer une
campagne nationale pour passer au
parrainage citoyen en écrivant à tous
les maires qui n'ont pas signé en 2022
et c'est une large majorité en leur
disant moi j'ai un système je vous
demande de le de le porter s'il vous
plaît. Je vais écrire à tous les
parlementaires parce que je n'oublie pas
que tous les 5 ans l'essentiel des
partis politiques, sauf ceux qui ont
aucun problème mais le RN et le FI et ça
ont tous dit en 2022 que c'était
insupportable ce système. Donc je vais
leur rappeler leur déclaration de
l'époque en leur disant donc soyez de
notre côté et je vais lancer des
pétitions nationales et puis des
campagnes de terrain la sortie des des
métros sur les marchés sortie des usines
et tout au français pour dire passons au
parrainage citoyen.
Rétons avec cette affaire parce que là
ça n'est plus un filtre de
représentativité, c'est un filtre
oligarchique. Voyez donc voilà donc vrai
sujet et je sais pas pourquoi on en est
arrivé là mais on en est arrivé là mon
cher Sky.
Revenons revenons à la France.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour
maintenant essayer d'avoir un peu plus
de paix en Europe ? Est-ce qu'il faut
récupérer notre souveraineté de parole
diplomatique ? Est-ce qu'il faut essayer
de d'appeler les copains en disant voilà
on y va franchement contre les Russes
c'estàd rentrer en guerre ou on essaie
d'avoir une diplomatie un peu plus
efficiente ?
Non on on récupère enfin ce que vous
appelez avoir un peu plus de de paix
puisqueà priori on l'a la paix. On n'est
pas la France n'est normalement pas en
guerre. En tout cas c'est ce qu'on nous
a dit.
La France
doit récupérer une diplomatie.
Aujourd'hui, la France n'a plus de
diplomatie, ce qui est normal. Un
protectorat n'a pas de diplomatie.
Peut pas avoir de diplomatie quand vous
êtes un protectorat. Donc, il est normal
qu'aujourd'hui on n plus de diplomatie.
Vous savez, une diplomatie, c'est pas
que des mots et une armée. L'armée est
très importante dans la diplomatie, mais
c'est pas que ça. Je donne un exemple
très concret. Quand vous allez voir un
pays que vous dites voilà, j'ai besoin
de négocier sur tel sujet diplomatique,
il y a toujours dans une négociation des
contreparties mais que vous ne maîtrisez
plus votre commerce
parce que ça peut être
su ou non su, ça peut être un élément
d'échange.
Vous avez peut-être des choses à
négocier en terme d'accord commercial
avec un pays en contrepartie d'une
position diplomatique qui peut vous
arranger mais que vous n'avez plus
levier commercial puisque vous l'avez
donné à la Commission européenne
suivez mon regard la France ben vous
êtes amputé d'une partie de votre
diplomatie
c'est je pourrais vous dire la même
chose sur l'immigration comment
voulez-vous gérer la question migratoire
si vous ne gérez pas les autres sujets
on verra plus tard la question
d'immigration
oui mais c'est c'est c'est un
raisonnement général c'est si vous
n'avez pas la souveraineté en entier.
OK. La diplomatie française,
il y a plein de sujets que vous ne
pouvez pas gérer.
La diplomatie française, vous la
considérez comment là ? Parce que amputé
inexistante complètement
amputé. C'està-dire que là on est amputé
en dessous du genou ou au-dessus du
genou ?
Mais en dessous de la cheville.
Non mais en dessous de la cheville ça va
parce qu'il nous reste le genou non ?
Ah non voulait dire dans ce sens là.
Oui. Non moi je pensais que je pensais
que on allait tomber dans l'autre sens.
Non vous avez jamais appareillé un
amputé. Vous
pardon
vous avez jamais appareillé un amputé.
Non, au-dessus du genou, c'est
problématique quand même. Après, il y a
auudessus de la hanche, mais
la diplomatie française aujourd'hui
n'existe plus.
Nous avions, vous savez, la France,
c'est un pays qui se caractérise.
C'est un pays occidental, mais pas que
occidental. C'est un pays qui est par
ailleurs présent sur tous les océans du
monde, qui a un outre mer, qui a une
histoire,
qui a une tradition qui est une
tradition de parler à tout le monde. Bah
on avait on avait
Non, mais je je dis je je suis dans le
la permanence de l'histoire si vous
voulez de ce qui est un peu l'âme de la
France. Nous sommes un pays qui euh
donner des exemples. On a parlé en
premier, on a reconnu la Chine en
premier. Oui. Bah le général de Gaul
c'est c'est assez mais mais oui bien
sûr. Le général de Gaulle reconnaissance
de la République populaire de Chine son
d'ailleurs on relâche toujours un peu de
pognon chaque année là au Chinois pour
l'aide ou Ouais l'aide Oui ce qui n'a
aucun sens. Oui de l'aide publique tout
ça on devrait arrêter. Oui bien sûr.
Mais euh nous avons également su contrer
les guerres américaines. Alors soit le
Vietnam soit le général de Gaulle mais
en 2003 Jacques Chirac Dominique de
Villepince sur l'Irak.
Il y avait encore même sous Miteran le
fameux golomilitéisme qui est un peu
surfait mais bon qui avait encore une
prétention d'indépendance.
Nous n'avons rallé le commandement
intégré de l'OTAN que sous SarkoZi en
2008 pas avant. Donc il y avait si vous
voulez une capacité la fameuse politique
arabe de la France une capacité de
parler à tout le monde qui faisait notre
force et le respect en face.
C'est-à-dire que nous n'étions pas vu
comme le 51e état des États-Unis parce
que sinon on va directement voir le
maître. Ils n'ont pas son domestique.
Non
mais c'est pas déjà pris le 51e état.
Je crois qu'ils sont 50 aujourd'hui.
Oui. Non mais c'est pas non il y a
peut-être Israël entre-temps. Non
parce que là là sur la guerre en Israël
le cesser le feu
les États-Unis ont dit
oui ils sont très très liés bien sûr
mais vous avez le Royaume- Muni qui est
extrêmement lié y compris par c'est le
déclenchement de son arme nucléaire.
Mais mais mais par l'histoire si on dit
si on dit le Royaume-Uni, on peut
rajouter les five.
Oui oui, bien sûr. Australie, c'est ça.
Nouvelle-Zélande, c'est ça. Ouais. Euh
mais là, vous savez d'ailleurs qu'ils
veulent créer une CIA européenne, hein,
sur le modèle des Five Eyes.
Et on mettrait qui à la tête ?
Ursula Funder Lyon. Non, je sais pas. Et
donc derrière quelqu'un d'autre à
Washington. Mais euh
quel regard vous portez sur le le con ?
Non, la diplomatie, attends juste, la
diplomatie française, elle doit être
libre. Donc pour ça, il faut qu'on ait
un pays souverain parce que ça n'existe
pas une diplomatie libre sans pays
souverain. Donc moi, je ne conçois pas
la possibilité d'une diplomatie libre
sans être un pays souverain. Donc en
étant dans l'Union européenne. Mais moi,
je suis favorable à ce qu'on quitte
l'Union européenne et l'OTAN. Voilà, je
pense que l'OTAN aurait dû disparaître
en même temps que la guerre froide. Je
suis intimement persuadé. Vous me direz,
on fait pas parler les morts, mais on
fait vivre un héritage. Je suis
intimement persuadé que le général de
Gaulle aurait quitté l'OTAN à la fin de
la guerre froide. Parce que certes, vous
savez le général de Gaulle,
c'est une pensée complexe.
Il a pas lâché les États-Unis lors de la
crise de Cuba.
Lui, il voulait empêcher la construction
du mur de Berlin. C'était le seul
d'ailleurs. Il a pas eu les Britanniques
et les Américains avec lui. Il a dit
d'ailleurs, on m'aurait écouté, il y
aurait jamais eu ce mur de Berlin. Donc
il savait aussi être punchy par rapport
à l'URSS quand il fallait, mais il
savait l'être tout autant par rapport
aux Américains parce que c'était un vrai
français libre.
Donc il a pas quitté l'OTAN, il a il a
il a quitté le commandement intégré, il
a viré les bases américaines quelques
mois plus tard, 66, on sait tout ça. Euh
mais je suis persuadé qu'à la fin de la
guerre froide, 91, il aurait quitté le
l'OTAN. Et et un pays comme la France
qui est quand même un des plus grands
pays du monde, un des plus vieux pays du
monde, qui a une tradition militaire
diplomatique, séculaire et peut-être
même millénaire, a toutes les capacités
évidemment de gérer sa diplomatie. Je
pense que ce serait un pays utile
aujourd'hui au monde. La France serait
un pays utile au monde dans toutes les
crises si on avait une puissance capable
de de parler à la Russie et à l'Ukraine,
de parler à la Russie et aux États-Unis,
de parler à Israël et à l'Iran,
de parler à Israël et au monde arabe, ce
serait bien.
Là, on parle à qui là ? On passe pour
des clouses aux yeux de
On parle, on parle on parle le matin à
au bureau américain qui nous dit ce
qu'on doit dire. Point barre.
Non mais ça c'est de la supputation.
Non, c'est de la vérité.
Quand vous avez Attendez.
Vous avez on ne sait pas qui d'ailleurs
a autorisé le le le le tir en Russie sur
le sol russe contre la Russie de missile
à longue portée ATA CMS.
C'est pas Macron qui a dit qu'il était
d'accord ?
Bien sûr,
mais Biden aussi.
C'est pas Biden qui l'a dit.
C'est qui ?
On sait pas. C'est un ce sont des hauts
responsables américains anonymes dans la
presse. Point barre. Même les
Macron et Schulz, on dit d'accord.
Non, Schulz non. Scholz il veut même pas
envoyer des missiles à longue portée.
C'est les britanniques et les et les
Français. Donc scalp pour nous et eux,
je sais plus comment ils s'appellent
leur missile qui sont d'accord. Mais
Macron, il n'a même pas attendu une
décision formelle qui n'est toujours pas
venue je crois de la Maison Blanche ou
du Pentagone. Il s'est contenté
d'articles de presse repris dans Reuters
AP et la FP de haut responsable anonyme
américain pour dire "C'est superbe, on y
va pareil, allons-y." Mais
youpi !
Mais mettez-vous à la place des
Ukrainiens.
H
Ils sont un peu bombardés méchamment,
non ? Il faut peut-être pouvoir
neutraliser les chaînes logistiques
derrière les les lignes de front.
Cette histoire est complexe.
Je vous écoute. Vous connaissez le
dossier un peu ?
Je connais le dossier.
Bien, pas bien
bien.
Qu'est-ce qu'il a dit Poutine tout à
l'heure là sur le fait que des États qui
permettent de taper la Russie ?
Non, il a dit en septembre ça.
Ah ça c'était en septembre.
Il a dit oui, on considérerait qu'on est
en guerre directement contre toute
l'OTAN.
Et donc il
oui parce que si vous envoyezorise
si vous voulez le missile longue porté
c'est pas que le missile il est guidé
par satellite donc vous avez des
satellites américains.
Il y a du personnel
du personnel. Voilà
donc là là il peut s'autoriser de
frapper des
il aurait envoyé un missile
intercontinental. Ouais.
Non il l'a envoyé ce matin.
Il l'a envoyé. Ouais. Moi je sais pas où
on en est dans les A ou parce que je
vous avoue que j'ai lâché mon depuis que
je vous ai rencontré, j'ai lâché mon fil
d'actu. Non, ça date de ce matin, il a
réveillé il a réveillé les leaders
européens à 5h du matin.
Non parce que j'ai vu la France qui
disait je vous dis je vous dis auré
parce que la France a dit si c'est
confirmé alors c'est très grave. Le Koré
a dit ça le Koré a dit ça Jean-Noel
Barre.
Non mais je
bah oui mais c'est le Corcé.
Excusez-moi, j'y peux plus rien. C'est
bien leoré officiel aujourd'hui. Bon,
Jean Noël Barreau qui arrive à nous
faire regretter Stéphane Séjourné.
Je sais pas ça
non
parce que Stéphanné bon vous me direz il
faut rester gentil sur la chaîne vous
m'avez dit donc pas rester gentil
mais il avait un problème avec la
maîtrise de la langue française.
Dyslexique c'est c'est évident.
Non non non non ça non. et respectons
les dyslexiques.
Ne confondons pas celui qui a pas fait
assez de bled et de de Bécherell avec le
dyslexique.
Fils d'instituteur qui vous parle.
Donc Poutine peut s'autoriser maintenant
à frapper des capitales européennes.
Mais non mais arrêtons-le.
Non
mais non mais vous croyez vraiment que
Poutine a envie d' d'envahir l'Allemagne
et la France
d'abord l'Allemagne la France on verra.
C'est ça.
Bien sûr. Bon, on lui à la limite il
fasse l'Allemagne, on s'en fiche passer
par la Pologne.
On s'en fiche de l'Allemagne. Mais mais
non, vous inquiétez pas.
Est-ce que vous avez peur que Non, non,
je vais rien attendre du tout. Je vais
laisser terminer ma phrase.
Est-ce que vous pensez que le fait que
la Russie je me fais l'avoquer du
diable, est-ce que vous pensez que
maintenant l'économie de guerre russe,
elle va elle va s'arrêter, elle va pas
s'arrêter ? Une économie de guerre, vous
le savez, ça demande toujours du sang
pour continuer. Hm
hm.
La Russie pour vous est passée en
économie de guerre ? Oui. Non.
Oui.
Comment on va faire pour calmer les
choses ? On va laisser la mayonnaise
continue à monter. Il y a c'est 4 jours
quand Macron et son copain britannique
ont dit "OK, vous pouvez taper en
profondeur". Carmer. Ouais.
Tout de suite, on s'est dit l'Ukraine va
en prendre plein la tête.
Ce matin, il y a un ICBM
qui tombe sur l'Ukraine qui continue le
plan de Poutine, c'est-à-dire
neutraliser pendant l'hiver des
complexes énergétiques,
des capacités à produire de
l'électricité, de la chaleur et gens
passaient les meilleurs.
C'est la mayonnaise qui est en train de
tourner vinaigre.
De l'autre côté, on a des vieux
soviétologues qui ont jamais foutu le
pied en Russie ou qui ont toujours frayé
avec des sexes des des cercles d'expatri
et ou des contestataires minoritaires
qui conseillent nos militaires, qui
conseillent nos politiques.
H
là, c'est en train de partir en sucette.
Oui, c'est ce qui est voulu. Non,
mais c'est quoi qui est voulu ? Qui veut
vouloir quoi ? Qui qui eux sait quoi ?
Bah ce il me semble qu'en avril 2022
à Istanbul, il y a un plan de paix qui
est possible, que le gouvernement
ukrainien est d'accord, que la Russie
est d'accord et qu'on envoie Boris
Johnson et l'OTAN planter ce plan de ce
plan de paix. Donc c'était donc c'est
que c'est voulu. Quand vous venez
d'avoir une élection aux États-Unis,
Trump a gagné largement. Trump il a
gagné sur une idée quand même, personne
peut dire le contraire. Il a gagné sur
un plan de paix. C'est ce qu' entendu
les électeurs américains, ils savent
pourquoi ils ont voté.
Il a surtout parlé des questions
économiques aussi.
Ils a parlé beaucoup aussi de tout ça.
Il a parlé aussi beaucoup de tout ça, le
fameux je réglerai ça en 24 heures ou
48h et cetera. En tout cas, la paix et
pas la poursuite de la guerre et que on
se permet pendant la période de
transition inédit, c'est inédit parce
qu'il est investi le 20 janvier. Une
personne en tout cas des gens on sait
pas qui décident des haut responsables
anonymes américains décident qu'on va
autoriser alors que Biden avait toujours
refusé jusqu'ici le l'utilisation du
missile à longue porté. et bien qu'on
veut envenimer la situation alors même
qu'on sait qu'il y a un président qui
attend qui va prendre le pouvoir qui
sera sur une ligne diamétralement
opposée.
C'est peut-être aussi pour calmer les
ardeurs de Poutine à défoncer la tête de
l'Ukraine. L'Ukraine c'est une affaire
compliquée.
L'Ukraine c'est une affaire où vous avez
eu en 2004 Révolution Orange puis en
2014 Euromaïdane
la CIA présente qui a décidé de
remplacer des pouvoirs jugés trop
prusses. Yanukovic par
Yuchenko,
Porochenko et cetera. Ensuite
ceux qui sont pas encore convaincus de
cela, je vais vous dire, il y a un film
très simple produit par Canal Plus,
c'est pas Patriote Magazine, c'est Canal
Plus. Il est sur YouTube en libre accès.
Il s'appelle les masques de la
révolution de Paul Morera. Vous allez
voir tout ça, ce qui s'est passé en
2014. Vous allez voir le rôle de
Victoria Noland qui était ultra présente
euh qui distribuait ses petits pains,
hein. Euh
avec les frites,
non, des petits pains, je crois, au
chocolat. Il y avait pas John McKen qui
était sur le Il y avait aussi d'ailleurs
des Français qui étaient là-bas. Il y a
BHL qui était là et on les voit euh et
toujours bah voilà la bande et vous la
bande de Libide enfin voilà et vous
retrouverez ces gens-là et euh il se
trouve que on
vous dites la bande
parce que parce que moi pour moi BHL
c'est scandaleux qui sont encore invités
à la télévision. Excusez-moi.
Ça diton pour la paix.
Non non non mais pour la paix
vous avez vu la la Libye ? Moi, j'en
parle tranquillement parce que moi en
temps réel, en 2011, j'étais contre la
guerre de Libye et j'avais annoncé
modestement parce que j'avais pas une
voix publique, mais ce qui allait se
passer et ça a été dramatique la Libye,
il y a eu de l'esclavage ensuite, du
trafic d'êtres humain, l'ouverture des
voies migratoires, des voix de
djihadistes, un pays, un état
complètement détruit. Je n'ai aucune
sympathie pour Kaddafi, vous l'imaginez
bien.
Les généraux de Kaddafi qui ont été
formés d'autres groupes, ils sont partis
avec des armes un peu partout. Donc si
vous voulez pour moi un BHL et puis on
peut dire il y a plein de plein de
sujets sur lesquels comme ça où ça a été
quand même euh je peux revenir aussi à
l'histoire de la Youugoslavie et tout le
reste. Pour moi un BHL qui a son rond de
serviette sur les plateaux télé où on
lui déroule le tapis rouge alors que je
suis désolé ce type pour moi allez je
vais pas sur votre chaîne on doit rester
gentil mais
c'est pas gentil
non mais il a du rouge sur les mains.
Respectueux dire respectueux
je suis respectueux je dis ce que je
pense. évité de dénigrer les gens que ce
soit sourcé, carré, cubique, ça c'est
l'histoire c'est sourcé mais je pour moi
mon opinion personnelle ça n'engage que
moi. Cet homme ne devrait plus pouvoir
avoir libre expression comme il l'a
parce qu'il a fait un tort considérable
à beaucoup de gens, des vrais gens, des
gens qui meurent et il a fait un tort
considérable à l'image de la France dans
le monde. Alors, vous avez tout ça
votre à votre avis, c'est votre point de
vue.
Oui, je l'ai dit et redit et de toute
façon, je n'exprime que mon point de
vue. Il y a aucun problème là-dessus.
Euh donc 2014, vous avez cette affaire.
Vous avez ensuite un gouvernement qui
pendant 8 ans ukrainien bombarde
le Donbas qui est l'est interdite par
les Russes alors qu'on sait que
l'Ukraine est un pays vous savez
l'Ukraine à part quelques mois après la
révolution 17 c'est un pays qui n'a
jamais été indépendant sauf en 91 bien
sûr he depuis 91 il l'était par la chute
de de l'Union soviétique mais sinon dans
son histoire non ça a été autrichiens
hongrois polonais
russe et quand vous dites ça est-ce que
est-ce que derrière
donc c'est un pays compliqué
quand vous dites Est-ce que
vous vous faites harceler par des gens
prourainiens qui vous disent "Tu
racontes n'importe quoi ?"
Non, pas pas tu raconte n'importe quoi.
Non non. Alors moi maintenant au début
oui. Même au début parfois vous savez,
on faisait des manifes pour la paix et
on va probablement en refaire. On avait
au début des mini contreemanifs. Quand
je dis mini, c'est que nous on était
5000, ils étaient 12. Euh mais pas pour
nous contredire, juste pour essayer avec
des portes-vois nous de nous empêcher de
parler. Mais bon, ça nous a moi ça, vous
savez, de toute façon, peu importe, je
suis sensible à aucune intimidation et
euh tant que je pense que j'ai des
arguments et des choses à dire dans le
respect parce que vous savez les
premières victimes de ce qui se passe en
ce moment, c'est les Ukrainiens et les
ceux qu'on envoie mourir pour rien en ce
moment. Ceux qu'on enlève dans la rue
pour jeter dans des buses.
Les civils ukrainiens, les civils
russes, pareil. Mais bien sûr toutes ces
vous avez vu la ce qu'ils appellent en
Ukraine la buscification, c'estàd qu'on
emmène on on enlève des gars, même le
monde en parle maintenant et on les
jette dans des bus emmenés au front puis
ils vont mourir. Enfin c'est
épouvantable. Nous on se ruine parce
qu'on envoie des milliards plus un pay
très corrompu. Euh et on continue, on
entretient, on entretient, on entretient
parce que
parce que vous avez un certain une
certaine caste américaine, c'est la
doctrine Brezinski. Bon, le grand
échiqué, tout le monde connaît en le
livre en bon je sais pas en 1997, il y a
un livre qui est sorti Brzinski qui a
été un homme très influent qui avait
conseillé au début des années 80
président américain sur la politique
étrangère et qui a qui a expliqué en
terme de doctrine qu'il fallait
absolument séparer grâce à à l'Ukraine
qui est un point stratégique, la Russie
des pays européens en terme énergétique,
en terme économique et que ça allait
être favorable à la perpétuation parce
que c'est la grande crainte à ce
moment-là des États-Unis, de la
puissance américaine au 21e siècle qui
effectivement est en déclin, même si
elle reste très très forte. Euh et donc
pour un nouveau siècle américain et
comme on disait à l'époque, il fallait
absolument euh mettre en place cette
affaire. Donc, on a eu
une série en permanence de de
d'interventions, je cité 2004 l'Euridane
pour que l'Ukraine ne soit ne tombe
jamais du côté russe, reste dans le camp
occidental avec maintenant des pressions
très fortes pour qu'elle intègre l'Union
européenne, ce qui serait une folie
totale hein, en terme agricole,
économique, industriel,
budgétaire pour nous. Enfin, je on se
rend même pas compte de la folie absolue
que ce serait d'intégrer ce pays euh qui
a un un revenu moyen de 200 € par an,
par peut-être un peu plus 400 et qui a
en tout cas un un SMIC, enfin
l'équivalent d'un revenu minimum à 150 €
par mois euh qui nous concurrence, on le
sait, avec le poulet et tout le reste en
terme agricole, de le faire et qui est
par ailleurs très corrompu le faire
venir dans l'Union européenne, mais ça
il y a des pressions en ce sens. Donc
l'Ukraine a toujours été
instrumentalisée par une caste
américaine et il a fallu que cette
guerre soit déclenchée. Alors certains
diront "Poutine est tombé dans le piège"
peut-être. Ça c'est une analyse qu'on
peut faire que j'entends. Mais il se
trouve qu'on peut pas considérer que
tout a commencé le 24 février 2022 quand
la Russie et je le reconnais la Russie a
attaqué l'Ukraine, on est d'accord
là-dessus mais ça n'a pas commencé là.
Vous aviez des gens qui étaient
bombardés depuis 8 ans dans des régions
russophones où les enfants n'avaient pas
le droit d'aller à l'école, n'avaient
pas le droit de parler leur propre
langue russe et où des coups d'état
étaient menés tous les 10 ans pour
empêcher les gens de choisir
régulièrement leur gouvernement. Et donc
à un moment et on leur dit finalement
contrairement à toutes les promesses
faites à la suite de l'Union Soviétique
notamment par Bush confirmé par Roland
Duma qui était alors ministre français
des affaires étrangères que ces pays ne
rejoindraient jamais l'OTAN et
finalement on leur dit que peut-être ils
vont rejoindre l'OTAN. Donc la Russie a
fini par s'énerver.
Je vous je vous ouvre une parenthèse.
Bon, ça
je vous parenthèse. Je me fais la du
diable.
La Russie filit peut-être du blé en
sous-main pour exciter tout le monde
pour que ce soit une région
sécessionniste, que de l'autre côté ils
leuront ils leur ont mis une grosse
pâtée que ça a duré 8 ans et que la
Russie armée de l'autre côté que ça
monte ça monte ça monte. Je voudrais que
on revienne sur l'aspect énergétique.
Je suis pas sûr que vous avez besoin de
corrompre cette région parce que par
histoire par l'histoire cette région
était très russophone, très tourné vers
la Russie. Donc moi, je suis pas
persuadé de cela. Je ne attention, je je
je ne considère qu'il n'y a aucun
innocent et aucun ange dans les
relations internationales. Je ne
considère pas que la Russie soit un pays
que soit l'Immaculé Conception, ni que
ni qu'il y ait très bien l'Immaculé
Conception, dites-moi. Non. Oui. Voilà.
ni qu'il y ait de diable ou de ou et
d'ange dans les dans les relations
internationales. Ce que disait aussi le
général de Gaul, les États n'ont pas
d'amis, n'ont que des intérêts. Donc il
faut être très très réaliste, il faut
relativiser tout cela.
Rentrons plus profondément.
Mais oui, non mais juste sur sur votre
affaire euh il se trouve que
enfin l'affaire dont dont nous parlions
en ce moment, c'estàd l'affaire
ukrainienne, qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire aujourd'hui ?
Arrêter de financer d'armer, arrêter
l'escalade comme nous sommes en train de
le faire. Il faut offrir la gé
Est-ce qu'il faut offrir la géopolitique
? Est-ce qu'il faut offrir la
géopolitique pour les nules à Emmanuel
Macron ?
Pas des munitions antipersonnelles, des
des mines antipersonnelles. Vous avez vu
ça quand même ? Oui, mais paraît-il que
c'est des des mines euh qui ont un
autodestructrices,
c'est ça ?
Oui, mais Handicap International a
répondu à cela et en disant à chaque
fois que un gouvernement nous a vendu
que c'était des mines euh à durée de vie
limitée, c'était il y avait il y a
tellement de défaillances techniques.
Il a un problème de conception.
Oui, mais vous savez, c'est pas drôle
cette affaire parce que ça vous savez
qui
c'est les protocoles d'Otawa, c'est ça ?
Les accords d'Otawa. Oui, mais les
États-Unis ne sont pas signataires, ni
la Russie d'ailleurs. L'Ukraine, oui.
L'Ukraine, oui. La France oui. La France
a mollement dit, je vais reprendre le
terme exact de Jean-Noël Barreau sur
cette affaire. Pour moi, c'est pas une
affaire anodine parce que 80 % des
victimes des mines antipersonnelles, ce
sont des civils et 35 %, ce sont des
enfants. Chiffre de handicap
international. La France a dit
là-dessus, nous ne sommes pas alignés
avec les États-Unis. trouverez vous
trouvez que c'est à la hauteur ?
Ça fait un peu mimol quand même non ?
Ouais, très très mi. Ouais.
Revenons plus profondément dans le
sujet. La clé de lecture énergétique, de
souveraineté énergétique, de
consommation énergétique et donc
d'économie.
Euh élargissons et prenons de la
hauteur.
C'est un match à mort pour des
ressources. H
c'est la chute de l'Occident parce que
on est en train de courir après les
ressources et les matières premières.
Comment ça va se terminer cette histoire
?
Je j'ai pas de je suis pas en état de
panique sur ce sujet-là.
Surtout pas notre pays qui a développé
une industrie électronucléaire.
Elle vient d'où l'uranium ?
Ça vient d'Australie. Ça vient de si ça
vient de
ça vient de chez Vladimir un peu non ?
C'est pas les trois il est pas dans les
trois premiers. Euh il y a d'autres pays
qui sont avant, je me souviens plus.
Enfin la communauté regarder mais euh
l'U235,
l'isotope 235 puisquon est aujourd'hui
qu'on aime bien pour faire du plutonium.
Oui mais c'est celui qui reprend moins
d'un % de si on avait la 4e génération.
Ah si on avait pas arrêté le programme
Astrid. Si monsieur Macron en 2019
n'avait pas arrêté le programme Astrid,
on pourrait être sur l'isotope 238 qui
représente plus de 99 %. Euh mais enfin
peut-être pas tout de suite mais en tout
cas on y travaillerait de manière un peu
plus intensive donc ce qui réglerait
aussi pas mal de ce problème. Je suis
pas très inquiet là-dessus parce que
nous avons plusieurs sources
d'approvisionnement. Ce qui est très
dangereux en terme d'approvisionnement
manière générale sur les matières
premières ou l'énergie c'est quand vous
avez une seule source. Combien de vous
êtes dépendant
combien de réacteurs actifs en ce moment
dans le monde ? dans le monde,
je sais pas combien il y en a. 300 pif
au pif
quelques centaines.
450 et des patates 456
j'allais dire quelques centaines. Ouais
mais
pas mal et il y en a combien qui sont en
projet ?
Pas tant que ça. Je cis qu'il y en a un
aux États-Unis,
en Chine un peu. Euh puis en France, on
a soit-disant des projets. J'espère
qu'ils seront tenus. Il Agnè Panier
uneché qui veut recruter 100000 talents
pour l'industrie électronucléaire.
Ouais, on a du boulot là-dessus.
Et on a du boulot, on a du boulot sur
les Est-ce que nos politiques sont pas
un petit peu des
ménestrelles de la parlotte
blindé d'éléments de langage pour tenir
le
Non mais là vous êtes très gentil. Non
non mais là c'est très grave qui s'est
passé.
Je sais je sais que je suis très gentil.
Ouais je sais.
Attendez de voir. J'ai commencé à
m'énerver. Ouais, mais pas avec moi.
Mais non, mais avec eux, il faut
s'énerver parce que honnêtement, vous
savez, j'étais conseiller régional grand
est grand est, il y a l'Alsace,
l'Alsace, il y a Fenheim
comme président de groupe, d'abord FN,
puis j'ai créé mon groupe les Patriotes.
J'ai fait régulièrement des motions pour
condamner, elle n'était elle n'avait pas
encore eu lieu pour essayer d'empêcher
la fermeture de Fenheim.
La fermeture de Fessenheim, largement
pensé comme un cadeau à l'Allemagne
puisque c'est à la frontière
est absolument scandaleuse.
Et ceux qui s'en sortent aujourd'hui en
passant à travers les gouttes alors
qu'ils ont été décisionnaires sur
Fenheim, je trouve que le peuple
français et ses parlementaires sont très
gentils parce que ça a des incidences
extrêmement graves sur notre
indépendance énergétique et sur notre
capacité industrielle. C'est une
forfaiture.
Ah oui, c'est une forfaiture. Oui.
Ça veut dire quoi fortfaiture ?
Une trahison. C'est une trahison.
Un manquement à sa position, à son rang.
Oui.
Oui. On a une obligation de résultat. On
n pas une obligation de moyens quand on
est en charge de l'énergie et de
l'industrie de la France et son
indépendance nationale. À force, quand
on est président de la République et
qu'on a constitutionnellement
l'obligation de défendre l'indépendance
de la France. Vous me direz, je suis pas
certain que beaucoup de présidents de la
République dernièrement se souviennent
de tout cela, mais
ils ont fermé Fenheim. Macron, il y a
toujours les tweets qui sont toujours
là, annonce "On va fermer je ne sais
combien de réacteurs d'ici 2035 et puis
3 ans plus tard, on nous dit on va
ouvrir 6 + 8 réacteurs."
Très bien.
Attendez, c'est
moi j'ai pas varié là-dessus. Moi, j'ai
toujours défendu notre industrie
électronucléaire et nos barrages
hydroélectriques parce que je vous
signale qu'à cause d'une directive
européenne, signaler
depuis 10 ans, nous n'investissons plus
dans nos barrages hydroélectriques alors
qu'en France nous en avons beaucoup et
de grande qualité grâce à EDF qui est
une remarquable entreprise.
Va peut-être les vendre. Non
non, on est obligé de les privatiser si
on bouge le petit doigt. Si on investit,
Bruxelles nous oblige à ouvrir la
privatisation. Donc on investit plus.
Donc on les laisse crever. Bah donc on
les laisse crever avec peut-être un jour
d'ailleurs donc ils perdent en en
rendement et peut-être un jour il y a
déjà eu une rupture il y a pas très
longtemps ça n'a tué que des animaux je
sais plus où c'était
en Ardèche peut-être je ne sais plus il
y a un an la communauté se retrouvera
Dieu merci les hommes des hommes ne sont
pas morts mais mais un jour un mal passé
vous savez mal passé frais justus ça
pourrait se reproduire et
parce qu'on investit plus parce qu'on
obéit à l'Union européenne parce qu'on
est dans l'Union européenne.
Revenons au cas Macron. Hm
hm.
Un coup il est à gauche, un coup il est
à droite, un coup il ferme, un coup il
crée, un coup bon c'est parce qu'il a
pas de clé de lecture, parce que il va
avec le vent,
parce que il sait pas où il va, il est
complètement perdu.
C'est à cause de c'est parce qu'il est
mal conseillé,
c'est parce que nos services ne lui font
pas remonter de la prospective
de la vision long terme circueil.
Ah si
assis quoi ?
Non moi je je n'aime pas trop. C'est
assez courant en ce moment de se
défausser sur les petits hommes gris.
C'est quoi les petits hommes gris ?
Les fonctionnaires. Les fonctionnaires,
tout ça.
Quand tu es le patron tuassume.
Ouais. Ouais. Puis attendez, on a des on
a des gens de qualité en France.
Si si on a des gens de qualité, on a des
on a des institutions, on a des
inspections générales, on a des
organismes qui font vous inquiétez pas
remonter tous les problèmes.
On a des comités théodules
aussi trop. C'est vrai. Ah oui, si on
parle d'économie, on peut en faire un
paquet. On a
après, on va s'occuper du
Hermes. Mais on a aussi Hermes.
Ouais. C'est comment il s'appelle notre
ancien ministre de l'économie ? et Bruno
le maire Hermes
mais on a aussi des gens qui travaillent
très remarquablement en France
et qui ont fait remonter tout ça c'est
alors OK
non non Macron non mais je vous suis
faire on va faire un dialogue.
Donc nos hommes grides, nos tout ça
super experts, il voit bien que le pays
va dans le mur. Il voit bien que ce
qu'ils font remonter, ça arrive dans une
oreille, ça ressort par l'autre. Ils
font quoi ces gens-là ? Ils sont
patriotes, ils démissionnent,
ils font comme les ambassadeurs, ils
font une pauvre petite lettre comme quoi
c'est pas bon quand même Macron pas
bien. Et puis non, ils font quoi ? Ils
font une manifestation, ils font une
grve de la fin, ils démissionnent.
Ouais,
ils se sacrifient pour la France. Oui,
mais
ils font quoi ?
Vous êtes marrant, ils peuvent pas tous
démissionner. Il faut bien qu'il faut
bien qu'il mange.
Faut bien qu'il mange.
Non, mais attendez, on peut demander à
des gens de démissionner quand on peut
assurer ses arrières. C'est pas si
simple.
Pour vous, imaginez, vous avez des
enfants, imaginez, vous avez une
famille,
vous vous sacrifiez vous et votre
famille pour le pays ou vous continuez
de manger, de faire manger votre famille
? Mais vous pouvez vous savez. Non,
c'est une vraie question que vous vous
posez hein.
Merci bien. C'est fait avec
Oui. Non mais elle est elle est elle est
très éthique très morale.
Non mais c'est parce que on est à la
veille d'une énorme guerre.
J'espère que non.
Comment ça vous espérez si ? On n pas là
pour espérer, on est là pour anticiper.
Oui mais j'ai assez confiance en
l'arrivée de Donald Trump au pouvoir.
D'accord. Non mais OK.
Oui.
OK.
J'espère que Trump déjà parle avec on va
prendre le cas suivant. Imaginez-vous,
mais je voudrais vous répondre quand
même sur Macron, c'est important votre
question.
Alors, je vous en prie.
Juste sur les fonctionnaires, vous savez
quand vous avez un choix moral éthique à
faire, je pense à des fonctionnaires de
Vichi, la collaboration et vous savez
qu'à la fin de votre décision, il y a
des gens qui partent dans un train et
qui meurent.
Ça ça porte un nom, ça non ? Les
bayonnettes intelligentes. Oui,
peut-être. Mais là
là vous avez si vous voulez
un choix moral éthique extrêmement lourd
à faire parce que vous avez la vie de
gens dans votre main
et là je peux pas me mettre à j'étais
pas de cette époque mais j'espère que
moi j'aurais démissionné à cette
époque-là et j'aurais pas participé à
cette horreur.
Je pense que j'aurais eu les ressources
d'humanité et de patriotisme
nécessaires. Mais je peux pas parler à
la place puisque je n'y étais pas. Mais
là, vous me parlez d'autre chose. Des
gens qui participent à un programme
énergétique défaillant pour la France,
ils peuvent aussi espérer avoir plus
d'influence s'il reste et peut-être
éviter le crash et peut-être faire en
sorte que des bonnes décisions soient
prises un peu plus tard. Donc je peux
comprendre aussi qu'il reste, ils font
pris pour des diplomates.
Pas fou.
Voilà.
Non, la responsabilité et de toute
façon, je n'aime pas ce principe de
déléguer la responsabilité. La
responsabilité c'est le chef.
C'était à Macron, à son gouvernement
d'anticiper les choses. Ils ont décidé
et Hollande avant parce que laure de
Faille m'a été décidé aussi avant.
Macron a poursuivi. On a décidé de
s'aborder l'industrie électronucléaire
française.
Qui aurait pu prédire
Oui.
Qui aurait pu prédire ? Phrase de
Macron.
Oui. Oui. C'est facile ça. Vous savez,
il y a aussi "J'assume." Quand vous avez
quelque chose de terrible à dire, vous
dites "J'assume" et ça passe. Non, ça
passe pas. C'est pas parce que vous
dites "J'assume que c'est mieux". Mais
ça c'est une technique, vous remarquerez
rhtorique très classique des macronistes
qui viennent me chercher.
Qui viennent me chercher. Euh
et là on a eu donc cette période là où
on a sacrifié le programme l'industrie
électronucléaire française.
On a par ailleurs et n'oublions pas nos
barrages hydroélectriques cédés à
l'Union européenne en investissant plus.
Je vais le rappeler parce qu' il y a ces
directives qui menacent de
privatisation.
Bah vous avez les ingrédients pour que
ça se passe mal en France et puis vous y
ajoutez le trè la trisème étape on reste
dans le marché européen électricité.
Alors même, Bruno Lemer, vous
retrouverez l'interview, elle est
toujours en ligne dans le Parisien
septembre
2021 ou 22, il déclare "Ce marché, il
est aberrant et il a deux adjectifs,
aberrant et délétaire, je sais plus ce
qu'il dit." Mais il reste. Mais on reste
et on y est toujours aujourd'hui. Nous
avons du pseudoréforme il y a un an qui
n'a absolument rien changé. On y est
toujours. Nous payons bien trop cher
notre électricité. La France devrait
payer bien moins cher son électricité.
Sous influence de l'Allemagne, nous
sommes restés dans ce système parce que
l'Allemagne avait tellement peur qu'on
ait un gain de compétitivité énorme par
rapport à son industrie parce que elle a
fait le choix idiot de quitter le
nucléaire. Nous, on n'a pas fait ce
choix mais tant pis pour elle. Et et
mais elle a peur qu'on ait un gain de
compétitivité et qu'on mette son
industrie à mal. Et donc elle nous a
emmené dans sa galère et nous on a
accepté. Elle
a réussi de nous planter
au nom de l'Union européenne et du coupe
franco-allemand. Et on se retrouve à on
est aujourd'hui.
L'Allemagne, c'est un peu l'ami qu'il
faut pas avoir.
Mais c'est Oui, c'est pas un ami, hein.
Elle elle avait essayé de nous planter
déjà
notre nucléaire. Elle essaie de nous
planter avec des grands sourire. Non,
bah l'Allemagne nous a planté sur le
mercure. Qui qui fonce sur le Mercosur ?
C'est l'Allemagne.
Parce qu'elle veut pouvoir vendre des
Mercedes en Amérique du Sud.
Exactement. On vend les voitures
allemandes et on sacrifie l'agriculture
française en échange.
Voiture, machine, outil, enfin tout ce
qui est allemand.
L'Allemagne nous a planté sur
l'élargissement déjà
l'Europe de l'Est. Vous savez qu'avant
l'élargissement, on avait un excédent
commercial avec cette zone d'un milliard
et demi par an. Aujourd'hui, on a un
déficit de 10 milliards parce que on a
financé nos délocalisations. On a filé
tellement de pognons à la Pologne, à la
Roumanie et on continue hein. La Pologne
chaque année, elle a 11 milliards de
cont de de d'apports nets par le budget
européen. 11 milliards par an.
Ils sont en face des Russes, faut
peut-être les aider. Oui oui. Puis on a
surtout les autoroutes russes, les
autoroutes polonaises pardon, les
autoroutes qui permettent ensuite et les
ronds-points qui permettent d'accueillir
nos usines. Je vous cit le Grand qui a
alors c'est pas la Pologne, c'est à la
Hongrie mais le Grand part aujourd'hui
de France pour aller en Hongrie. Puis on
peut citer la Bulgarie, la roumaniste.
Mais ça c'est l'Allemagne qui a voulu
faire venir son interland.
L'Allemagne nous a planté avec l'euro
là, la grande naïveté de Miteran qui dit
"J'accepte la réunification. En échange,
je leur prends leur marque.
Eh,
tu t'es fait avoir deux fois, tu as
accepté leur réunification et en
échange, tu leur as donné un grand
marque qui s'appelle l'euro qui est une
catastrophe pour nous
qui était bien pour eux parce que ça ça
dévaluait le marque sans le dire, qui
n'existait plus mais ça permettait
d'avoir une monnaie moins forte,
un peu moins et pour nous beaucoup trop
forte. Et puis vous savez, il y a un
problème structurel, j'en reviens à ce
que j'ai dis tout à l'heure, un pays qui
ne gère pas sa monnaie n'est pas un pays
libre. Voilà, c'est tout simple. C'est
tout bête. La première chose quand la
Tchécoslovaquie c'est c'est est devenue
la Tchéquie d'un côté République tchèque
et la Slovaquie de l'autre dans les
années 90. La première chose qu'ils ont
faite dans les de semaines, c'est
recréer deux monaies nationales. Et
d'ailleurs, ça s'est très bien passé
pour ceux qui sont paniqués du retour à
un nouveau franc. Il y a pas de panique
à avoir là-dessus. Ça se passera très
bien. Des pays et des unions monétaires
internationales, il y en a eu des
dizaines dans l'histoire, elles ont
toutes fini à chaque fois par
disparaître et on sait recréer des
monnaies nationales à Forceurie quand on
est la France qui quand même a eu son
franc, je le rappelle, pendant 700 ans
qui qui et qui est quand même qui reste
une puissance politique, diplomatique et
économique euh primordiale dans notre
monde. Voilà. Donc oui, l'Allemagne et
le couple franco-allemand, vous savez,
c'est une expression qui n'est utilisée
qu'en France, qui n'existe pas. en
Allemagne et aujourd'hui euh
nous sommes un pays qui paye trop cher
son énergie, donc qui est en train de
pousser son industrie à délocaliser, qui
en plus il a ajouté les sanctions
antires
qu'on a commencé avec la Crimée en 2014,
qu'on a aggravé à partir de 2022 qui
sont en fait une balle qu'on se tire
dans le pied voire dans la tête et donc
on est en train de payer encore plus
cher pour rien notre énergie, les
ménages et les entreprises. économie
indienne, c'est
on fait fonctionner Oui, parce qu'ils
achètent le pétrole, ils nous le
revendent quatre fois plus cher. On fait
fonctionner le gaz de chiste américain
en GNL qu'on importe bien.
C'est bon pour l'écologie.
Ah, on entend pas les écolos. On entend
pas les écolos. C'est c'est bizarre
d'ailleurs, on entend pas les écolos. Ni
sur le Merco on les entend pas trop dès
que ça touche aux intérêts fondamentaux,
la construction européenne, l'Union
européenne, la dépendance aux
États-Unis, les écolos terminé. Il a
plus rien.
C'est pour ça que j'appelle ça
l'escrologie. Moi je suis pour la vraie
écologie.
Yannick Jado, il a forcément dénoncé le
gaz de chiste américain.
Et ben, j'en suis pas certain. En tout
cas, sûrement à l'époque, mais pas
depuis 2022. Il faudrait au contraire
reprendre ces déclarations et vous
verrez que il dira probablement que
c'est un moindre mal parce que c'est
vrai qu'il faut quand même punir
Poutine. N'oubliez pas cette commissaire
européenne qui disait "Prenez des
douches froides et dans votre douche
vous crierez prends ça Poutine." Vous
souvenez de ça ? En prenant une douche
froide, vous crierez prend ça Poutine.
Parce que c'est vrai qu'en prenant une
douche froide, vous ferez du mal à
l'économie russe. Résultat, l'économie
russe aujourd'hui a une croissance
prévue cette année à 3,7 % et nous 1,1.
Merci Bruno Lemè qui devait mettre
l'économie russe à genoux.
Bon, vous parlez de Bruno Lemire,
c'est un excellent ministre des
finances, vous trouvez pas ? C'est pour
ça qu'il est devenu un excellent
professeur en Suisse,
excellemment accueilli par ses étudiants
d'ailleurs qui avaient hâte de
bénéficier de ses cours et de ses
lumière.
Payer
1000 milliards de dettes en 7 ans.
Bon, on enlève les 200 milliards du
Covid.
Non, moi je les enlève pas.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'on pouvait s'en passer.
Bon,
on était pas obligé de faire des
couvre-feu stupides, des confinements
débiles, des trucs qui coûtent super
cher.
Vous êtes pas vous vous étiez pas dans
les petits papiers des services de
renseignant pour savoir si c'était un
accident industriel qui allait équer la
séclever
40 % de votre matière grise quelle long
terme ? Je je caricature,
je vais vous dire, moi je suis très
tolérant. On s'accorde pour 200
milliards à
au bénéfice du doute.
Attendez. Non, je suis très tolérant sur
le premier mois. Je suis très tolérant
sur le premier mois. Je lui ai dit je ne
suis plus du tout tolérant ensuite parce
qu'ensuite on peut faire du parangonage
international
benchmarking diront les HC comme moi. On
peut faire du parangonage international.
C'estàd qu'on peut comparer
par rapport à des pays qui ont fait
différemment. À partir du moment où vous
pouvez comparer par rapport à des pays
qui n'ont pas confiné, qui n'ont pas
fait de passe, qui n'ont pas fait de
couvre-feu, qui n'ont pas fermé des
commerces un peu gentil avec cet
excellent ministre des finances.
Il ne l'est pas avec moi, j'ai aucune
raison de l'être avec lui.
On ne lui accorde les 200 milliards au
bénéfice du doute, on est d'accord
non ?
Donc 7 ans,
il a fait un peu de dette.
Beaucoup. Oh, pas trop quand même. Il a
rajouté que un tiers à la dette
française en 7 ans sur une fonction
exponentielle. C'est pas grave, j'essaie
de faire un peu d'humour parce que vous
comprenez, je comprends comme vous que
c'est quand même un scandale. Hm
hm.
Mais bon, il a acheté la paix sociale,
il a fait la startup nation,
il a renvoyé les gilets jaunes chez chez
eux, il a fait le bouclier tarifaire,
il a fait des choses bien, il a écrit
plein de bons livres.
Ouais. Dans un renflement
de création littéraire,
j'ai rien dit. Je n'ai pas dit de mot
enfonant. Il y a que moi qui ai le droit
de faire le clown ici.
Je fais pas le clown. Je fais pas le
clown. Non, je fais pas le clown.
Comment on va se s'en sortir de cette
merde ?
Alors sur les 1000 milliards, vous avez
aussi les 110 milliards de boucliers
énergétiques.
Parce que comme on ne quitte pas le
marché européen et qu'on fait les
sanctions antirusses, on fait des chèqus
qui d'ailleurs ne comblent pas toute la
hausse puisque ça com ça a quand même
augmenté mais ça coûte cher. On est on
fait un effort de guerre déguisé
et puis on le dit pas aux français que
c'est un effort de guerre. Oui, mais je
vais vous dire le problème de la dette
en général,
il y a toutes ces ces fautes qui sont
plus que des erreurs inadmissibles.
Mais il y a pas que ça. La principale
raison, enfin la principe principal
problème, c'est qu'on ne crée plus en
France. Vous savez, si on avait
une réindustrialisation française, si on
était un pays qui recréait de
l'industrie, qui recrée de la richesse,
qui recrée de l'innovation, qui avait
une agriculture prospère comme c'est
normalement le cas en France, hein. Nous
sommes un très très vieux et très grand
pays agricole. Quand j'étais encore au
collège, on nous apprenait que la France
était la deuxème puissance agricole
mondiale derrière les États-Unis.
Aujourd'hui, on a du mal à être 3e ou 4e
européen. Donc, si vous voulez
euh si et ça ça c'est de l'impact de de
vrais choix politiques, le choix de
l'euro, le choix du libre échange, le
choix de l'élargissement, le choix de de
du refus du patriotisme économique, de
l'interdiction même du patriotisme
économique ou agricole. Si nous créons
des richesses en France, la dette vous
la verriez même pas parce que vous
auriez un pays prospère qui crée donc
les gens accepteraient beaucoup plus
volontiers et facilement le consentement
à l'impôt. Vous pourriez payer des
impôts parce que vous auriez le
sentiment en face d'avoir des services
publics de qualité qu'on rénve, qu'on
entretient, des transports, de l'énergie
moins cher qui vient partout. Bon, la
France, cette France-là, on l'a connu,
mais on pourrait l'imaginer encore. Et
et vous voyez, et le principal problème
de la dette pesante, c'est ça
aujourd'hui, c'est que nous sommes un
pays qui ne crée plus. Notre part dans
le PIB du point de vue industriel est
passé en dessous de la Grèce. En dessous
de la Grèce.
Nous sommes un des pays de la révolution
industrielle. Comment est-ce possible ?
Donc, c'est ça qu'on doit remettre en
cause.
Vous posz une question très
intéressante.
Comment est-ce possible ? parce qu'on
crée plus de cerveau ou parce queon se
fait avoir de l'intérieur par des euh
gens euh pas très intelligent qui se
copte entre eux
parce qu'on met à la tête du pays des
gens qui n'ont pas le sens de l'intérêt
national.
Bah c'est les Français qui votent. Non,
on a les politiques qu'on mérite.
Oui, d'une certaine manière. Mais c'est
vrai.
Est-ce que la subordination de vote va
tuer la France ? Mais est-ce que le
choix
éclairé est offert aux français ?
C'est un tacle aux médias que vous vous
êtes en train de faire
au médias. Est-ce qu'ils font les débats
éclairés ? Est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que lors des élections
dernières que nous avons vécu, nous
avons eu des débats éclairés sur les
grands choix pour la France ? Moi, j'ai
pas le sentiment. Deuxièmement,
euh
c'est vrai que les Français n'ont
responsabilité, mais quand le
l'intégralité des candidats
officiellement autorisé à se présenter,
je reviens sur mes 500 signatures
puisqu'on connaît la prépondérance de
l'élection présidentielle en France. On
peut parler du reste, hein, mais c'est
pas l'élection régionale en France qui
va changer le cours des choses, hein.
Euh, quand on a un panel de proposition
qui n'est qu'en fait qu'un dégradé,
qu'un arc-en-ciel
du même une variation du même choix de
fond, ce que je disais moi pendant les
européennes, c'est que vous nous
proposez tous de rester dans la prison
européenne mais vous demandez de
repeindre les barreaux. Alors, vous
voulez repeindre le barreau en rouge,
vous en rose, vous en vert, vous en bleu
marine, vous en bleu reconquête, vous en
bleu Macron, vous en ce que vous voulez,
mais vous nous demandez simplement de
rester derrière les barreaux et de
repeindre les barreaux. Donc c'est ça le
problème. Mais vous savez, c'est une
constante de l'histoire de France.
La France malheureusement a tendance
dans son histoire
à s'abandonner assez vite et à tomber
dans les mains de gens de ce que le
général aura appelé les bourgeois des
enville. C'estàd des jouants qui pour
rester à la mode sont prêts à toutes les
compromissions. C'est toute la 4e
République est une triste République qui
est une République complètement sous
influence américaine où se sont succédés
des personnages faibles.
Euh je dis pas tous attention hein, il y
a toujours des gens d'exception mais qui
globalement n'avaient pas d'ambition
nationale. Et il y a eu le choc de 1958
le retour du général de Gaulle et il a
dû batailler tout chaque seconde chaque
minute de son mandat et de sa vie. Et ça
avait commencé en 40 à l'époque contre
Roosevelt qui ne l'a jamais aimé. Il a
dû batailler chaque seconde pour faire
vivre l'histoire d'une France
indépendante parce que ça n'a rien de
naturel. Quand la France s'abandonne,
elle est sous tutelle. Quand la France
s'abandonne, elle plonge peut-être plus
que d'autres pays. Parce que nous ne
sommes nous ne sommes pas fondés sur une
vision à la base ethnique du pays. Nous
ne sommes pas nous avons pas la vision
du folk allemand. Nous n'avons pas la
vision de la prédestination des pères
fondateurs américains. Nous sommes une
nation fondamentalement politique et
citoyenne. Et donc ça nous oblige à
avoir une vision politique et citoyenne.
Et quand vous n'avez pas à la tête du
pays une âme française profondément
attachée à la France, qui sent la
France, qui aime la France, qui connaît
la France, vous vous abandonnez très
vite et vous vous tombez très bas, très
très vite. Nous sommes un pays qui se
caractérise par de très très grandes de
très très grands sommets de très grand
très grandes fulgurances et des abandons
malheureusement très profond. C'est ça
l'histoire de France.
Vous avez f tourner votre
C'est pour ça que vous ne faites pas
vivre la France sans l'idée de grandeur.
Ça n'est pas possible. Vous ne faites
pas vivre le peuple français sans lui
promettre la grandeur.
Bon là on a plus nos colonies.
On est détesté un peu partout
parce que bon les déclarations de Macron
ça a pas aidé.
On va on va jamais se remettre.
Mais si.
Non. Mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour se remettre ?
Comment on se remettait en 40 ? Comment
on faisait ? Imaginez,
on faisait de la dette.
Comment on faisait ?
On a eu les Américains qui nous ont
aidé.
Non non non. Il y a un général qui est
parti à Londres. Il y a des résistants
en France qui ont commencé à résister.
Il y a des gens qui se comptaient au
début sur les doigts d'une main qui
l'ont rejoint.
Il y a des gens qui ont qui sont qui
dans l'empire à l'époque n'ont pas
décidé cette fatalité.
C'est ça l'histoire de France.
Est-ce qu'on se venge ?
On se venge de qui ?
De ceux qui nous ont mis dans la panade
ou est-ce que c'est une responsabilité
collective de tous les Français ? Vous
savez, le jour où on se redressera et je
suis sûr qu'il arrivera, c'estàdire
qu'on sera un pays indépendant
et qu'on retrouvera
bah le goût d'une politique nationale,
le sens de la France
et qu'on sera indépendant. Donc ça n'est
pas possible autrement. Donc quitter en
ayant quitté l'Union européenne, l'euro
en rebattant monnaie, en ayant de
nouveau des frontières économiques,
migratoires, commerciales, en ayant
quitté ces alliances militaires qui nous
obligent comme l'OTAN. Le jour où nous
serons de nouveau la France,
on aura d'abord œuvre à faire de
Concorde nationale
pour les
Donc on sera pas dans un esprit de
vengeance, dans un esprit de jugement
peut-être sûrement il le faudra parce
qu'il y a des gens qui devront payer
pour ce qu'ils ont fait un acte de haute
trahison supprimé de la Constitution.
D'ailleurs, je vous le rappelle par
Nicolas Sarkozi euh à mon avis, c'est
pas un hasard parce que en matière de
haute trahison, il se pose là.
Ça c'est gratuit ?
Non, c'est pas gratuit. Je vais
démontrer. Prêté de Lisbonne
2008,
c'est-à-dire aller contre le référendum
du 29 mai 2005. J'y étais hein, j'étais
un jeune militant du nom. Je je vous le
je vous rappelle ma première télé,
c'était sur ça. C'est dramatique, c'est
honteux et c'est une haute trahison.
la guerre de Libye
qui met à mal nos intérêts nationaux les
plus profonds, c'estàd notre sécurité
nationale. C'est une haute trahison pour
des raisons que la justice est en train
d'éclairer. Je ne sais pas mais enfin on
parle d'éventuell contrepartie entre un
financement de campagne électorale et
quelqu'un qu'il fallait ensuite éliminer
même s'il était chef d'état parce qu'il
en saurait un peu trop. Vendre 300
tonnes d'or
à ville prix lors de la France et des
Français.
faire revenir la France dans le
commandement intégré de l'OTAN et se
prétendre quand même gauliste à côté
parce qu'on est à l'UMP qui se dit
héritier des golistes la blague. Ça vous
en fait déjà quatre. Oh, je peux y
ajouter. C'est peut-être pas de la haute
trahison mais c'est de la très mauvaise
gestion. La RGPP qui a détruit largement
et l'hôpital s'en est toujours pas
remis. Nos certaines de nos préfectures
s'en sont toujours pas remis et cetera.
La révision générale des politiques
publiques qui a détruit une bonne partie
de l'appareil d'État supprimé 12000
policiers et gendarmes au moment où on
avait absolument pas besoin de le faire.
supprimer 54000 militaires au moment où
il fallait certainement pas le faire.
Moi c'est bon. Sarkozi, vous voyez, je
l'ai vu paradé récemment sur une autre
chaîne YouTube, je citerai pas.
Il avait un bracelet,
il faisait le beau. Pour moi, il fera
pas le beau devant moi. Pour moi, il
devra être en jugement cet homme parce
qu'il a trahi la France.
Il avait son petit bracelet
électronique.
Je sais pas. On n pas vu ses pieds.
L'immigration selon Florian Filippo, les
OQTF selon Florian Philippo,
on fait quoi ?
On les expulse. On les expulse pas.
Bien sûr, on applique la loi.
Au QTF, c'est obligation de quitter le
territoire français.
Mais si les pays euh les veulent pas, on
fait quoi ? Parce que si vous expulsez
des délinquants, les pays vont pas on
les récupère. C'est délinquant.
Alors, d'abord avant de les expulser, il
faut en accueillir moins. Beaucoup
moins.
Faut peut-être les mettre en prison
avant. Non,
attendez, déjà, il faut accueillir
beaucoup moins de monde.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'on peut pas se permettre
d'accueillir aujourd'hui 320000 titres
de séjour. Donc ça c'est l'immigration
légale.
On va payer comment nos retraite ?
Ah bah écoutez euh
alors attendez
vous voulez qu'on ouvre tous les tiroirs
? Parce qu'il y a plein de sujets là.
Vous me posez plein de sujets.
On va réarmer la démographie.
Il y a pas que ça.
La retraite pourquoi pourquoi on finance
pas la retraite aujourd'hui ? Parce
qu'on a du chômage et parce qu'on a pas
assez de création de richesse en France.
Vous vous réduiriez le chômage à 4 %
réel. Vous n'avez aucun problème de
retraite.
Mais mais on le réduit d'un coup de
baguette.
Mais non, on recrée l'industrie en
France.
Mais mais
mais comment se fait-il que toutes les
grandes
Non mais non mais non, il y a pas je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de plein de
choses extrêmement concrètes sur l'euro,
sur le patriotisme économique, sur le
protectionnisme, sur l'aide à nos
entrepreneurs. Je peux parler de sujets
extrêmement concrets, c'est pas du Yaka
Fauku. Mais comment se fait-il que ces
20 ou 30 dernières années, 20 dernières
années, toutes les grandes nouvelles
boîtes,
vous prenez les capitalisation
boursières, il y en a aucune qui est
créée en France et même pas dans l'Union
européenne, ce qui prouve qu'il y a un
problème structurel avec l'Union
européenne. Le
leas de la licorne en France,
ça reste quoi nos grandes boîtes
aujourd'hui ? Ben toujours les mêmes. On
a toujours LVMH, je les dénigre pas,
heureusement qu'ils sont là. Mais on a
LVMH, on a Total, on a EDF, on a Renault
Stellantis tenté que ce soit encore
français.
Technip
techni français.
Euh voilà quelques
Non, c'est même enfin c'est à moitié euh
même plus la pharge non voyez c'est
dramatique. Et puis surtout il y a rien
de nouveau sur les nouveaux secteurs. On
n pas créé et on ne peut pas créer dans
les conditions actuelles. De toute
façon, ça n'est pas possible. les
retraites.
Donc les retraites se perraent comme ça.
Et moi je suis pas du tout favorable à
ce qu'on mette les gens à 64 65 70 ans.
Je ne suis pas du tout favorable à ça.
D'autant qu'il y a une grande arnaque
actuellement, c'est nous dire "Mais
l'espérance de vie augmente ?" Mais non,
elle augmente plus l'espérance de vie.
Elle a commencé à baisser et l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé, elle est stable à
65 66 ans depuis 15 ans l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé. Donc on me fasse pas
croire cela. Donc et puis si vous voulez
qu'on parle de vrai gaspillage en
France,
on peut en parler mais c'est pas ce à
quoi on pense. C'est certainement pas
sur les retraites ou sur la santé des
gens qu'on peut faire de l'économie.
C'est sur plein d'autres gaspillages
qu'on peut en faire les
et je suis d'accord par ailleurs sur le
réarmement démographique parce que je
pense que l'avenir d'une nation c'est
évidemment de soutenir ses familles, de
soutenir la naissance, c'est soutenir sa
natalité, c'est de faire en sorte qu'on
crée une natalité, une démographie
robuste.
C'est elle s'appelle Priska Tvenu. Oui.
Oui. La porte-parole. Elle dit, elle dit
"Ah bah il faut réarmer la démographie
mais quand il y a pas de d'hôpitaux,
oui,
il y a pas de crèche, les écoles ça
devient compliqué
puis il y a pas d'espérance.
Et puis le logement, le prix du
logement, c'est pas mettre un peu la
charrue avant les bœ de faire c'est pas
des effets d'annonce encore ?
C'est verbal.
C'est verbal,
ça fait bien.
C'est verbiage.
C'est verbiage si vous voulez. C'est
c'est verbiage. C'est verbal. C'est
pipo.
C'est pipo pour dire trivialement. C'est
Pipo. Euh, j'ajoute à tout ce que vous
dites qui est parfaitement vrai,
notamment la question du logement à mon
avis est une un énorme sujet hein pour
les pour les familles. Évidemment, vous
allez pas avoir un enfant en plus. Si
vous avez pas une pièce en plus, c'est
compliqué. Vous
êtes propriétaire ?
Non.
Vous payez combien de loyers ?
Trop.
Combien ?
Je suis à Paris.
Quelle surface ?
Oh, je sais pas. J'ai combien ? 55 je
crois.
Euh,
j'ajoute une chose qui qui surclasse
tout ce que vous dites. Il manque de
l'espérance.
Vous cré Non mais vous faites pas
l'enfant si vous avez l'impression que
vous allez lui léguer un monde d'enfer
infernal.
Infernal.
C'est quoi le monde de demain ? La
guerre.
un monde
où il devra peut-être partir pour faire
ses études ou travailler parce qu'en
France on voit pas très bien où est
l'avenir industriel
où on se dit de plus en plus qu'en plus
ce qui nous restait de bien c'est par
exemple la bonne bouffe, la qualité,
l'alimentation locale, ça va être de
plus en plus remplacé par la malbouffe
qu'elle soit ukrainienne, brésilienne,
américaine, canadienne au choix ou les
insectes de Bill Gates ou la viande de
synthèse de Bill Gates.
un monde où vous allez à la moindre au
moindre virus, la moindre peur, au
moindre grand événement type Jio ou
autre. On va vous mettre sous passe, on
va vous demander un QR code, on va vous
demander de vous identifier en ligne
identité numérique. On va vous mettre un
fil à la pâte. On va vous surveiller. On
va vous mettre de la reconnaissance
faciale partout. On va vous dire de
remettre le masque dès que ça toussera
un peu trop dans les rues. Et vous
croyez que ça donne envie à quiconque de
fonder une famille, d'avoir un l'enfant
de plus qui permettrait de passer
peut-être au deuxème enfant et donc
s'approcher des 2,1 qui est le seuil de
renouvellement des générations et donc
peut-être qu'on en aura zéro ou un au
lieu d'en avoir deux ou trois et ça fait
toute la différence pour l'avenir d'une
nation.
Mais vous pouvez pas créer et vous ne
créez pas d'avenir et d'envie d'avoir un
enfant ou une famille dans ses
conditions. Vous ne pouvez pas.
L'humanité et la la France, les Français
en particulier sont désespérés
aujourd'hui.
Vous avez des enfants ?
Non.
Vous allez avoir des enfants ?
Non. Les
vous allez pas réarmer le pays ? Alors
non, je vais pas réarmer moi
démographiquement le pays. C'est vrai,
vous avez raison. Mais le euh Mais vous
savez, un responsable politique, il doit
aussi penser euh euh au-delà de sa
propre personne. Je crois
faut penser printemps.
Non, peut-être pas printemps. Mais il
faut Non, mais très sérieusement, je
pense qu'il faut être capable justement
de de penser
de voir les grands enjeux et et c'est
vrai que c'est un grand enjeu.
Ce que je vois en tout cas, voyez, même
si je suis pas concerné personnellement,
vous me direz ce que je vois en tout
cas, c'est que le monde actuellement, il
est bien triste
et que les Français aujourd'hui sont
particulièrement déprimés
et c'est je crois d'autant plus dur
parce qu'on il y a souvent des sondages,
c'est bizarre, c'est les Français les
plus déprimés de tous. Je pense que
c'est tout à notre honneur. Je
m'explique. Je pense que
vous allez adopter.
Non, non, attendez, je pense mais non,
j'ai pas de raison d'adopter. Il y a des
gens qui le feront, qui sont des couples
qui sont en attente d'adoption depuis
des années et ils ont bien plus de
raison de moi qu' que moi d'adopter et
ou plus d'envie. Euh
il y a des Français qui les Français
sont particulièrement déprimés parce que
nous sommes une nation particulièrement
politique et ça nous fait extrêmement
mal de voir ce que devient la France. Ça
nous fait extrêmement mal de voir que
la France est piétinée,
rapetissée,
humilié, qu'elle s'humilie elle-même par
une diplomatie qui est indigne, par une
incapacité à prener un discours de paix,
une incapacité même d'indignation par
rapport à des massacres qu'on voit, je
pense, au Moyen-Orient et et pas que au
Moyen-Orient.
Non, mais en ce moment, il y a cette
affaire à Gaza qui est quand même
épouvantable. Et la France, elle est où
? une affaire un génocide.
Oui, mais elle est où cette France qui
éit capable d'indignation et capable
surtout d'action derrière ? Parce que
indignation ça peut être beau mais il
faut derrière qu' l'action concrète.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi Macron il tortille
un peu du cul pour appeler un chat un
chat de ce qui se passe à Gaza ?
Ben il a pas de position sur enfin il en
a une franchement honnêtement
il pas de position il
bah non mais au tout début il était pour
une coalition internationale contre le
Hamas qui ne voulait rien dire. Il
confondait le Hamas avec Daesh et
ensuite il était euh et ensuite il a eu
ses mots contre Israël qui n'était qu'un
pays créé par une résolution de l'ONU.
Donc il a brusqué Israël. Ensuite il a
voulu s'excuser. Donc il a redit un un
truc dans l'autre sens et puis on
nexiste pas. Et puis quand nos gendarmes
ont été arrêtés euh mis à terre euh dans
les Léona là le un des quatre sites du
domaine national français en terre
sainte qui est quand même respecté tout
temps enfin depuis 150 ans par toutes
les autorités là-bas. On a quasiment, il
paraît qu'on devait protester, je sais
pas ce que ça a donné. Je crois qu'on a
convoqué l'ambassadeur et puis c'est
tout. Euh
c'est mais je vous le je vous redis la
base que sur l'Ukraine comme sur le
Moyen-Orient, comme sur d'autres sujets,
un protectorat n'a pas de diplomatie. Un
protectorat ne peut pas avoir de
diplomatie.
Donc il y a pas de mol.
Les États-Unis ont une diplomatie qui va
probablement d'ailleurs changer sur
certains sujets en janvier. La France ne
peut pas ne peut plus avoir de
diplomatie puisque nous n'avons pas les
instruments de la souveraineté. Vous
attendez quoi de Trump ?
Euh, j'attends je d'abord et avant tout
la paix sur l'Ukraine et la Russie.
C'est la première des choses parce que
ça nous concerne directement. J'attends
un combat pour la liberté d'expression.
J'attends la vérité sur ce qui s'est
passé avec le Covid.
Kennedy Junior, ministre de la santé. Ça
franchement ce qui va au bout de ce
qu'il a dit. Dans le pays où il y a la
première industrie pharmaceutique au
monde,
dans le pays où il a la première
industrie agroalimentaire au monde, si
Kennedy Junior met en place son
programme, il va aller face à des lobby
extraordinaires.
Il va avoir un accident.
Bah chez les Kennedy, ils ont
l'habitude. Vous me direz
comment vous avez vu la tentative
d'assassinat ?
Non, je lui souhaite pas vraiment pas.
Non, mais c'est très important
l'histoire de Kennedy Junior. C'est
c'est peut-être la nomination la plus
importante du du quinquena du comment on
dit 4 ans quadrena, je ne sais pas des 4
ans de Trump. Euh
il va mener une politique pour démasquer
la corruption immense de ce système-là
pour restaurer au mieux parce qu'il
pourra pas tout faire mais la santé
publique dans le pays quand même des
scandales sanitaires. Enfin pure du et
le l'oxyontin tout ça
cette épidémie
d'eau piacé
épouvantable 500000 morts aux États-Unis
beaucoup de jeunes et tout c'est les
États-Unis euh et puis sur le Covid tout
ce qu'on sait et puis la malbouffe les
additifs les pesticides dans la terre
dans l'eau. C'est un combat qui pour moi
est très important. Nous, on a fait une
grosse on a fait une une grosse
opération devant Bayern Monstau. On a
même avant bien avant que Kennedy Junior
soit nomé parce que pour nous le combat
du vivant, de l'eau, de l'alimentation,
de la santé sont des combats
gigantesques. Là, je vais vous dire là
on va être face à quelque chose de
phénoménal. Donc c'est ça que j'attends
de Trump.
Après, vous savez, je serai demain
président de la République
et Trump serait président face à moi aux
États-Unis. on aurait des sujets de
confrontation parce que je suis pour une
France parfaitement indépendante.
Cadriena, vous aviez raison. Euh
Cadriena, voilà.
Revenons, revenons euh euh à Trump. Hm
hm.
Vous avez écouté un peu les la
couverture des médias européens et des
médias français. Avant
c'était Haris s'était plié voire au
coude à coude.
Oui,
ils ont rien vu venir. On a vu les
astrologues de plateau télé défiler nous
faire des madames Yarma basé sur je ne
connais pas les chiffres du terrain. Je
ne sais pas ce qui se passe dans les
provinces américaines.
Je ne vois pas le wisme qui énerve
profondément les campagnes américaines
et ils sont retrouvés le bec dans l'eau.
Oui.
Comment vous jugez la couverture des
médias français et des médias européens
? Comment vous jugez
le fait que Trump est présenté comme le
nouvel Hitler, le nouveau dictateur ? Il
ne lâchera jamais le pouvoir ?
C'est normal, pas normal ? C'est des
médias,
c'est
c'est informé ou c'est milité ?
Est-ce qu'il y a encore un sujet, on va
dire important vous avez le sentiment
qu'elle est une variété de son cloches
dans les médias français ? Il y en a
pas.
Regardez sur le Covid, ils ont tous dit
la même chose. Regardez sur l'Europe,
ils disent tous la même chose. Regardez
même en 2005, le référendum déjà à
l'époque, ils appelaient tous, ils
faisaient tous campagne pour le Oui. Euh
sur Trump 2016, 2020 2024, ils disent
tous la même chose. Je suis désolé mais
sur l'Ukraine, ils disent tous la même
chose. Il y a plus aucune variété. Alors
ça s'explique par plein de choses.
L'homogénéité idéologique des
journalistes et sociologique surtout par
le financement et qui tient les
c'est pour ça que nos oligarques veulent
racheter une école de journalisme.
C'est pas très bon signe.
Moi je crois je vais vous dire vous
savez c'est pour avoir leurs militants
de leur côté parce que on a l'impression
que les écoles de journalisme forment
plutôt des militants que des que des
journalistes.
Non mais l'avenir à mon avis il est plus
là et ça a été une grande modernité de
la campagne de Trump c'est de faire
appel aux médias indépendants. Je vais
vous dire, regardez ici les discussions
queon a ce soir et que vous avez avec
tous vos invités. Ce sont des
discussions de fond et intelligentes.
Quoi qu'on pense des invités ? Ce sont
des discussions de fond et
intelligentes.
On essaie de vous comprendre.
Oui, je sais. Et on a des discussions et
avec tous vos invités sans exception, il
y en a que je vois que j'aime bien, il y
en a que j'aime pas. C'est pas le sujet,
on s'en fiche. Vous avez des discussions
de fond et utiles au débat démocratique.
Vous aimz pas lesquels ?
Il y en a que j'aime moins.
Lesquels ?
Dans ceux que vous avez eu récemment.
H
non je suis moins proche quoi.
Et vous les aimez pas pourquoi ? C'est
pas que je les aime pas d'ailleurs c'est
un mot un peu fort. Je suis moins
proche. Il y en a je suis plus ou moins
proche on va dire c'est tout.
Vous êtes plus proche de qui ? Vous êtes
moins proche de qui ?
Non c'est compliqué à dire mais je suis
Non vraiment parce que ça va ça ça
dépend des sujets
si on fait pas de la langue de bou.
Non mais par exemple avec de la marche
dans son
Olivier de la marche
Olivier de la marche dans sa dernière
intervention. Je suis assez d'accord
avec à peu près tout, je crois. Vous
voyez ? Alors, je sais qu'on a des
sujets par ailleurs de divergence sur
d'autres sujets,
mais euh je serais moins d'accord.
Vous avez Jean-Claude, c'est ça ? Jean
Covici, son prénom c'est
Jean Covici,
son prénom c'est quoi ?
Ah comment ?
Vous savez pas ?
Jean-Marc.
Mais oh
Jean-Marc Jeancovici
Roger, tu te calmes ?
Non. Jean-Marc Jeancovici. J'ai des
points d'accord sur le nucléaire et j'ai
des points de divergence.
sur lesquels ?
Bah par exemple, mais il l'a pas redit
chez vous, mais il l'a dit souvent
souvent dans les médias quand il dit il
faudrait limiter les gens à quatre
voyage en avion par vie, je suis pas
d'accord quand il met en cause les
animaux de compagnie parce que ça pollue
je suis pas d'accord.
Il est ingénieur, il a peut-être du mal
à s'exprimer
concernant concernant les cas de vols
par vie. Est-ce que vous avez essayé de
vous mettre à sa place
de comprendre pourquoi il dit ça ?
Ah mais j'ai entendu son raisonnement.
On essaie de comprendre pourquoi vous
dites frexit.
Oui, j'ai entendu son raisonnement.
Et donc vous avez essayé d'analyser sur
quoi il se base.
Oui. Oui. Non mais il parle de
l'empreinte écologique. Voilà.
L'empreinte climatique, tout ce que vous
voulez. on connaît euh c'est de la
restriction mais enfin dans le même
registre vous avez euh depuis les années
90 vous avez une école britannique et ça
a fait Florest depuis qui promo le passe
carbone. Quand vous allez faire vos
achats, on vous dira même elle sera
intégrée d'ailleurs à votre carte
bancaire ou à votre euro numérique hein.
C'est le prochain truc qui nous en est
ça. Je suis contre aussi. Euh on vous
dira bah non désolé vous avez déjà mangé
deux fois de la viande ce mois-ci. Vous
avez dépassé votre empreinte écologique,
vous avez fait trois enfants.
Voilà. Vous en plus vous avez trop
d'enfants, vous avez un chien, vous avez
un chat, euh vous avez pris euh l'avion
l'été dernier pour les vacances, euh
vous avez une voiture qui consomme trop
euh et cetera. Enfin, il y a vous avez
votre voisine nous a informé du fait que
vous aviez fait un barbecue le weekend
dernier.
Voilà. Donc c'est ça le passe carbone.
Donc et en fait c'est une logique de
crédit social derrière, c'est-à-dire de
notation du citoyen en fonction de ce
qui est considéré comme vertueux et non
plus légal. C'estàd qu'on on remplace la
vertu on remplace la loi par la vertu,
le droit par la vertu. Ce qui est ce qui
est très subjectif et ce qui
très dangereux peut-être
ce qui est extrêmement dangereux et ce
qui vous rend dépendant de la mode du
moment aussi. Mais
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des wok ? Donc
moi je je suis plus confiant que cela
dans la je donne aucune leçon à monsieur
Jean Kovici parce qu'il est très
connaisseur de son domaine mais je suis
plus confiant que lui dans la capacité
de l'être humain à innover pour dépasser
des limites qui nous paraissent
aujourd'hui indépassables.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des wook ?
Je les trouve extrêmement dangereux.
Pourquoi ?
C'est pas que drôle, c'est drôle souvent
mais c'est beaucoup plus que ça. Parce
que c'est une logique parce que c'est
une pensée totalitaire.
Vous savez dans le dans le wisme
qui alors ça vient en fait de France et
c'est le déconstructivisme
et ça ensuite je trouve jugé génial par
les campus américains dans les années 70
qui ont euh
qui ont maturé ça et qui ont qui ensuite
nous l'ont revendu en mode dégénéré. Et
donc le wisme euh vise à ne plus
choisir, à ne plus considérer que la
sélection, la bonne sélection se fait
selon la compétence ou la qualité de
l'être humain intrinsèquement universel.
En fait, ça ni l'universalité des gens.
C'est ça qui me fait extrêmement peur
là-dedans, c'est que vous êtes un homme
ou une femme. Vous êtes un homosexuel ou
un hétérosexuel. Et c'est même beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça puisque vous êtes,
il y a 50 nuances aujourd'hui de
sexualité. Si vous regardez les drapeaux
euh de de de du mouvement LGBTQ+ plus+
plus+ plus euh je suis déjà très
réducteur en disant homosexuel et
hétérosexuel. Vous êtes euh vous êtes
euh fait à descendre les
noir blanc jaune à moitié noir à moitié
blanc à moitié jaune à moitié rouge et
cetera ou pas. Et en fait vous n'êtes
plus du tout on vous reconnaît plus
votre universalité de citoyen capable.
Regardez, les walkist ont dit par
exemple, il faut que les noirs votent
Camalaris parce qu'elle est d'origine
euh indienne.
Indienne.
Donc vous avez des journalistes qui ne
comprenaient pas que des Américains de
couleur noire ne votent pas pour
Camalaris parce queils auraient dû et
voter pour elle naturellement.
Ils ont peut-être entendu parler. Alors
ça voilà, peut-être oui ou peut-être
qu'ils ont des idées politiques et des
convictions
comme tout le monde. Et vous voyez qu'en
fait à la fin vous dites "Il's sont où
les vrais racistes ?" B ils sont là. Ils
sont là les vrais racistes parce que
mettre les gens dans des cases en
permanence,
c'est à la fin vous qui niez
l'universalité de l'être humain
et c'est vous qui êtes un
communautariste et un raciste. Et ça va
très très loin parce qu'à la fin on vous
dit mais il faut déboulonner les
statuts, il faut canceller des gens
parce que il y a 300 ans, ils ont eu un
propos inapproprié qui est le terme
approprié en l'occurrence qui est
souvent utilisé faisant fit de toute
anachronisme et toute bêtise historique
de faire ce genre de raisonnement et
vous arrivez dans une société absolument
totalitaire. Vous n'avez pas le droit de
dire ça parce que ça passe à la pensée,
ça passe pas le crible de la pensée
totalitaire, de la police de la pensée.
Et vous vivez à la fin dans un camp de
redressement. Vous vivez plus dans un
pays, vous vivez dans un camp de
redressement. Donc le wisme fait
extrêmement peur. Je le trouve
extrêmement dangereux et je suis très
heureux que l'élection de Trump ait mis
un grand coup d'arrêt à tout ça aux
États-Unis.
Vous on vous met dans quelle case ?
On met dans la case ça dépend. Les gens
qui m'aiment ou qui m'aiment pas.
Qui vous aiment pas ? Euh ça on va me
dire euh extrême droite complotiste, euh
voilà
et les gens qui vous aiment
ou ça peut être d'autres qu'est-ce qu'on
peut me dire encore ? ou non, c'est
globalement sal qui revient le plus
souvent.
Les gens les gens qui vous aiment,
gaulistes, patriote souverainiste.
Bon, ça fait 3h 3 minutes qu'on est
ensem
je vais je vais pas le temps passer ici.
Mais vraiment
ouais, je vais vous poser quelques
questions internet.
Allons-y.
Après, puis après on va se mettre un
coup de beaujolet, c'est ça ? Avec
modération.
Ah oui oui, c'est la soirée beaujet.
Euh
comme si on était pas au courant et
qu'on ait pas bu un verre avant.
Euh moi, j'ai pas bu de beauelet, hein.
Non, pas du beau gelet, c'est bon. J'ai
bu une bière.
La bière nouvelle. La bière qui va bien
d'ailleurs. Euh question internet, on va
prendre
la première, je je retrouve pas la
première, mais je vais m'en rappeler de
tête.
Quelqu'un parlait de de
concernant dans la question parlait du
fait qu'elle était diabétique ou sa
fille sous insuline ou elle avait un
problème de comorbidité et elle disait
mais euh
est-ce que je dois assumer le fait des
gens qui portent pas de masque ou qui
sont pas vaccinés dans le domaine public
? Il fallait faire quoi ? Il fallait
mettre sous masque les ce ceux qui
avaient des des raisons de de d'être
infecté avec des risques très important
où il fallait mettre tout le monde sous
cloche,
il fallait voir avec son médecin. Non
mais attendez, je vais très simple.
Ce que je n'ai pas supporté c'est
l'obligation. Si cette personne estime
que mettre un masque c'est mieux pour
elle, je ne suis pas du tout pour
l'interdiction de mettre un masque. Je
suis contre l'obligation pour tout le
monde, ce qui n'a rien à voir. Alors
qu'elle soit parfaitement libre de
mettre un masque. Si son médecin estime
avec elle que c'est bien qu'elle se
fasse vacciner.
Moi, vu tout ce que je sais maintenant
sur ce produit, j'en suis
personnellement pas convaincu, mais je
ne suis pas médecin. Donc, elle verra
avec son médecin. Ce à quoi je peux
répondre de manière certaine,
c'est queelle n'a rien à craindre des
gens non vaccinés puisqu'on sait que le
vaccin n'empêche pas la transmission.
Donc ça ça a été si vous voulez c'était
la pierre angulaire du pass sanitaire et
du passe vaccinal, c'était de dire que
le vaccin empêchait la transmission ce
qui était un énorme mensonge. Et Delfi a
révélé qu'il avait dit tôt au
gouvernement, à Olivier Verrand, au
premier ministre que il n'empêchait pas
la transmission et pourtant ils ont fait
le pass sanitaire et le pass vaccinal.
sur euh l'obligation du masque partout.
Vous avez des études comme une étude
danoise qui a démontré que ça ne
changeait manifestement pas grand-chose
d'avoir ou pas le masque. Mais encore
une fois euh je suis contre l'obligation
pour tout le monde de le porter. Mais si
cette personne estime que c'est bien
pour elle et que son médecin l'a estimé
avec elle, pourquoi pas ? Moi, j'ai rien
à dire là-dessus.
Question internet qui est un commentaire
un peu rude. Se rend-t-il compte qu'il
parle avec assurance de choses qu'il ne
maîtrise pas ? Sérieusement, il s'en
rend compte.
Quand on voit qu'il confond climat et
météo, déjà on comprend que sa culture
scientifique est proche du néant. Il a
entendu parler du rapport du comité
d'éthique sur le protocole Raou qui a
été enterré par le CHU de Marseille.
Point d'interrogation.
Non mais j'ai entendu tout ça. J'ai
aussi entendu le fameux rapport du land
7 de mai 2020 qui dit que
l'hydroxychloroine
rapport auprès de 96000 patients qui
n'ont pas existé c'était super mal
c'était super mauvais et que l'OMS s'est
fondé sur ce rapport et qu'Olivier
Verron a tweeté dans l'heure en se
fondant sur ce rapport et qu'en fait ce
rapport a été retiré rétracté parce que
cit une énorme fraude avec une boîte qui
n'existait même pas. J'ai entendu
l'étude qui disait que le
l'hydroxychloroine
protocole Raoul avait tué 17000
personnes dans six pays européens études
de Lyon et qui finalement a été rétracté
le mois dernier. Donc j'entends tout ça
mais moi j'ai visité peut-être pas ce
monsieur moi j'ai visité l'IHU de
Marseille j'ai visité l'In Marseille
j'ai rencontré le professeur Raou
pendant 1hure et demi j'ai parlé avec
lui dans son bureau. Donc si c'était un
dingue, un douingue, un charlatan, je
pense que je m'en serais rendu compte et
surtout je pense qu'il aurait pas eu les
états de service qu'il a là parce que
vous devenez pas charlatan comme dirait
l'autre, vous vous inventez pas une
carrière de charlatan à 67 ans ou à 65
ans. Voyez professeur Raoul qu'on
s'intéresse à sa carrière au total et on
verra que c'est un homme qui a
découvert, qui a cherché, qui a trouvé,
qui a soigné et qui a continué de
soigner pendant tout le covid parce que
c'est bizarre qu'il y a eu aucune
plainte de patients contre lui alors
qu'il a vu passer des dizaines de
milliers de personnes dans son IHU.
Voilà. Donc euh alors je ne confonds pas
météo et climat mais je m'amuse et
parfois je titile les gens sur X parce
que ça m'amuse de voir leur surréaction
immédiate.
Ça sert peut-être tag à à rien de faire
ça. Ça excite peut-être les gens pour
rien.
Si si parce qu'il faut faire réfléchir
les gens, je vous assure.
Mais est-ce qu'on les fait réfléchir ?
Est-ce qu'on on les fait réfléchir en se
foutant de leur je pas de leur gueule
ou ou en les ostracisant ou les mettant
en boîte. Vous reprochiez au fax checker
de vous avoir catégorisé en tant que
vous savez ce que je fais quand ils
disent il fait chaud c'est le climat.
Les jours où il fait froid, c'est la
météo.
Parfois, on s'amuse à faire l'inverse
pour voir un peu comment ça réagit.
Voyez,
ça sert peut-être à rien.
Si il faut réfléchir un peu dans la vie.
C'est immature.
Non, non, non. Il faut vraiment que ces
gens-là remettent en cause aussi ce
qu'ils pensent être sûr et certain.
Qu'ils réfléchissent un tout petit peu.
Vous inquiétez pas, je les je les vexe
pas. Ils ont tout le système avec eux.
Ils ont tous les gouvernements, tous les
médias, tous les fa shakers, ils ont
tout le monde avec eux. Qu'est-ce que
vous pensez du réchauffement climatique
?
Bah, je pense que le réchauffement
climatique
euh
je pense qu'il faudrait que nous ayons
là-dessus euh
un débat qui dépasse les limites du JC.
Non, mais un débat avec qui ? Bah, par
exemple, vous avez une fondation
Florient Philippo qui va débattre sur le
club.
Non, vous avez une fondation de gens
beaucoup plus qualifiés que moi qui
s'appelle Clintel qui a été créée en
2019 au Pays-Bas. Si vous connaissez
peut-être pas mais vous regarderez sur
Google. C'est une fondation créée en
2019 au Pays-Bas
qui commence financé.
C'est 1952 euh enfin en tout cas ils ont
fait un appel en 2022 signé par 1952
chercheurs dont je crois 122 français
qui sont universitaires qui sont
scientifiques
financés comment ?
Bah c'est financé comme j'en sais rien.
C'est financé comme ça doit être
financé. Mais ça on peut se poser la
question pour tous les organismes vous
savez.
Nous on se pose la question pour tous
les organismes
mais il faut se la poser. Vous avez
raison. Mais souvent
financé comment vous
nous à 100 % par adhésion à adhésion
don. Il y a pas de des des financements
de de puissanceuse
et et agressive.
Il y a pas de valise de billets russes.
Non, il y a pas de rouble. Donc voyez,
il y a du dollar.
Ah non non, il y a du J'allais dire il y
a du franc. Non, il y a de l'euro. Il y
a non, il y a 100 % mais de toute façon
les comptes des partis politiques sont
en ligne hein. CNCCFP c'est légal, c'est
obligatoire et nous n'avons pas de
subvention publique. Donc on est à 100 %
par adhésion réadhésion don
on peut défiscaliser
et boutique pardon. Je peux ajouter pour
peut-être ça représente 0,5 % la
boutique
on peut défiscaliser chez vous
bien sûr au 2 tiers j'arrive tout le
monde d'ailleurs à adhérer vous vous
défiscaliserez au 23 de tiers
le le réchauffement climatique
oui donc qu'on ait un un débat serein
sur le sujet c'est tout voilà qu'on a un
débat serein sur le sujet
parce que derrière cela, ce qui
m'inquiète encore plus que le
réchauffement climatique c'est les
conséquences qu'on en tire derrière
si vous voulez l'Union européenne est
hystérique sur le sujet et on en arrive
la interdiction des ventes de de moteur
thermique pour les voitures à partir de
2035. les quartiers, les zones à faible
émission, les aidu qui sont en fait
issues de directives européennes dans
nos villes, la ville 15 minutes et
cetera qui sont quand même le passe
carbone, on en parlait des techniques de
plus en plus totalites. On en arrive à
ça et dans le même temps, la même Union
européenne vous signe des accords de
libre échange à tour de bras dont celui
qui serait les plus grand de l'histoire
du monde avec le mercur, ce serait le
plus grand accord de libre échange de
l'histoire de l'humanité qui sont eux de
manière sûre et certaine ultra pollue et
je parle pas que du climat parce que ce
qui me fait peur aussi dans le
réchauffement climatique c'est qu'on a
on a résumé toute l'écologie à ça.
Pendant ce tempslà, vous avez une
extinction de masse sur la faune,
biodiversité,
la biodiversité, la faune et la flore.
Vous avez la un océan, un continent de
plastique dans l'océan. Vous avez la
pollution terrible des terres, des sols,
des mers, des océans. Vous avez des
oiseaux qui disparaissent et cetera. Et
ça plus personne n'en parle parce que
100 % de la question écologique se
résume au climat. Donc remettons du
débat serein et arrêtons d'ailleurs
d'imposer des mesures totres aux gens.
Arrêtons déjà de libre échange.
Repensons le modèle économique et
agricole mondial et on verra qu'on
arrivera à faire des choses beaucoup
moins polluantes déjà.
Question simple. Est-il familier avec la
notion de méthode scientifique ? Point
interrogation, c'est une des premières
questions à lui poser. Tout son discours
dépend de ça ? Non, d'abord tout mon
discours dépend pas de cela parce que la
politique c'est pas ça. La politique
c'est des convictions.
Mais oui, je connais la méthode
scientifique. J'ai je j'ai pas fait
d'études enfin j'ai fait euh bac s si ça
l'amuse
scientifique
scientifique option math. Et j'ai fait
ensuite HC où il y avait des
mathématiques mais c'est vrai que
c'était pas des études de sciences en
soi. Mais oui, je suis très curieux.
D'ailleurs, j'aime beaucoup le les
sciences en général. Je suis passionné
par ce sujet-là, mais euh je ne sais pas
ce que ce que cette personne met
derrière parce que peut-être que c'est
une question tout à fait neutre et très
bienveillante. Peut-être que c'est une
question malveillante en disant euh
il va contre le consensus de la science.
Bah écoutez, sur le Covid, faisons le
bilan 3 ans après, 4 ans après, faisons
le bilan. Qui avait raison ? Qui nous a
vendu le vaccin efficace à 95 % ? Qui
nous a dit que le confinement ça allait
être génial ? qui nous a dit que
euh on allait pouvoir
euh arrêter la transmission du virus et
cetera, qui nous a dit qu'il y avait pas
d'effets secondaires, qui nous a dit que
ça venait forcément du pangolin et de la
chauve-souris et cetera. Et qui a dit
l'inverse ou a demandé en tout cas qu'on
doute ? Voilà. Et qui avait raison à la
fin ? Bah, je pense que ça répond à la
question. Et mettez-vous dans la peau du
gouver J'ai retrouvé la question
d'ailleurs que je voulais vous poser.
Mettez-vous à la place du gouvernant
h
qui se dit "Bon, on a une saloperie qui
se balade, ça met notre population à
risque,
on est dans une panade phénoménale,
h
on fait quoi ?"
Mais on était pas dans une panade
phénoménale.
Mais vous le saviez à l'époque ?
Mais non, mais ça je savais. On était
pas dans une panade phénoménale. C'est
pas vrai. À quel moment on a été dans
une panade phénoménale ? À la fin, on a
su que ça occupait 2 % des lits à
l'hôpital.
Est-ce que Est-ce que au début
et peut-être qu'on arrête de fermer des
lit, ce serait déjà pas mal. He
d'accord. Mais sur les séquel à long
terme, peut-être qu'ils sont au courant
de trucs que vous ne savez pas.
Bah, ils ont pas ils l'ont pas montré en
tout cas.
Ils voulaient peut-être pas créer la
panique.
Non, je suis pas certain qu'Olivier
Verrand a des aujourd'hui des
connaissances très supérieures à ce
qu'on a.
Il est neurologue lui.
Ce serait presque rassurant mais je
crois pas.
Il est neurologue chirurgien neurologue
?
Non, il est je sais pas ce qu'il est. Il
est médecin anesthésiste. Non. Aucune
idée.
Je sais pas, on avait un urologue qui
parlait souvent sur les plateaux télé
aussi. Belge.
Il est français. Vous êtes vilain.
Qui ça ?
Laurent Alexandre. Non, il est belge.
Il est naturalisé belge.
Ah, elle est peut-être franco-belge.
Alors
donc la question
mais il est pas il est urologue.
La question la question le détail de la
question il est
bah oui mais à ce moment-là
bah à ce à ce moment-là travaillons sur
les traitements. À ce moment-là
n'empêchez n'empêchons pas les médecins
euh de famille généralistes de voir
leurs patients. À ce moment-là, ne
fermons pas des lits à l'hôpital. À ce
moment-là, je veux dire travaillons
sereinement sur ce qui semble
fonctionner. à ce moment-là, envoyons
des missions scientifiques médicales
françaises dans les pays qui
fonctionnent. Je veux dire, c'est je
peux comprendre qu'il y a de la panique,
mais à ce moment-là, on fait des choses
rationnelles, pas irrationnel.
Quand notre ministre de la santé de
l'époque a essayé de prévenir Macron euh
dans ses confessions de bouquin, il est
neurologue. Euh
d'accord. Bon, il est neurologue. Busin,
vous avez lu son bouquin
Agnè Busin ? Non, je l'ai pas lu. J'ai
vu les interviews qu'elle a fait de
sur le fait qu'elle essayé d'appeler
Macron pour dire quand même bon. La
question que j'ai retrouvé c'est
je suis pas sûr que ce soit vrai he ce
signer je pense qu'elle se protège
après coup parce qu'elle l'a pas dit en
temps réel ça je vous savez il y a des
procès qui vont arriver à un moment vous
savez le médiator ça a mis du temps
tout ça ça met du temps.
Oui. Et malheureusement ça a mis du
temps mais ça n'a pas donné grandchose.
Mais à mon avis là comme il y aura une
pression vous savez pour eux pour tous
ces gens-là Kennedy Junior n'est pas une
bonne nouvelle hein parce que ça va
secouer sec aux États-Unis. Conseil de
défense, c'est secret défense 150 ans
50 ans je crois.
150 ans. C'est Sarkozi qui a prolongé le
secret défense. Alors il y a une
personne qui peut lever le secret
défense c'est le premier ministre.
Mais si on avait en France des
parlementaires d'opposition de qualité
depuis longtemps, on aurait une grosse
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
le Covid en France qu'on a pas eu. Ils
l'ont eu en Allemagne, ils l'ont eu au
Royaume-Uni, ils l'ont aux États-Unis.
Nous en France, on l'a pas parce que ça
n'intéresse manifestement aucun parti
politique d'opposition entre guillemets
de LFI RN. Je mets je ne cible personne
he LFI RN, LR, PS, PCF, Vert, tous ne
les intéresse manifestement pas comme le
Covid ne les a pas beaucoup intéressé en
temps réel mais il y a des pays où ça
les intéresse un peu plus et je vous
assure que Kennedy Junior, c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour eux parce que ça va
secouer sec là-bas et donc ça secoura
fort ici.
Je je je vous lis par respect pour la
question que j'avais posé de travers. B
bonjour. Ma fille est diabétique
insulinodépendante
et je suis asthmatique. Où s'arrête la
liberté de vouloir protéger ma famille,
vaccin et masque et où s'arrête celle de
ceux qui ne veulent être libre à se
balader dans la rue en mettant
potentiellement les autres en danger ?
Oui, mais je dis à ce monsieur que c'est
dommage qu'il croit encore ou cette dame
qu' qu'elle croit encore ce genre de
fable 4 ans après.
Voilà.
Question internet.
On n jamais mis personne en danger parce
qu'on était pas vacciné. Il faut arrêter
le délire
sur la transmission. Alors, il y avait
Non mais franchement sur la charge,
vous savez ce genre de raisonnement, ça
justifie toutes les dérives totalites.
Je je me fais pas le politique ici.
Vacciner la charge immunitaire d'immuner
deux fois plus vite que le non vacciné.
On est d'accord ou on n pas d'accord ?
Non.
En terme de propagation virale, quand
vous avez une charge immunitaire deux
fois moins importante, non. Non. OK.
Je me trompe peut-être he
mais non. Et d'autant qu'en plus on
avait pas le droit d'utiliser cet
argument puisque les les des personnes
qui avaient eu le Covid qui demandaient
à faire des tests en disant "J'ai
l'immunité, vérifier mes anticorps", on
leur répondait "C'est pas une bonne
méthode." Bon ben voilà.
Euh
ça c'est Robert Kennedy. Vous l'avez
déjà vous l'avez déjà bien abordé.
Ils sont très Covid les gens.
Non, c'est à mon avis votre communauté
qui est venue poser quelques questions
pour vous entendre répondre.
Considérez-vous que la justice est
laxiste et qu'il faut plus de sévérité
contre les voleurs point interrogation
contre les élus qui font du détournement
de fonds public interrogation.
Euh alors au-delà des élus, je pense que
la justice est globalement trop laxiste
en France. Oui. Contre la toute la
délinquence du quotidien, la
criminalité.
Bon ça je c'est un constat très partagé
mais très vrai hein. C'est inadmissible
que les gens après alors qu'ils ont un
casier judicière long comme le bras se
retrouve euh dans le bureau du juge et
ressortent une heure après. Ce qui n'est
pas une vue de l'esprit, c'est une
réalité en France et alors que dans
beaucoup de paysah vous êtes condamné
fermement et je peux vous assurer que
c'est un un caractère extrêmement
dissuasif. Alors derrière ça suppose
qu'on ait plus de place de prison, qu'on
qu'on expulse les délinquants étrangers
ou criminels étrangers qui représentent
à peu près 23 % aujourd'hui des des
places de prison. Et donc on puisse le
faire, c'est-à-dire qu'on quitte l'Union
européenne et la CDH parce
qu'aujourd'hui on n pas le droit de le
faire.
Vous prenez souvent un exemple les pays
nordiques dans les pays nordiques qui
ferment les prisons.
J'ai pas pris l'exemple des pays
nordiques parce que moi je les connais.
J'ai vécu au Danemark.
Où ça ?
À Copenhague.
Il y a de beau musée là-bas non ?
Oui, il y a de belles choses en général.
Il a Christian
la ville libre. Ah elle est très
attaquée par le gouvernement.
Pourquoi
ils veulent plus ? Ça me plaisait
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils avaient mis
au-dessus de Christiania
ici vous n'êtes plus dans l'Union
européenne. Ils avaient quitté l'Union
européenne symboliquement.
Après à l'intérieur c'est des
c'est c'est ça ça fume et cera c'est
Vous avez déjà fumé ?
Non.
Vous avez déjà pris des substances ?
Des drogues ? Non. Non. Non. Jamais.
Non. Jamais. Ah non. Jamais. Absolument.
Non. Jamais. Non. Non non. Ma drogue ma
vraie grosse drogue c'est le café.
Mais euh
leur Danemark, non, je prends pas comme
exemple parce que il y a beaucoup de
choses fausses qui sont racontées sur le
Moi je sais très bien tout cela. Enfin,
vous savez, un moment la Suède qui était
un petit paradis sur terre a ouvert
grand la l'immigration et ça a été la
catastrophe absolue. Euh moi je m'étais
baladé à Malmeux qui est la vide quand
vous traversez le pont.
On connaît bien.
Vous connaissez ?
Oui.
Quand on arrive en Suède, on arrive à
Malmeux. Moi, j'y étais allé quand
j'étais à Copenhag, donc en 2007 par là.
Le taux de suicide par habitant est
relativement important
mais c'était mais c'était très
sympathique et puis c'est
peut-être la dépression hivernale.
10 ans plus tard, c'est devenu une ville
où il y avait des agressions couteau
partout, des explosions de bombes
artisanales. Ça c'est devenu l'enfer
parce qu'ils ont ouvert grand les portes
et depuis ils ont remis une politique
plus restrictive tant qu'ils peuvent
parce que tant que vous êtes dans
Schengen, l'Union européenne et la CEDH,
vous pouvez pas faire grand-chose.
Et madame Mélonie est en train de se
rendre compte, elle fait rien. question
internet, il est plutôt team des murs et
des guns ou plutôt team il y a une
coopération qui nous sauvera ?
Je comprends pas la question.
OK. Vous êtes plutôt de l'équipe euh des
murs et des flingues des des pistolet
Ouais, gun, j'avais compris. Ouais.
Ou plutôt l'équipe, il y a que la
coopération qui nous sauvera
plutôt la première.
Parfois, il faut savoir coopérer, mais
il faut savoir aussi se défendre. Vous
êtes pour le port d'arme.
Ah non mais c'est pas la question.
Non non mais moi la question que je la
comprends en mode pour un état, est-ce
qu'il faut être capable d'avoir des
muscles, de s'imposer et de se faire
entendre ? Je pense que c'est la raison
même c'est c'est la condition pour qu'un
état persiste et existe. Que si on ne
défend pas sa nation, personne ne le
fera à sa place à notre place. personne.
Après, ça n'empêche qu'il faut savoir
aussi quand c'est nécessaire et utile
coopérer et surtout il faut avoir des
relations, des un maximum de Moi, je
suis un homme très paisible. Je souhaite
que la France défende ses intérêts
nationaux et la paix. Et la paix
c'est c'est c'est facile d'avoir de la
paix quand les ressources se rarifient,
que on est en train de se battre pour
les dernières parts du gâteau de la
mondialisation.
Je suis pas sûr qu'aujourd'h premier
facteur de guerre pour nous.
pas pour nous. Aujourd'hui, le premier
facteur de guerre, c'est qu'on est
entraîné dans des guerres qui ne sont
pas les nôtres.
Quand nous sommes aujourd'hqués dans des
alliances militaire comme l'OTAN et
surtout une subordination politique aux
États-Unis, nous sommes embarqués de
fête dans des guerres qui ne sont pas
les nôtres et avec toutes les
répercussions derrière parce que vous
savez casser la figure de certains pays,
on parlait de l'immigration, c'est aussi
une des causes majeures des départs
migratoires vers chez vous. Ensuite,
c'est que vous cassez un pays, bah
ensuite vous ouvrez la porte.
Donc il faut voir la cohérence globale
de toute cette politique et aujourd'hui
la politique de la France n'est pas une
politique qui défend notre intérêt
national et c'est pas une politique qui
défend la paix.
Question internet. Que répond-t-il à
ceux qui lui disent "Mon bon monsieur ?
La France est trop petite face à la
Chine ensemble on est plus fort."
C'est tout ce qu'on m'a appris quand
j'étais en
en
école primaire. L'union fait la force.
Tout ça c'est toujours, j'imagine ce qui
a appris aux enfants de France
aujourd'hui, c'est du bourrage de crâne.
Je pense que dans la mondialisation, la
première qualité des nations, c'est
l'agileté.
Être capable de prendre une bonne
décision au bon moment, rapidement, de
s'adapter. Alors, je vais répondre
concrètement. La Suisse négocie seul son
commerce,
négocie ses traités commerciaux.
Elle négocie bien mieux que nous parce
qu'elle sait quels sont ses intérêts
nationaux et qu'elle est une nation
homogène et cohérente. Point barre. Je
peux dire la même chose du Canada. La
gent Canada c'est énorme. Non, le Canada
c'est 35 millions 38 millions
d'habitants et c'est 2 ti3 du PIB de la
France. C'est plus petit que la France.
Pourtant ils négocient seul vous savez,
ils ont négocié le CTA avec nous à cor
Union européenne Canada. Qui a gagné le
CTA ? Le Canada. C'est incroyable. On
pourrait dire il y a 500 millions d'un
côté, 38 millions de l'autre. PIB de
énorme, PIB petit. Pourtant, c'est le
Canada qui a gagné. Pourquoi ? Mais
c'est logique. Quand vous arrive seul à
la table de négociation mais que vous
savez quel est votre intérêt national,
vous gagnez. Vous savez comment la
Suisse gère son agriculture ? Pas la
Pâque, hein. La Suisse toutes les
semaines décide, on peut le faire
informatiquement facilement aujourd'hui.
Les agriculteurs de Suisse rentrent un
petit code, ils disent "Voilà, j'ai
produit tant et cetera." Donc le système
suisse au niveau national confédéral
là-bas instantanément de quoi il a
besoin et pas besoin chaque semaine. Si
on produit trop de salade, on importe
pas de salade. Si on produit pas assez
de carottes, on importe des carottes. Et
ben ça fonctionne magnifiquement. Et
aujourd'hui, un un je parle même pas des
agriculteurs, un employé agricole en
moyenne en Suisse, il gagne 4500 francs
suisse par mois. C'està-dire à peu près
4500 €. un employé agricole, pas un
agriculteur parce que c'est un système
prospère. Pourtant la Suisse, c'est quoi
? C'est 10 millions d'habitants 9
millions.
C'est plus petit que la France à tout
point de vue.
Ça vaut combien un Big Mac en Suisse ?
Hein ?
Un Big Mac ?
Ah oui, l'indice Big Mac là.
Ça vaut combien une peinte de bière en
Suisse ?
Euh je sais pas, ça fait très longtemps
que je suis pas allé en Suisse.
Question internet. Avez-vous déjà fait
une erreur ? Si oui, avez-vous eu du mal
à la reconnaître publiquement ? J'en ai
fait plein des erreurs.
Un Big Mac en Suisse, c'est 7,59 €.
Et en France, c'est combien ?
Il va chercher. E euh
c'est le menu ou c'est le Big Mac ?
Pas pas
parce que Tiens tiens question.
C'est le Maxi Best of
Tu me bien vu. On va pas fast food,
ça nous donne faim. On a un peu faim.
Euh 5,40 €
en France. Donc oui, bah c'est normal.
Oui. Bah oui, ils sont plus riches que
nous. beaucoup plus riche que nous. Puis
ils ont le ils ont les votations, c'est
formidable ça.
Mais c'est pas une question, c'est un
commentaire du petit Arnaud qui est
perdu dans le supermarché. Le Conseil
d'État a quand même validé le
Rassemblement national comme partie
d'extrême droite. Donc c'est faux de
dire le contraire.
Mais je suis pas au RN moi.
Puis vous croyez que je prends mes
analyses politiques au Conseil d'état ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
Je me fiche de ce que pense le conseil
des
question internet que que Ouais,
d'accord. Que pense-t-il de la politique
de Ravier Miley ? Ah, eu liberté euh
Oui, c'est ça euh avec la tronçonneuse
là. Euh ça m'a l'air fantasque.
Si s'appelait
Argentin, tant mieux pour lui, hein.
Tant mieux pour eux. On verra sur pièce.
Je suis pas à la fan je je suis pas à la
base très fan si vous voulez.
Euh
voilà, je suis très attaché à la liberté
mais je pense que c'est très très très
loin de la tradition française tout ça.
Question internet. Monsieur Philippo,
voit-il le souverainisme comme une
opportunité pour aborder les problèmes
écologiques des années à venir ou bien
est-ce un domaine où l'Union européenne
a du sens ? Non, je pense que
effectivement le souverainisme c'est par
définition écolo. Je pense que le
patriotisme est par définition
écologique parce que c'est le domaine du
local, c'est le domaine du proche, c'est
le domaine de la du circuit court. Donc
c'est totalement pour moi la vraie
écologie. l'Union européenne qui est la
grosse machine héritée des années 50, la
technure centralisée à Bruxelles. Pour
moi, c'est c'est dépassé, c'est obsolète
et ça n'a rien d'écolo puisqueen plus
c'est une structure qui étant hors
contrôle démocratique est infestée par
les lobby et les lobby par définition
sont plutôt plutôt pollue que pas pollue
hein. C'est assez logique. L'hobie
chimique, lobby agricole agrochimique,
lobby pharmaceutique, c'est plutôt des
domaines extrêmement pollue que plutôt
que pas pollue Tommy qui vous met au
défi.
Pensez contre vous-même. Hm
hm.
Quelles sont les conséquences négatives
d'une sortie de l'Union européenne ?
Hm
honnêtement. Euh j'ai pas envie de faire
une réponse convenue, mais je suis
désolé mais
je je ça sera beaucoup de travail si
c'est ça qui fait peur aux gens. Oui, il
y aura beaucoup de travail.
On va remettre des gens au travail parce
qu'il va falloir négocier des accords
bilatéraux alors qu'on avait l'habitude
d'appuyer sur un bouton et puis ça se
faisait mais contre nos intérêts. Donc
oui, il y a des gens qui vont devoir
retravailler beaucoup plus mais
honnêtement
je n'y vois vraiment que les intérêts.
Euh question internet. Peut-il nous
expliquer pourquoi en 2005 il était
contre la Constitution européenne ?
Qu'avait-il lu interpréter entre les
lignes ? J'avais tout lu euh Ah non mais
moi la campagne de 2005, je peux vous
dire, je l'ai faite refaite et archiite.
J'étais toutes les nuits euh en train de
coller mes petites affiches que je
faisais moi-même. Euh vous savez,
j'avais fait un blog, on mettait des
tractes à disposition. Un jour, je sors
d'un métro et rue de Ren d'ailleurs et
je sors du métro et je vois un type qui
me distribue mon tract qu'il avait
imprimé sur internet. Donc là, je me
suis dit ça circule quoi. Pas reconnu,
mais
j'étais personne me connaissait. 2005,
j'étais étudiant HC. Question internet
s'il est élu en sorte
Non mais j'ai fait vous savez que j'ai
fait tous les meetings en 2005 j'ai fait
Deux Liers j'ai fait Mélenchon, j'ai
fait Marie-Georgees Buffet Nicolas
Lupignan j'ai fait tous ceux qui
existaient en 2005 pour le nom
question j'étais à fond pour le nom le
soir du nom j'étais dans le bunker de la
safresse. J'ai su le nom avant Chiraak.
Ça ça vous intéresse pas ? Alors je
viens de vous donner un scoop. J'ai su
le nom avant le président de la
République parce que j'étais devant
l'écran où est tombé le nom par les bul
les bureaux de test de la SFresse parce
que je je viens jeuner de faire un stage
à la SFresse et j'ai vu le nom arriver.
Au bout de quatre bureaux de vote, on
était en bonne réalité statistique, ça
convergeit vers un. Donc on savait que
notre échantillon au bout de quatre
bureaux était déjà représentatif. C'est
moi qui avais constitué le le le
l'échantillon de bureau de votre test.
Et donc ensuite on appelait le SIG,
service d'information du gouvernement
qui appelait l'Élysée pour annoncer les
les résultats. Donc j'ai su très très
tôt que le nom avait gagné et j'ai
débouché le champagne.
Question internet. S'il est élu alors en
tant que président de la République, je
pense h
on sort de l'Union européenne à quelle
échéance ? 1 mois 6 mois ? Comment on
garde la confiance des marchés et autres
pays pour ne pas se faire sabrer par
notre dette ? Comment on a introduit
notre nouvelle monnaie ?
Alors ça c'est assez simple. Nous allons
signifier à Bruxelles en conformément à
l'article 50 du traité européen que nous
quittons l'Union européenne. Nous avons
la possibilité de négocier un accord de
sortie.
En plus nous on a le précédent du
Brexit, donc on peut voir les pièges, on
peut voir ce qui a fonctionné, pas
fonctionné. Donc on va en tirer de
l'enseignement, on va le faire bien on
aura en plus préparé les choses et euh
nous ne serons pas attaqué par les
marchés parce que je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui les marchés n'ont pas
confiance, de moins en moins confiance
dans l'Union européenne et dans l'euro.
C'est aujourd'hui que nous sommes
attaqués.
La dette de la France, elle est à
combien là ?
Elle est à 3200 milliards.
Et la note de la France, elle est à
combien ? Ça dépend des des agences,
mais elle s'est elle s'est dégradée.
Oui, on a perdu la première fois le
triple A en 2012, il me semble, mais on
l'avait toujours avant, mais elle se
dégrade. Mais euh ce qui est la preuve
que rester dans l'euro et l'Union
européenne n'est pas gage d'une note au
plafond. Donc, nous allons euh montrer
qu'on a un avenir économique,
industriel, agricole. On va le
démontrer. Ce qui donne confiance, ce
qui donne confiance dans notre dette, ce
qui donne confiance dans notre monnaie.
Et et là-dessus, j'ai envie de rassurer
tout le monde, ne tombez pas dans les
manipulations du projet peur, ce qu'on
appelle le Fear Project au Royaume-Uni,
c'est ceux qui agitent la peur pour
faire en sorte que jamais rien ne
change. N'ayez pas peur. Ah, je vais pas
paraphraser un pape célèbre, mais
honnêtement, n'ayez pas peur parce que
les gens qui vous demandent Oui, tout à
fait. Les gens qui vous demandent de ne
pas avoir peur sont des gens qui veulent
juste que vous préserviez leurs intérêts
à eux, pas les vôtres, les leurs.
Vous avez un ami imaginaire ?
Non.
Vous croyez pas en Dieu ? Si je crois en
Dieu, mais c'est pas un ami imaginaire.
C'est quoi alors
un ami imaginaire ? Ça me fait penser à
un film effrayant d'un petit garçon qui
voit les fantômes et qui ensuite se fait
massacrer par un fantôme.
Ça s'appelait comment ce film ?
Bon, il y en a plein.
Mais
il y a plein de films américains comme
ça. Vous avez jamais vu des films un peu
de terreur américain où au début on voit
dans une les parents aménagent dans une
grande maison et on voit le fils qui
parle dans sa chambre et en fait la nuit
non. Vous avez des terreurs nocturnes.
C'est pour ça que j'ai pensé à ça quand
vous m'avez dit ça. Je me suis dit je
suis pas du tout là-dedans.
D'accord. Vous vous croyez en Dieu ?
Oui. Voilà. Je crois en Dieu. Oui. Oui.
Je suis catholique.
Vous priez ?
Euh oui.
Quand je vous dis ami imaginaire, vous
comprenez la boutade.
Oui. Oui. Mais pour moi, c'est pas le
mot approprié pour Dieu
depuis longtemps. C'est une révélation ?
Non, j'ai été élevé. Je suis allé au
catéchisme,
communion, confirmation.
Vous me direz c'est pas un gage de j'ai
pas je suis pas très pratiquant pour le
coup. J'ai plus de problèmes aujourd'hui
avec l'église qu'avec qu'avec le Christ.
Question internet. Si on peut rester sur
l'écologie, votre invité connaît-il le
rapport Midos de 1972 ? Qu'en pensent-il
? Que ferait-il pour amortir la chute
des courbes de prédiction ?
Non, je suis désolé, ça me dépasse. Je
vais pas faire croire que je connais. Je
connais pas.
On arrive à la fin, il y a 25000
questions, je peux pas toutes les poser.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Vous pouvez nous conseiller trois livres
à lire ou trois livres qui ont été
importants pour vous ?
Oui. Euh
alors, sans surprise, mais pour moi
c'est tellement fondamental. Les
mémoires de guerre et d'espoir du
général de Gaulle, il faut les lire.
D'abord, c'est magnifiquement écrit,
c'est ce qu'on sait trop peu du général
de Gaulle. Vous savez qu'il a écrit une
pièce de théâtre quand il avait 15 ans
où il était généralissime
et il allait sauver le l'Europe de la
l'invasion russe
dans une guerre. Non, c'éit pas
l'invasion russe mais je sais plus par
rapport à qui mais ou peut-être. Mais
c'était en tout cas à la fois un peu
prémonitoire même si il a pas été
généralissime pendant la guerre mais il
a été mais et cette surtout ce que je
voulais dire c'est que vous lisez cette
pièce écrite quand il avait 15 ans.
C'est incroyable. Le style est
extraordinaire. Bon, le style des
mémoires est extraordinaire et puis
c'est ça apprend tellement de choses sur
l'histoire de France que il faut de mon
point de vue absolument les avoir lu.
Euh un livre que je recommande, alors on
a parlé beaucoup du Covid à ce
moment-là, je vais citer Pierre
Chaillot, statisticien sur euh ce que
disent les chiffres officiels du Covid.
Ça doit être à peu près ça le titre qui
est un vrai statisticien qui a pris que
les chiffres officiels et qui les a
vraiment mis en perspective et il nous
offre une autre lecture de cette
affaire.
Et dans ce livre, il y a il y a les
séquels neurologiques sur une étude à
grande échelle.
Il y a il y a pas encore énormément tout
cela parce que c'est il est sorti il y a
je crois un peu plus d'un an mais c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai sujet. Et puis le
squel du de l'injection he du vaccin,
c'est quand même le sujet principal
aujourd'hui je crois.
Et troisièmement, un livre que j'ai
trouvé moi je l'ai dévoré en quasiment
une nuit, c'est l'ami l'ami nos amis
l'ami américain je crois s'appelle de
Eric Branca euh qui explique en 30 ans
de gaulisme 40 70 1940 1970 comment
euh euh voilà de Gaul enfin de Gaul a dû
batailler en permanence contre il avait
aussi des vrais amis américains mais il
a dû quand même globalement batailler
pour asseoir la France par rapport aux
États-Unis. qui sont beaucoup plus un
pays qui nous fait du mal qu'on le
croit. Quand Mitéran déclare les
Français sont en guerre et face aux
Américains, ils ne le savent pas et
c'est toujours vrai aujourd'hui. Sauf
que le problème c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui des dirigeants qui sont les
amis de nos ennemis.
Est-ce que vous avez un Il y a plein de
questions, c'est dingue.
Vous intriguez les les gens.
Ah bon ?
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable.
Très simple, soyez des esprits libres et
courageux. C'est tout.
C'est le plus important et ça manque
beaucoup aujourd'hui. Beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup.
Libre et courageux.
Floriant Philippo. Merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]